très bien mes chers mes chers collègues
nous allons poursuivre l'examen donc du
texte du projet de loi de financement
rectification de la sécurité sociale
pour
2023 et donc comme d'habitude je vais
vous donner les informations très
importantes à savoir nous avons donc
examiné 348 amendements depuis lundi et
il nous reste donc 5000 51 amendements a
terminé d'ici
384 pardon j'ai dit moins à 48 oui alors
384 excusez-moi et il nous reste donc
plus que 5000 51 amendements à examiner
d'ici ce soir 20h
alors
nous allons donc pouvoir accélérer
alors nous poursuivons avec
l'amendement
[Musique]
5968 et qui le défend madame
vous avez la parole madame la
description madame la Présidente vient
nous sommes quittés tout à l'heure en
déjà en faisant la liste longue comme le
bras de toutes les pistes de financement
alternatif qui avait été proposé par la
nupes nous avons continué dans ce
festival donc de pistes de financement
alternatif qui permettrait d'équilibrer
facilement le solde des régimes de
retraite dont le déficit est limité je
le rappelle parce que certains nous nous
feraient penser qu'il est illimité et
insurmontable alors qu'il est limité sur
mon table entre 0,4 et 08 points de PIB
en 2030 avec un retour à l'équilibre en
2070 donc il nous faut trouver les
solutions conjoncturelles en voilà une
nouvelle avec cet amendement qui vise à
remettre en place la contribution
additionnelle de solidarité à la taxe
sur les salaires pour les
rémunération en l'affectant à la caisse
nationale vieillesse plus précisément la
tranche supérieure des rémunérations des
passants les 160
000 euros voilà c'est quand même bien
costume se trouverait prélevé à hauteur
de 20 %. donc voilà encore une
proposition de justice pour résoudre ce
problème temporaire de financement de
nos retraites
bien Madame la rapporteur votre avis oui
merci madame la Présidente c'est un avis
défavorable je voudrais vous faire vous
alerter peut-être parce que je suis pas
sûr que c'était le sens que vous lui ai
donné à votre amendement mais cette taxe
s'applique aussi à l'hôpital public donc
diminuerait le budget de l'hôpital
public elle s'applique aussi à des
organismes coopératifs mutualistes et
professionnels agricoles
très bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté
amendement suivant alors amendement
identique monsieur Petavy vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente donc
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
corriger les inégalités grimpantes que
l'arrivée de la retraite sanctuarise en
proposant une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les fonds de pension
dont le produit serait affecté à la
Caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
alors d'un côté il y a ceux qui peuvent
se permettre de mettre de côté pour
s'assurer une retraite correcte de
l'autre il y a ceux et surtout celle qui
ont subi toute leur vie professionnelle
et qui loin d'avoir un repos bien mérité
devront subir à nouveau
arrivé à la retraite cette proposition
de contribution exceptionnelle sur les
fonds de pension est une proposition
pour remettre un peu de justice sociale
dans ce projet de loi qui fera payer le
prix fort au plus vulnérable nous
remettons nous ne remettons pas en cause
le principe contributif qui est le socle
de notre système de retraite mais nous
disons que ce n'est pas au plus précaire
de payer la facture
très bien amendement suivant madame
Rousseau merci madame la Présidente en
fait là on touche un sujet qui est très
important puisque la capitalisation en
France atteint 16 milliards d'euros et
en fait cette capitalisation les gens
épargnent pour leur propre retraite
future mais elle est en attendant placée
sur des fonds qui par ailleurs sont
utilisés souvent sur des industries et
des investissements extrêmement
polluants ça a été montré par de
multiples rapports et donc en fait ça
fait partie de ces conditionnalités des
aides et des soutiens et là en
l'occurrence on vous propose de d'avoir
une fiscalité sur cette sur cette
épargne par capitalisation et sur ces
fonds de pension parce que
une autre chose que l'on ne sait peu sur
les fonds de pension mais qui est
pourtant décisives c'est qu'ils imposent
aussi par les placements de masques ils
font sur les marchés financiers des taux
de rendement qui derrière obligent
certaines entreprises si ce n'est
beaucoup à délocaliser une partie de
leur de leurs activités et donc en fait
en fait c'est fond de pension qui se
sont massivement développées après les
années 70 et bien ont un rôle majeur
dans la financiarisation de notre
économie mais aussi dans le soutien
d'activité polluantes donc nous vous
proposons de d'avoir une contribution
exceptionnelle sur ses fonds de pension
très bien Madame la Députée amendement
suivant madame Guérin oui allez-y
[Musique]
j'y vais
merci madame la Présidente alors sur les
fonds de pension je vais vous citer une
petite phrase tu comptes sur l'état pour
payer ta retraite respire profondément
et bien vite tester notre simulateur sur
les réseaux sociaux depuis l'annonce de
la réforme des retraites il y a un
secteur qui s'affole c'est le fond de
pension à la française papi et c'est
l'un des plus actifs donc sur Instagram
il promet qu'en plaçant 96000 euros le
futur retraité pourrait toucher 200 000
288 637 euros preuve que la
capitalisation fait un retour en force
le site Capital.fr estimant que la
réforme pourrait faire évoluer le
montant de la pension pas toujours
favorablement je cite engage les
salariés à anticiper et à épargner dans
cette optique et donc ce site livre à
ses lecteurs son analyse des meilleurs
placements du moment sur France Info le
conseiller d'un gestionnaire de
patrimoine fait même état d'une
augmentation de 80% en un mois du nombre
de demandes sur notre site Internet pour
avoir des informations sur l'ouverture
d'un plan et par une retraite vous voyez
je cite toujours les affaires reprennent
certes le millésime 2023 de la réforme
des retraites apparaît moins
destructeurs que celui de 2019-2020
puisqu'à l'époque le système par point
rendait le montant des futurs pensions
inconnues et volatiles invitant donc
mécaniquement les plus hauts revenus à
recourir à des plans d'épargne privé
pour les compléter depuis quelques
années Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements successifs cherchent à
rendre plus attractif ces produits de
capitalisation et à développer le marché
c'était le cas dès 2019 et la loi pacte
avec deux dispositions en particulier je
pense notamment à la création de fonds
de pension à la française donc organise
de retraite professionnelle
supplémentaire associée à des
assouplissements réglementaires donc
personne n'est dupe sur le fait que vous
souhaitez développer toujours plus le
système de capitalisation et la
marchandisation des pensions et bien
évidemment nous sommes opposés à cela
c'est le sens de ces amendements
très bien
Madame la rapporteur votre avis sur ces
trois amendements identiques merci
Madame la Président je partage pas
l'idée de créer sans cesse de nouveaux
impôts sachant que la protection sociale
a des recettes très dynamiques depuis la
sortie de la crise sanitaire parce que
nous avons soutenu les entreprises et
que la masse salariale ne cesse
d'augmenter depuis 2021 donc avis
défavorable très bien Madame kéké vous
avez demandé la parole non c'est qui
madame héraudy allez-y madame la députée
oui je voulais rebondir sur les propos
de mes collègues de la nupesse qui
seront les principaux gagnants de la
réforme je vous donne une indice
Blackrock oui les principaux pour ne pas
dire les seuls gagnants de la réforme
que vous proposez ce sont les fonds de
pension or ces fonds de pension sont vos
amis oui vous leur déroulez le tapis
rouge depuis plusieurs années pour vous
les dépenses les recettes socialisées du
système de retraite de l'argent qui
échappent au marché financier c'est pour
cela que contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez vous c’était encourager le
développement d'un système par
capitalisation
en 2019 déjà la loi pacte crée des
plantes d’épargne retraite et des
conditions fiscales très avantageuses en
5 ans les conditions annuelles les
cotisations annuelles d'épargne privées
ont augmenté de 27% pour atteindre 16,4
milliards en 2020
si l'on prend l'ensemble des régimes la
part de retraite par capathique
capitalisation pardon à augmenter de
30%. en deux ans seulement il s'agit
d'un manque à gagner non négligeable
pour notre système de retraite de la
même manière la réforme que l'on a sous
les yeux a augmentant la durée
d'assurance requise et en diminuant la
retraite des français puisque oui la
peinture moyenne cumulée des françaises
sur l'ensemble de la durée de la
retraite va diminuer la réforme va
encourager les plus aisées à se préparer
un complément un complément de retraite
par capitalisation nous à la nups nous
pensons que la tendance actuelle à la
capitalisation capitalisation doit
cesser et que Blackrock et compagnie
doit passer à la caisse quand on sait
que cette société a touché plus de 2
milliards de dividendes du CAC 40 au
titre de l'exercice de 2021 il serait
temps de lui faire les poches ou un
minima de reprendre une partie de ce que
vous lui avez donné merci
très bien Madame Thévenot
je vous donne le micro madame la député
allez-y merci madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur j'entends tout à
fait je suis assez satisfaite qu'on
commence enfin à rentrer dans le fond du
sujet et à parler effectivement de deux
modèles qui s'opposent d'un côté le
système par répartition et d'un autre le
système par capitalisation je suis
rassurée d'entendre que mes collègues de
gauche veulent absolument rester dans un
système par répartition dénonçons
peut-être un système par capitalisation
qui pourrait exister et bien ce que je
vous dis c'est que aujourd'hui aussi
aujourd'hui déjà ce système par réparti
par capitalisation un peu Shadow un peu
dans l'ombre existe déjà et va continuer
à exister si nous ne menons pas cette
réforme pourquoi ce n'est pas moi qui le
dis ce n'est pas la majorité qui le dit
c'est le corps qui le dit le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites prévoit une
baisse très significative des pensions
moyennes relativement au salaire moyen
si nous ne venons pas répondre aux
problèmes budgétaires dont nous parlons
maintenant depuis trois jours ici donc
oui d'accord avec vous pour préserver
notre système de répartition oui
d'accord avec vous pour faire en sorte
que les Français n'aient pas
l'obligation de croire assez fantasmes
de capitalisation qui en réalité ne
serait pas saine dans un système de
solidarité que nous voulons et donc oui
d'accord avec vous pour travailler
ensemble à pérenniser notre système de
répartition
très bien donc je mets oui monsieur
d'arriville oui allez-y pardon je
croyais que vous m'aviez vu
non simplement sur cette question moi je
crois évidemment que il faut s'attaquer
au fond de pension parce que les fonds
de pension nous attaquent je crois qu'on
ne dira jamais assez la toxicité de de
ces fonds sur notre économie sur nos
entreprises sur les salariés de nos
entreprises la façon dont ils se
comporte comme des prédateurs moi j'en
ai eu l'exemple et vous en avez sans
doute connu dans vos circonscriptions
avec des rachats d'entreprises à court
terme où on vient simplement se payer
sur la bête avant de repartir voilà le
système de spéculation maximum qui est
induit par le système de fond de pension
donc je crois effectivement que nous
devons contribuer à
essayer de rendre un peu plus vertueux
le système autant pour autant que ça
soit possible en tout cas en s'y
attaquant et en essayant de les faire
contribuer tout simplement notre système
par par répartition
donc là je trouve qu'il y a une idée qui
mérite d'être d'être creusé après je
voudrais quand même peut-être lever une
ambiguïté c'est à dire que la réforme
qui est proposée aujourd'hui à travers
ce texte budgétaire qui n'en n'est pas
un
en réalité elle ne répond pas la
question du décrochage des pensions
vis-à-vis des salaires il y a aucune
réponse dans le texte qui nous est
proposé à cela donc je crois qu'il faut
pas essayer d'en fumer les gens
là-dessus si on voulait indexer
effectivement les les pensions sur les
salaires ça serait une très bonne idée
c'est une proposition que nous formulons
mais ça n'est pas dans le texte qui
proposait là donc voilà et puis pendant
des années la compression des des
pensions a quand même joué contre le
contre les retraités de manière
significative donc voilà je crois qu'il
y a effectivement forte à faire pour
restaurer un droit à la retraite qui
était beaucoup abîmé et je regrette que
cette réforme contribue à l'abîmer plus
encore
très bien
alors je vais tout à l'heure reprendre
quelques personnes excusez-moi mais on
avait une discussion commune avec
d'autres amendements donc voilà mais je
ne redonne pas la parole aux personnes
qui sont déjà exprimées par groupe on
est d'accord donc je reprends les
amendements identiques et donc je vais
demander à Monsieur PTV de défendre le
34 21 monsieur le député
merci madame la Présidente alors la
capitalisation représente déjà plus de
16 milliards d'euros de cotisations par
an dont les dividendes proviennent
largement des capitaux issus du plan
d'épargne retraite ces fonds sont par
ailleurs des acteurs de la
délocalisation du chômage l'optimisation
fiscale et donc de la baisse des
recettes pour les femmes nous rappelons
qu'un texte est discrètement arrivé à
l'Assemblée nationale ces trois fois
rien il s'agit de l'adaptation au droit
de l'Union européenne de diverses
dispositions dans les domaines de
l'économie de la santé et du travail ce
texte une simple formalité bien sûr vise
notamment à accompagner l'essor de la
retraite par capitalisation à l'échelle
européenne le but de cet article c'est
de permettre de transporter son épargne
retraite d'un pays de l'Union européenne
à l'autre pour créer une nouvelle étape
dans l'intégration des marchés des
capitaux donc voilà en France on
détricote et privatise petit bout par
petit bout le système de retraite en
Europe on prépare l'émergence des fonds
de pension européens
très bien amendement madame Rousseau le
38 95 et bien c'est toujours une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
fonds de pension dont on ne dira jamais
en effet comme l'a dit Pierre darréville
la toxicité quand on ne démontre jamais
suffisamment le niveau de toxicité et en
l'occurrence là la le premier taux qui
vous était proposé était de 10 %, ce qui
aurait permis d'avoir déjà une un
encadrement assez significatif de ses
activités ce deuxième amendement vous
propose un taux de 5% d'encadrement des
d'encadrement des activités de ces fonds
de pensions et une contribution
exceptionnelle sur ses fonds de pension
je rappelle que ces fondations se
nourrissent sur la bête et sur la
disparition de l'État social sur la
baisse de notre protection sociale et
qui est évidemment il nourrissent les
plus riches d'entre nous et vraiment
la contribution exceptionnelle de 5%
c'est le minimum pour garantir une
absence de financiarisation de notre
retraite et de sa part par
capitalisation
bien ensuite amendement suivant
monsieur Petavy 34 98
très bien merci madame la Présidente
donc l'une des certitudes avec cette
réforme c'est qu'elle va creuser les
inégalités entre les retraités entre les
femmes et les hommes retraités et entre
les retraités pauvres et ceux qui
pourront se permettre d'épargner le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un
système à l'américaine c'est une grande
ligne droite jusqu'à la privatisation de
notre système de protection sociale
c'est l'ombre de BlackRock qui plane sur
l'un des derniers piliers de la
protection sociale à la française
gestionnaire d'actifs a ainsi déclaré
récemment sur France Info qu'il a eu une
augmentation de 80% entre décembre et
janvier du nombre de demandes de plan
d'épargne retraite c'est ça l'agenda du
gouvernement derrière la réforme des
retraites ces efforts qu'ils demandent
au plus vulnérables vont venir gonfler
les caisses des banques des compagnies
d'assurance et des fonds de pension
cette réforme du gouvernement c'est du
pain béni pour les banques et pour les
marchés financiers
très bien amendement suivant vous faites
le suivant monsieur Petavy je parle du
34 71
alors nous proposons nous proposons
cette taxe sur les fonds de pension car
si le gouvernement avait inclus dans sa
réforme une étude d'impact sur ces
mesures antisociales il aurait ainsi vu
que cette réforme est une catastrophe
pour le climat augmentation
qui vont passer par l'épargne donc
auprès des banques l'assurance et le
fond de pension dans l'espoir d'avoir
une retraite toutes ces acteurs sont
aujourd'hui également ce qui
investissent massivement dans les
énergies fossiles l'ONG réclame donc
France s'est penché sur les mesures
écologiques mises en place par les 10
plus gros acteurs français du secteur et
aucune d'entre elles a adopter des
engagements pour mettre fin au
développement des projets de production
de pétrole cette réforme c'est aussi une
aubaine pour la BNP Paribas qui en
septembre dernier détenait 2,7 milliards
de dollars de participation dans les
énergies fossiles avec cette proposition
de contribution sur les fonds de pension
nous voulons remettre un peu de justice
dans notre système pour que ce soit pour
que ce ne soit plus les plus vulnérables
les plus impactés par la réforme
bien monsieur le député madame Rousseau
vous faites le suivant le 38 88 oui
alors il s'agit toujours d'une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
fonds de pension et comme le disait
André gorght en fait la force du
capitalisme c'est détendre la sphère
marchande et comme le disait Karl Polini
le problème du libéralisme et d'avoir
transformé le travail en une quasi
marchandise et là typiquement c'est fond
de pension qui font commerce de notre
travail de l'épargne lié à notre travail
et de la diminution de la solidarité
entre ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui
et ceux qui ont arrêté de travailler et
bien participent de cette folle
accumulation capitaliste qui n'en finit
plus de détruire la planète et les
humains donc nous vous proposons une
taxe au moins d'un pour cent
très bien donc Madame la rapporteur
elle avait déjà donné son avis elle
était donc favorable défavorable contre
tous ces amendements et nous étions dans
la discussion alors je rappelle que je
ne vais pas redonner la parole à
l'ensemble des groupes puisque madame
héraudy s'est exprimée madame Thévenot
et Monsieur d'arriville donc je poursuis
alors Monsieur Bazin avait demandé la
parole mais il y a également monsieur
Juvin
monsieur Juva très bien monsieur Jubin
vous avez la parole merci madame la
présidente madame rapporteur devant la
capétisation ça marche par exemple le
régime additionnel de la fonction
publique c'est un régime de
capitalisation qui permet au
fonctionnaires de bénéficier d'un
complément avec leur retraite par
répartition d'une retraite par
capitalisation donc il ne faut pas dire
que la capette civilisation ça ne marche
pas ça marche et ça marche tous les ans
en particulier pour les fonctionnaires
l'intelligence serait non pas de taxer
comme c'est proposé les fonds de pension
mais de compléter le système de
répartition justement par de la
capitalisation le vrai progrès serait de
créer un fond de pension souverain
obligatoire garanti par l'État qui
permettrait de garantir la retraite par
répartition enfin j'ajoute que les fonds
de pension dans les pays où ils existent
ils permettent de réunir des fonds dans
les actifs
dégagent de l'argent d'une manière
considérable pour investir dans
l'économie réelle en moyenne 46 de la
valeur du PIB dans les fonds de pension
dans les pays de l'OCDE où ces fonds de
pension existent donc les fonds de
pension c'est aussi une manière de faire
vivre l'économie et l'emploi
très bien
Madame madame rogol vous avez la parole
non non vous ne pouvez pas monsieur le
député seul madame rigole à la parole
merci beaucoup bonjour à toutes et tous
je voudrais saluer les nécessaires à mon
demande de mes collègues sur cette
question des fonds de pension et je suis
très étonnée de votre réaction monsieur
Juvin en tant que spécialiste des
questions de santé de dire que les fonds
de pension ça marche les fonds de
pension c'est avant tout des fonds qui
vont financer les énergies fortement
carbonées les mêmes énergies qui
creusent le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale et altère la santé de chacun
chaque année un peu plus je rappelle que
le Sénat a chiffré combien ça coûte à
nos impôts c'est 100 milliards chaque
année qui s'envolent littéralement en
fumée du fait de la pollution de l'air
et uniquement de celle-ci et je suis
heureuse d'entendre madame Thévenot
faire front commun avec nous contre ces
fonds de pension mais je m'étonne un peu
de la modalité de défense de ça puisque
pour que ça fonctionne c'est la solid
avant tout celle que vous refusez et je
m'étonne encore plus de votre capacité à
vous appuyer sur les explications du
corps après le camouflé que vous avez
infligez monsieur bras sans commission
des finances sur votre interprétation
toute personnelle de des analyses de ce
même corps et je m'interroge et cela la
même utilisation ou va t'en faire entrer
dans le débat sur le fond
très bien monsieur turquois
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de rentrer dans le débat sur le
fond une fois de plus
que dit le corps si on ne fait rien les
pensions ce qui seront servis au
retraités dans 20 ou 25 ans seront
inférieures de 25% au revenu des actifs
premier sujet donc nécessité nécessité
d'agir
deuxième deuxième sujet par rapport à
cette réforme où on porte et l'âge légal
et la durée certains disent mais
pourquoi vous avez pas fait la durée
uniquement la durée parce que ça
listerait une liberté de choix et on
voit que
quand il y a une liberté de choix et
bien un certain nombre de situations de
gens qui ont pu épargner par leur propre
par leurs propres moyens eux vont
choisir de partir plus tôt parce qu'ils
auront leur trimestre alors que là je
les gale contraint à faire l'effort pour
tout le monde contrat à faire l'effort
pour tout le monde donc le mix entre âge
légal et durée et un bon sens ensuite
sur la
très bien donc je vais mettre aux voix
donc ces amendements alors je commence
avec les amendements identiques le 34 10
le 38 91 le 50 22 qui ont reçu donc un
avis défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre
ils sont rejetés deux amendements suite
ou trois tendez-vous amendements
identiques pareil avis défavorable de
Madame la rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement ensuite 34,98 défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre rejeté amendement
identique mais ma vie même votre pour
les deux suivants
identique très bien rejeté alors nous
arrivons à des amendements pouvant être
mis en discussion commune avec
amendement
identique qui font l'objet qui fait
l'objet d'un sous amendement au-dessous
amendement alors
madame monsieur Petavy pour l'amendement
34,80
merci madame la Présidente
alors la France a encore battu son
propre record l'année dernière de
versement de dividendes avec 44
milliards d'euros versés de fait elle
est même championne d'Europe toute
catégorie parmi ces entreprises on
retrouve pêle-mêle BNP Paribas Sanofi
AXA
ces entreprises ont gavé comme des oies
moi je viens de Périgord donc leurs
actionnaires on entend déjà la majorité
nous dire que parmi ces actionnaires il
y a le petit actionnaire avec ces
quelques dizaines d'euros d'action qui
fait fructifier pour se mettre un peu
d'argent de côté mais je me permets de
vous de lancer en vous disant que les
chiffres contredisent ce fantasme du
petit investisseur en 2019 62% des
dividendes ont été reçus par les 0,1%
des foyers les plus aisés dont 31% par
les 0,01 des plus riches
on entend aussi déjà la majorité
invoquée à nouveau sa théorie du
ruissellement la réalité c'est que
toutes les mesures de ces dernières
années qui ont bénéficié aux ultra
riches n'ont eu aucun effet sur la
population l'adresse donc a évaluer
d'elle-même que le coût budgétaire de la
suppression de l'ISS s'élèverait entre
2,9 et 3,5 milliards par an les
richesses des entreprises s'échappent de
plus en plus de leur obligation de
contribuer à l'état social pendant ce
temps là pendant ce temps la demande aux
Français les plus précaires de faire des
efforts car oui c'est au plus vulnérable
qu'on demande de faire des efforts alors
par cet amendement de contribution sur
les dividendes nous disons que oui nous
sommes nous aussi pour l'effort oui pour
l'effort que doivent produire les grands
patrons qui décident de priver les
travailleurs et travailleuses d'une
majorité de la richesse créée merci
très bien ensuite
amendement suivant puisque c'est
amendement identique madame Rousseau
merci madame la Présidente c'est une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
dividendes cette fois-ci puisque vous
avez voté contre les fonds de pension
mais les dividendes quand même les
dividendes on est d'accord qu'on a une
explosion des inégalités notamment liée
à au stock de patrimoine et aux revenus
du patrimoine bien supérieurs à
l'augmentation des inégalités liées aux
différences de salaire donc là c'est une
des manières de faire je rappelle que
Total cette année a fait à distribuer
des dividendes record de 13 milliards
d'euros 13 milliards d'euros alors que
le déficit maximal de par année de
l'Assurance retraite c'est de 12
milliards donc en fait là on a quand
même une manne qui est facile d'aller
chercher en plus c'est absolument moral
parce que c'est de l'enrichissement sans
rien faire pour le coup les dividendes
c'est vraiment on a investi dans des
actions donner des actions qui polluent
qui font des écocytes qui détruisent les
droits humains partout dans le monde et
hop on empoche 13 milliards donc là
vraiment je suis sûr que vous allez nous
suivre
très bien Madame la Députée amendement
suivant madame Garin s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues on
se calme
jumelles
ne vous laissez pas voilà
monsieur jumelles on se laisse pas
abattre nouveau record de versement de
dividendes en 2022 avec 382 milliards
d'euros qui ont été versés aux
actionnaires on a le prix Nobel Joseph
stigliss qui prend un taux d'imposition
mondiale de 70 % pour les plus riches on
a Oxfam qui vient de sortir un rapport
il y a quelques jours qui appelle à la
mise en place d'une taxation sur les
dividendes et ce que je dois vraiment
continuer oui je cite la part des
profits est inhabituellement élevé à
présent et la part des salaires
inhabituellement basse l'amplitude de
cette évolution et l'éventail des pays
concernés n'ont pas de précédents dans
les 45 dernières années alors vous vous
demandez peut-être d'où sont tirer
Céline donc ce n'est pas d'un texte de
la CGT non elles viennent d'un article
de la banque dérèglement internationaux
donc c'est une institution qui réunit
chaque mois à Bâle en Suisse les
banquiers centraux afin de coordonner
les politiques monétaires donc au fond
nous ce qu'on vous propose avec ces
amendements c'est un rééquilibrage un
rééquilibrage du partage de la valeur du
capital vers le travail et c'est bien
l'objet de cet amendement
très bien Madame la Députée alors on va
passer les sous amendements et je donne
la parole à Monsieur Guedj
pour le sous amendement 72 71 et si vous
le voulez bien faites le Président c'est
deux amendements sont sous un moment sur
les amendements de replis à l'appui de
l'amendement de du collègue pétavie en
prévoyant que cette contribution dans un
cas ne soit pas de 10% mais de 5% et
dans l'autre cas ce serait même déjà ça
uniquement de 1%
très bien monsieur le député alors je
poursuis avec deux amendements ou
plusieurs même alors attendez voilà
trois amendements
identiques monsieur Petavy vous avez la
parole
c'est pour le 95 madame c'est ça le oui
tout à fait c'est ça bien alors le
rassemblement national l'a dit tout à
l'heure ils n'ont rien contre les
milliardaires
au moins c'est dit le rassemblement
national tout comme le gouvernement n'a
donc aucun problème avec les inégalités
de richesse il n'a aucun problème avec
ceux qui creusent les inégalités avec
ceux qui payent des salaires de misère
aux travailleurs et travailleuses avec
ceux qui maltraite les seniors il ne
compte pas revenir sur les 5 milliards
d'isfaire du chaque année qui pourrait
financer notre système de retraite il ne
compte nullement remettre en cause ce
système ou 1% des riches ont capté 63%
des richesses produites la seule
solution qu'il propose de retraités
c'est le racisme à grande échelle c'est
le repli sur soi et sur la haine au lieu
de faire contribuer ce qui capte
injustement la majorité des richesses
produites alors par cet amendement le
groupe écologiste lui par du principe
que non seulement être milliardaire
n'est ni juste ni normal dans un pays
avec 10 millions de pauvres mais que la
France le paradis des exonérations
fiscales aux entreprises et responsables
avec le creusement de ces inégalités
contrairement à cette réforme cet
amendement est réellement une mesure
d'équilibre une mesure d'équilibre dans
la balance pour que ce ne soit pas les
plus vulnérables qui paye la facture
quand d'autres triplent leur fortune
chaque année excusez-moi très bien
monsieur le député ensuite madame
Rousseau vous défendez le suivant le 39
04 oui et bien il s'agit toujours d'une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
dividendes cette fois-ci de 5 % donc
comme ça a été très bien dit par mes
collègues Joseph Stiglitz prit Nobel
d'économie prix Nobel d'économie disait
qu'il fallait
augmenter la taxation sur les plus
riches à 70% et en fait pourquoi il dit
ça Joseph Stiglitz pour remettre les
plus riches dans le bien commun ce dont
on parle depuis le début de la matinée
c'est à dire qu'en fait on ne peut pas
faire sécession du bien commun et on ne
peut pas se satisfaire d'un niveau
d'inégalité qui progresse à une vitesse
qui défile entendement notamment liée
aux inégalités de patrimoine et de
revenus du patrimoine donc 5% versus 70%
de stiglit vraiment vous ne pouvez pas
dire non
très bien Madame Garin vous avez la
parole madame la députée
on parle de solidité de stabilité de
chiffres sur lesquels on peut s'appuyer
bon il y a des fois un petit peu
contesté par ceux qui les maîtrise le
mieux en tout cas quand c'est la
coalition présidentielle qui les agite
et de justice ordre d'après le Fond
Monétaire International dans les pays
membres du G7 la part des salaires dans
le PIB a baissé de 5,8% entre 83 et 2006
d'après la Commission européenne au sein
de l'UE au sein de l'Europe cette fois
cette parachute
8,6% et en France de 9,3%. on parle de
dizaines de milliards d'euros c'est ce
que représente ces 9,3% qui devraient
peut-être être au cœur de nos échanges
de nos réflexions et du débats que nous
avons
toute la contestation de vos soi-disant
nécessaires réformes en cours je mets
nécessaire avec beaucoup beaucoup de
guillemets que ce soit les régimes
spéciaux ou le reste pourrait s'appuyer
sur ce chiffre pour essayer de penser
vraiment la justice et pas l'injustice
parce que c'est plutôt à ça qu'on
assiste dans ce débat qu'on évalue se
transfert de richesse un petit peu le
PIB de la France s'élève après de 1800
milliards d'euros donc il y a en gros
120 à 170 milliards qui ont ripé du
travail vers le capital s'agit là d'un
calcul qui n'est pas le nôtre c'est
celui de l'Institut de recherche
économique et sociales soit même avec
des estimations basses
une dizaine de fois le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale et une vingtaine de
fois celui des retraites ces derniers
trous sont amplement médiatisés tandis
qu'en évoque moins souvent celui bien
plus profond creusé par les actionnaires
dans les poches des salariés entre qu'on
voudrait encore creuser un peu plus une
fois venu l'âge de la retraite il n'y a
vraiment aucune raison économique
financière de vouloir creuser à ce point
le niveau de vie des Français pour
l'abaisser autant que vous voulez le
temps que vous semblez le souhaitez à
travers cette réforme très bien ensuite
monsieur Petavy pour le 34 68
le gouvernement manque quand il demande
de faire des efforts aux Français parce
que ce ne sont pas tous les Français qui
devront faire un effort les 1% eux les
plus riches donc continueront à profiter
de leur jet privé de leur retraite dorés
et de leur exonération fiscale attire la
Rigot c'est 80 milliards d'euros
reversés par les entreprises du CAC 40
aux actionnaires auraient pu contribuer
au financement de notre système de
retraite il aurait pu servir à augmenter
les salaires et donc les contributions
sociales mais non cet argent s'est
évaporé massivement dans les poches des
actionnaires l'OMG Oxfam a ainsi
constaté que les écarts de rémunération
entre dirigeants et salariés se sont
creusés entre 2009 et 2018 les
versements aux actionnaires ont augmenté
de 70% sur la même période tandis que le
salaire moyen au sein de l'entreprise
augmenter de 20%. refuser d'augmenter
les salaires a été et un choix assumé
des patrons d'ailleurs j'entends la
majorité dire depuis tout à l'heure
qu'on ne comprend rien au système des
retraites mais si la différence est que
nous nous sommes pour que l'augmentation
des richesses sa juste place
c'est-à-dire dans les salaires des
travailleurs et travailleurs et donc
dans notre système de protection sociale
alors oui nous pouvons accès à hauteur
de 2% les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires c'est déjà une proposition
des camarades
du GDR en 2021 c'est une proposition
crédible et réalisable et c'est une
proposition que nous soutenons et
portons de vive voix aujourd'hui
très bien monsieur le député ensuite
monsieur Abba monsieur Petavy à nouveau
pour le 35 04
merci madame la Présidente donc cette
contribution sur les dividendes et
légitimes et juste parce que les moyens
que les entreprises auraient pu mettre
dans la formation des seniors elles ont
mis dans les poches des actionnaires qui
ne sont jamais autant gavés qu'en 2022
avec 80 milliards d'euros de dividendes
reversés par les entreprises du CAC 40
nous étions à 28 milliards en 2020 45
milliards en 2021 et nous sommes passés
au double en 2022 cet argent aurait pu
notamment aller dans la formation des
seniors comme je viens de le dire alors
que seul un salarié sur 10 a suivi une
formation professionnelle entre 45 et 62
ans ces différences sont d'autant plus
marquées entre les catégories
socioprofessionnelles presque tous les
cadres ont entendu parler d'au moins un
dispositif de formation professionnelle
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est le cas que de
six ouvriers et ouvrir sur 10 ce sont
les seniors et les ouvriers et ouvrières
qui sont les plus délaissés par les
formations les employeurs délaissent ces
catégories de salariés parce qu'ils y
accorde aucune valeur et aucune de nos
propositions dans votre projet de loi
agit pour améliorer la formation des
seniors vous espérez que l'index fera le
travail c'est un deck c'est un peu la
lampe magique Formation Emploi
pénibilité il exauce tous vos souhaits
sans frais sans engagement 1% c'est la
même contribution que vous demandez aux
entreprises pour la non publication du
formulaire senior on sait que vous avez
le sens du symbole chez la majorité donc
par cet amendement nous proposons
d'envoyer un minimal le symbole que ceux
qui s'enrichissent sur le dos des
travailleurs et travailleurs doivent eux
aussi contribuer au maintien de notre
système de retraite merci
très bien
alors madame Rousseau
ça vous manquait bah je peux en parler
pendant deux minutes sans problème de la
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
dividendes puisque en fait on est
toujours dans ce même sujet qui est une
forme d'enrichissement paresseux vous
savez cette espèce de choses dont il est
question depuis depuis longtemps
maintenant dans nos discussions qui est
le droit au travail à un travail juste
de qualité le droit au repos le droit
d'apparaisse en fait aujourd'hui les
plus paresseux sont quand même ceux qui
bénéficient des dividendes pourquoi
parce qu'en fait ils s'enrichissent son
strictement rien faire c'est-à-dire
juste en achetant des actions et en
ayant une fois par an le bénéfice de ces
actions via des dividendes donc en fait
là on touche parce que vous nous avez
fait des leçons de morale non-stop
depuis le début des discussions sur le
droit à la paresse ben là le vrai droit
à la paresse il est là
il est dans un enrichissement indus qui
n'est pas lié au travail donc alors
allez-y là on vous propose une taxe
exceptionnelle de 1% qui ira qui ira
fournir
la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse et bien ça nous résoudrait
bien des problèmes en fait de faire ça
et des problèmes économiques et des
problèmes d'équilibre des retraites mais
aussi des problèmes philosophiques et
éthiques
très bien Madame Guérin oui je crois que
là on est sur sur notre dernier rempart
donc 1% c'est vraiment pas grand chose
et ce serait effectivement assez
symbolique mais ça montrerait qu'il y a
une volonté effectivement de pas de ne
pas laisser quelque part une forme
d'oisiveté grevée nos caisses de
sécurité sociale donc 1% c'est vraiment
rien du tout et je trouve que ça enverra
un signal très très fort de la part de
la majorité si vous adoptiez cet
amendement
très bien alors madame là rapporteur
général votre avis sur tous ces
amendements merci madame la Présidente
après vous avoir écouté je voudrais pas
qu'on croit qu'il est pas d'impôt sur
les dividendes le taux de prélèvement
forfaitaire unique et de 30 % incluant
12,8 % en titre de l'impôt sur le revenu
et 17,2 au titre des prélèvements
sociaux de plus toutes ces ressources
obtenues avec cette fiscalité elles sont
aléatoires volatiles et il me semble
important qu'il puisse avoir des
recettes plus structurelles pour notre
régime de retraite
très bien donc j'ai plusieurs demandes
d'intervention monsieur jumelles
bon il est 15h40
à 20h vous allez plier non mais à 20h
vous allez plier les Gaules et faire
comme si rien ne s'était passé ni dans
la rue ni dans l'hémicycle donc je veux
tenter de de
l'hémistique de la commission madame la
Présidente vous me relèvera un point à
ma note
je veux résumer votre pensée
en macronie en macronie il vaut mieux
être riche et bien portant que pauvre
est malade ça c'est le premier principe
de base
deuxième principe de base en macronie on
fait le choix de faire payer les pauvres
parce qu'ils sont les plus nombreux et
d'épargner les riches parce que c'est
nos amis
sa gueule trou derrière eux il faudrait
l'envoyer des points
[Musique]
il vaut mieux faire payer les pauvres
parce qu'ils sont les plus nombreux
épargner les riches parce que c'est nos
amis et que ça soit moins il concourent
à notre élection troisième principe en
macronie on fait en sorte d'assécher
tous les outils de la République qui
prend soin pour ensuite nourrir ceux qui
s'apprêtent à combler les lacunes de la
République qui François on abîme l'école
publique pour enrichir l'école privée on
abîme l'hôpital pour mettre en place un
système de santé à plusieurs vitesses et
ainsi nourrir ceux qui font de l'argent
sur la santé de nos concitoyens et en
matière de protection sociale c'est la
même chose vous
le financement des retraites par des
mesures d'exonération à répétition et
vous refusez tous les amendements visant
à consolider financièrement le régime de
retraite par répartition comme nous vous
le demandons avec des amendements qui
sont loin des désamendements
révolutionnaires ici il vous propose
simplement de prendre un petit peu de
pognon là où il est pour le mettre là où
il y en a besoin je trouve que à 15h42
c'était pas mal de résumer votre vision
étroite de la République qui prend soin
votre vision étroite de monsieur le
député
là Monsieur Leduc madame pardon Leduc
merci madame la Présidente
de quoi de quoi parle ces amendements en
réalité il parle de quelque chose qui
devrait vous plaire sur dans les rangs
qui défendent cette réforme des
retraites on parle de quoi on parle de
la valeur travail vous nous avez pas mal
rabâché ça ce matin et en commission des
finances on nous avait aussi fait
entendre que nous n'aimions pas le
travail nous à la nupesse mais en
réalité ces amendements parlent
exactement de ça et votre rejet
systématique de ce type d'amendement
montre bien que votre mission première
ici est de défendre plutôt les intérêts
du capital que ceux du travail les
dividendes versées par le cac47 années
représente plus de 80 milliards d'euros
un nouveau record si on prend l'ensemble
des dividendes versés en France on
dépasse les 250 milliards d'euros versés
aux actionnaires si on soumettait à
cotisation ses revenus du capital on
pourrait récupérer 48 milliards d'euros
de quoi combler le léger déficit dont il
est question ici qui vous sert
d'épouvant permanent de quoi aussi aller
osons-le financer la retraite à 60 ans
pour toutes et tous avec 40 annuités et
de quoi il s'agit ici il s'agit de faire
contribuer ses revenus du capital et ce
ne serait que justice et pas seulement
pour des questions morales car oui il
est immoral de voir des fortunes de
plusieurs milliards s'accumuler pendant
que les plus modestes peinent à finir le
mois oui il est indécent d'être
milliardaire et nous pourrions nous
donner comme objectif la disparition des
milliardaires comme nous invite le
dernier rapport comme nous y invite le
dernier rapport d'Oxfam n'en déplaise au
président de la République un
milliardaire ne sert à rien mais au-delà
de toutes ces raisons d'où viennent les
dividendes d'où viennent les revenus du
capital il faut vous le dire une fois de
plus puisque vous refusez de l'entendre
les dividendes viennent du travail des
Françaises et des Français sans travail
pas de revenus du capital et oui la
force du travail est exploitée pour
dégager des profits or notre système de
retraite est financé par des cotisations
sur la richesse créée dans le pays
pourquoi pourquoi seul la part de la
richesse qui revient aux travailleurs et
aux travailleuses et soumise à
cotisations alors que la part qui finit
dans la poche des actionnaires et qui
est à Monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente
là encore je pense qu'il
bien sûr il y a peut-être des excès d'un
côté et des excès de l'autre pour autant
je pense pas qu'il faille opposer le
capital et le travail le capital n'est
pas une fin en soi le capital n'est pas
une fin en soi et quand vous dites les
le capital n'est pas dû au travail je
m'étonne parce que moi je connais des
salariés des ETAM qui sont très heureux
quand il y a la possibilité d'avoir une
participation où on intéressement verser
sur un plan d'épargne retraite collectif
et on voit que on peut avoir des revenus
ensuite du capital qui est issu du
travail et je m'étonne parce que il y a
la possibilité d'avoir une finance
durable il y a des fonds d'ailleurs
labellisés investissement social
responsable avec des critères
environnementaux sociaux et de
gouvernance qui permettent d'ailleurs la
Macif le fait par exemple l'important
c'est d'avoir des fonds à la fois
éthiques des fonds souverains qui
financent des investissements pour notre
pays les investissements cohérents avec
nos valeurs et on le voit bien il y a
parfois besoin y compris pour nous
retraités parfois de classe moyenne
d'épargne d'épargne salariale de capital
pour pouvoir financer des projets pour
pouvoir aider la génération qui suit et
ça ne concerne pas j'allais dire que les
très grandes fortunes et je crois qu'il
faut pas caricaturer d'ailleurs sur ces
abonnements notamment des entreprises
parce qu'il y a pas que les versements
des salariés sur ces fonds d'épargne
salariale pour la retraite il y a des
versements d'entreprises et sur ces et
les abonnements de ces entreprises il y
a un forfait social certes réduit mais
existant et donc je pense que c'est
quand même important aujourd'hui de
rappeler que toute finance n'est pas
mauvaise que tout capital n'est pas
forcément mauvais et que d'ailleurs ça
peut être du capital qui vient du
travail au service des travailleurs et
qui leur permettent notamment à des
travailleurs qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens je connais des personnes qui ont
bénéficié de leur épargne salariale pour
financer leurs projets et et ça c'est
ici du fruit de leur travail et je crois
que ça c'est aussi la méritocratie
madame Rousseau alors on a eu la paresse
lundi on a eu Mbappé mardi et mercredi
mais oui parce que je pense que à un
moment il y a des excès du capital et je
serai on pourra se rejoindre sur un
centre de points mais attention il y a
parfois de l'épargne salariale durable
qui mérite d'être gardé comme une
solution pour des retraités de classe
moyenne qui ont travaillé et ça leur
permet des solutions ils ont d'ailleurs
la liberté de choisir entre une rente ou
un capital au moment ils partent à la
retraite et c'est un vrai plus pour ceux
qui ont bossé
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Guedj
oui madame la Présidente on parle depuis
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
de la manière de mettre à contribution
les dividendes
je voudrais qu'on fasse le lien avec le
débat qu'on avait eu au moment du PLF
et y compris même du PLF et moi j'en
appelle à nos amis députés du MoDem
cette
série d'amendements elle s'inscrit dans
la lignée de ce que votre président de
groupe monsieur Mattei avait pu
soumettre un moment donné en considérant
que les dividendes en l'espèce à
l'époque c'était les super dividendes
qui étaient sollicité et bien là on est
exactement dans le même esprit je pense
qu'on s'accorde à dire que il y a un
décalage un dérapage dans le versement
des dividendes et que ceci puisse être
mis à contribution pour équilibrer le
régime de retraite c'était le même la
même philosophie que celle que Monsieur
Mattei lui-même avait mis en oeuvre
quand il souhaitait que ça puisse venir
financer le budget de l'État donc
j'espère que par cohérence nos amis du
MoDem pourront soutenir
[Musique]
très bien monsieur ménager
merci Madame la présidence alors je
voudrais juste revenir sur les propos de
ma Thévenot qui comme toute la macronie
depuis des semaines jure la main sur le
cœur que c'est pour préserver les
pensions de retraite des Français alors
déjà vous n'êtes pas crédible puisqu'il
Emmanuel Macron une des premières
mesures qu'il a mis en place quand il
est arrivé c'était la hausse de la CSG
qui a fait baisser les retraites premier
point deuxième point vous avez jamais
alors que Marine Le Pen a toujours
demandé Vous refusez une réelle
indexation des retraites sur l'inflation
donc clairement dire aujourd'hui que
c'est pour préserver les retraites c'est
clairement pas crédible et puis madame
nous mais dites nous dans votre texte où
vous préservez le montant des pensions
quel article et quel article on l'a
dépouillé on l'a totalement désossé
votre projet il n'y a rien sur cette
question très clairement par contre il y
a des exemples étrangers il y a la
logique la pur logique qui veut que dès
lors que vous devriez faire deux ans de
plus il y aura un grand nombre de
Français qui ne seront pas en capacité
physique de le faire et donc il y aura
des retraites des côtés il y aura aussi
un grand nombre de Français qui
n'arriveront plus à obtenir les
surcottes qu'ils arrivaient à obtenir
actuellement en faisant cet effort en
travaillant un petit peu plus
aujourd'hui vous comprenez pas que ça
sera naturellement qu'il y aura une
baisse des retraites une baisse des
pensions pour les Français notamment
ceux qui ont les métiers les plus
difficiles ceux qui seront usés ceux qui
ne seront pas en capacité d'aller
jusqu'à 64 ans donc apportez-nous des
réponses franchement les Français n'y
croient plus les Français ne croient
plus sur tous les retraités ils ont
arrêté de vous croire sur votre réel
volonté de préserver leur pouvoir
d'achat puisque vous n'agissez
absolument pas dans leur sens depuis
votre arrivée au pouvoir
et bien madame Rousseau
madame la Présidente alors bon on va
quand même rectifier une ou deux choses
là qui ont été dit sur le rapport
capital travail parce qu'en fait le
capital est lié au travail il est même
lié à la plus-value et à la différence
qui existe entre le prix auquel on paye
les salariés c'est à dire à la force de
reproduction et la valeur créée par ceci
d'ailleurs c'est un des sujets qui est
aujourd'hui qui est aujourd'hui dans la
dans la discussion puisque pour vous le
repos n'est que de la reconstitution de
la force de travail quand nous nous
défendons un droit à l'émancipation ça
s'appelle la retraite et ça s'appelle la
retraite à 62 ans tel qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui je rappelle quand même une
toute petite chose c'est que
les les 10% non mais déjà arrêtons cette
réforme on voit après pour les 60 ans ok
donc pour les 10% les plus faibles
niveau de patrimoine moyen et tu as 3800
euros quand pour les 10 plus pour les 10
% les plus élevés il est à 6007 700 €,
soit 159 fois plus 159 fois plus et si
on prend les 1% les plus riches la
différence est entre 1 et 503
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un facteur
multiplicatif de 503 entre les 10% les
plus pauvres en termes de patrimoine et
le 1% le plus riche et donc les
dividendes participent de cette
inégalité ça fait partie des choses que
nous devons taxer pour encadrer pour
réinstaller un état social diminuer le
niveau d'inégalité donc nous comptons
encore une fois avec tous l'espoir que
nous mettons dans votre vote positif sur
cet amendement
très bien
Madame Thévenot
me voilà merci madame la Présidente non
très rapidement c'est vrai c'est vrai je
sais que nos collègues du rassemblement
national sont un peu jaloux parce que
nous parlons beaucoup nous débattons
beaucoup avec nos collègues de gauche
mais force et de constater et là je vous
le je vous le dis très clairement mes
collègues de gauche c'est que vous avez
une proposition vous avez un projet à
défendre certes nous ne sommes pas
d'accord nous en soulignons un certain
nombre d'incohérences nous défendons pas
le même projet de société nous voulons
conserver le système par répartition
mais oui je suis d'accord avec vous vous
avez un projet à défendre mais c'est
vrai que le rassemblement national vous
êtes en tunnel depuis deux jours on vous
entend pas on vous voit pas sauf
peut-être en fin de journée pourquoi
mais parce que vous n'avez strictement
rien à proposer absolument rien à
proposer à la constance à la constance
des débats que nous avons eu depuis deux
jours l'incontinence qui est la vôtre et
fabuleuse elle est savoureuse
vous changez d'avis au gré des sondages
lisant les fiches des uns et des autres
le lendemain quitte à tourner en rond et
tomber par terre donc s'il vous plaît ne
venez pas nous donner de leçons vous qui
passez votre temps à faire des demandes
que ce soit sur la sécurité sur les
forces de l'ordre sur la justice surtout
ces sujets en permanence vous allez
brailler sur tous les plateaux mais
quand il s'agit de prendre ses
responsabilités dans l'hémicycle vous
avez toujours piscine
très bien on applaudit pas mes chers
collègues on ne s'applaudit pas
alors je vais passer avant que nous
passions au vote je vais passer la
parole
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on ouvre à nouveau ces chakras
allez je passe la parole à Madame la
rapporteur général ah non il y a
Monsieur Vigier entre temps qui s'est
inscrit
micro monsieur
ou alors à moi que vous ne vouliez pas
ah bah je vous donne la parole puisque
vous l'avez demandé
non mais comme madame la Présidente
qu'on lui connaît
m'a invité à parler de la proposition
qui avait été faite par Jean-Paul Mathis
sur les hyper dividendes dans le mot
super dividende il y a le mot super il a
pas oublié et il y a de beau dividendes
mais absolument mais à Madame et demi
mais le super bidon il sait très bien
que là-dessus notre position est très
claire on l'a défendu je crois
d'ailleurs avoir lu un peu dans la
presse que cette idée cheminée mais vous
savez il est des moments où faut savoir
prendre le point de départ et puis après
je suis persuadé qu'à un moment il y
aura un atterrissage en revanche à
vouloir taxer comme vous le faites
l'ensemble des dividendes là nous
opposons complètement pour des raisons
qui ont été explicitées et que chacun
peut bien comprendre c'est là où nous
avons une logique qui diverge avec vous
et les collègues de la nupaise alors
quand à Monsieur ménager j'ai dit mais
un instant vous nous parlez que de
l'article 7 mais revenez à l'article 7
parce que là depuis ce matin en tant que
ça alors un peu de patience et on y
arrivera je sais pas aujourd'hui ça sera
la semaine prochaine
très bien très bien mes chers collègues
très bien donc nous allons passer au
vote
alors on va déjà passer au sous
amendements le sous-amendement
et 60 alors attendez voir
et 71 alors je 71 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame larapenteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté même avis même vote pour
le sous-enté ça me demande même à vie
même vote et je mets au vote cette
fois-ci l'amendement 34 80 qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté et ensuite
je mets les deux tous les identiques ils
sont tous identiques
qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés une
autre série d'identique qui est pour
qui contre
ils sont rejetés ensuite amendement 34
68 qui est pour
oui qui est contre ils sont rejetés
ensuite amendement identique la dernière
série
qui est pour
qui contre
ils sont rejetés alors mes chers
collègues amendements pouvant être mis
en discussion commune et je passe la
parole pour le 7013
monsieur Lucas madame Guérin
merci madame la Présidente notre pays
est plus riche que jamais c'est un fait
s'il vous plaît on écoute
je crois que la digestion en disciples
certains de manière exacerbée toujours
notre pays est plus riche que jamais
c'est un fait lorsque François
Mitterrand passe la retraite à 60 ans en
1982 le PIB français est de 588
milliards en 2021 il est de 2500
milliards soit plus de 4 fois plus alors
la question qu'on peut se poser de
manière assez légitime c'est où est
passé cet argent donc cet argent il
existe dans certaines poches et
l'enjante des inégalités qui se
perpétuent notamment par l'héritage vous
n'ignorez certainement pas que la part
des 1% les plus riches dans le
patrimoine total est ainsi passé de 15 à
25% entre 1988 et 2015 tandis que la
fortune héritée en représente désormais
60% contre 35% au début des années 70
autrement dit il y a bien de la richesse
pour financer nos retraites il faut
simplement la répartir plus
équitablement et notamment aller la
chercher dans les inactifs familiers du
droit à la paresse afin de permettre au
plus pauvre d'accéder au temps libéré si
nécessaire à la dignité et
l'épanouissement de l'être humain
et je crois que madame la Présidente si
on peut avoir un peu de silence sinon je
terminerai pas mon intervention
non mais je vais dire c'est juste qu'on
s'entend pas quoi
vous avez fini madame manette députés
non j'ai pas terminé bon s'il vous plaît
on écoute madame la députée qui n'a pas
fini la présentation de son amendement
mais c'est pas pour moi c'est pour tout
le monde
donc
quand vous voulez sortir pour aller
voter vous le faites discrètement
poursuivez madame la députée donc avec
cette amendement on vous propose de
financer la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse avec une simple piqûre de
moustique donc 5% pour les héritages de
plus de 4,2 millions et 10% pour les
héritages de plus de 13 millions sachant
que cela ne concerne qu'à peine une
personne sur 100 en France donc
finalement en prenant un peu au plus
aisé c'est amendement redonne beaucoup à
la CNAV et donc au pauvre et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis certaine
que les défenseurs de la justice vous
êtes ne manqueront pas de le voter très
bien ensuite madame Rousseau le suivant
le 55 02 non c'est Madame
[Musique]
oui allez
c'est moi
mettez-vous d'accord aucun problème
ah non non mais
c'est défendu
non mais bon je vais le défendre pour
Madame Rousseau nos excuses difficiles
de s'organiser à distance
non mais pour vous dire que aujourd'hui
le alors on vous cite beaucoup Oxfam et
vous n'aimez pas trop mais aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut citer sur
les ritage c'est le Conseil d'analyse
économique qui est placé auprès du
premier ministre et qui dit quoi dans sa
note il y a à peine un an un peu plus
d'un an il dit qu'on est en train de
revenir à une société d'héritier comme à
la belle époque au début du 20e siècle
et que c'est extrêmement concentré et
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent il disent
pourquoi se préoccuper du retour de
l'héritage je cite le rapport car il
porte en lui le risque d'un dérèglement
profond de l'égalité des chances valeur
cardinale des sociétés démocratiques et
conditions de leur possibilité
d'existence à long terme le patrimoine
hérité est en effet plus inégalement
réparti que les autres formes de
transmission et joue un rôle fond
fondamental dans la constitution de
profonde inégalités dynastiques de
patrimoine nous revenons là au sujet de
la dernière fois il y a quelques heures
dans cette commission comme si dans
notre société c'était ceux qui
méritaient qui étaient au place
dirigeantes et aux places les plus les
les plus belles dans notre société ce
n'est pas du tout le cas et donc c'est
pourquoi il nous semble juste de que le
petit ponction sur l'héritage qui est
très concentrée qui touche 10 à 20% des
qui toucheraient 10 à 20% des plus
riches permettrait d'aider à financer ce
système profondément important pour
notre société que la retraite
très bien monsieur Guedj
oui madame la Présidente vous avez
compris depuis ce matin on essaye
d'avoir plusieurs cordes à notre arc on
a essayé les retraites chapeau on a
essayé les actions gratuites on a essayé
les dividendes là on vous propose de
mobiliser le patrimoine et en
l'occurrence celui
qui est transmis au moment des
successions et des donations dans les
précautions pour ne pas taxer
l'essentiel des successions de notre de
notre pays et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle et bien on teste avec
la mise en place d'une contribution sur
les successions et les donations pour
financer la branche la branche
vieillesse
les éléments sur le
l'inégale répartition du patrimoine sont
connus je vous rappelle que 10% des
ménages les mieux
pourvu disposent au moins de 600.000
euros de patrimoine de patrimoine brut
et des tiennes près de la moitié de la
masse de la masse totale c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette mesure n'affectera
pas je le dis tout de suite parce que
vous allez nous agiter l'argument de oh
là là
ça va pénaliser les classes moyennes ce
n'est pas le cas très bien Madame la
rapporteur votre avis
c'est une création nouvelle d'un pot
donc je suis défavorable très bien je
mets au
monsieur jacobelli
merci madame la Présidente évidemment
notre groupe votre a pas cet amendement
je suis un peu surpris qu'il arrive
maintenant je pense que le seul intérêt
de cette amendement c'est de gagner du
temps puisque ça a l'air d'être la
stratégie de la nupes et si j'entends
madame la députée Thévenot qui s'est
fait applaudir par l'extrême gauche
l'extrême centre applaudit par l'extrême
gauche finalement quoi d'étonnant vous
êtes finalement les deux revers de la
même médaille vous êtes tous là pour
faire en sorte qu'on ne puisse pas
débattre de cette réforme des retraites
et qu'à la fin elle soit adoptée on
vient de découvrir on vient de découvrir
qu'après la macronie de droite et que la
macronie de gauche il y avait maintenant
un courant stalinien à la macronie qui
s'appelle la nupes tout est fait par la
nupesse pour vous faciliter la vie c'est
pour ça que vous faites applaudir est-ce
qu'en fin on va parler des vrais sujets
est-ce qu'en fin on va aller à l'article
7 est-ce qu'en fin on va défendre les
Français contre cette réforme qui est
une atrocité sociale est-ce que la nupes
va arrêter après avoir appelé à voter
pour Emmanuel Macron à faire le lit de
cette réforme vous êtes comme le dirait
un de mes collègues les ennemis des
travailleurs les ennemis sociaux vous
allez faire passer cette réforme pour
flatter votre orgueil et faire des clips
sur Twitter vous êtes irresponsable
très bien Monsieur Madame Amrani
merci madame la Présidente revenons sur
des choses un peu sérieuses parce que
nous nous avons travaillé contrairement
à d'autres qui n'ont rien fait depuis le
début de cette commission donc je
reviens moi sur la très bonne
proposition de notre de mon collègue
Jérôme Guedj concernant la réaction
d'une contribution sur les successions
et les donations pour financer la
branche vieillesse de la sécurité
sociale pour combler ce potentiel
déficit qui vous préoccupe tant la
création d'une nouvelle branche
marginale d'imposition de succession
serait
pertinente cette nouvelle branche
dont le taux pourrait être de 100%
au-delà de 12 millions de patrimoine net
taxable permettrait de récupérer près de
9 milliards d'euros par an enfin je vous
rappelle qu'une telle mesure impacterait
seulement
0,01% de la population et permettrait de
financer la retraite vous savez des
aides des éboueurs des fonctionnaires et
encore tous les Français pratiquement
qui étaient dans la rue hier encore et
qui ont cherché et attendus des élus du
Front national qui n'ont pas vu
très bien la parole est à Madame taillée
polluant oh non monsieur Lucas
pour mettre un peu d'apaisement dans ce
débat et contrairement à notre collègue
du rassemblement national je vais
essayer de ne pas brasser du vent notre
pays est plus riche que jamais c'est un
fait lorsque François Mitterrand passe
la retraite à 60 ans en 1982 le PIB
français est de 588 milliards en 2021 il
est de 2500 milliards soit plus de 4
fois plus alors la question qu'on peut
se poser légèrement c'est où est passé
cet argent et on sait on l'a vu et cet
élément très par mes collègues ici à
longueur d'argumentaire dans les poches
des plus riches engendrant des
inégalités qui se perpétuent par
l'héritage car que vous le vouliez ou
non l'accumulation des richesses par
quelques-uns malgré votre théorie du
ruissellement n'est pas et la source
aujourd'hui des inégalités de l'extrême
pauvreté vous n'ignorez certainement pas
chers collègues la part des 1% les plus
riches dans le patrimoine total est
ainsi passé de 15 à 25% entre 1988 et
2015 tandis que la fortune héritée en
représente désormais 60% contre 35% au
début des années 70 donc votre discours
sur le mérite la méritocratie ceux qui a
la sueur de leurs front ont accumulé
aurait mérité quelque chose en réalité
ils ont sué pour aller chercher leur
héritage pas pour travailler autrement
dit il y a de la richesse pour financer
nos retraites il faut simplement aller
la chercher là où elle est plutôt que de
demander aux Français ou d'imposer aux
Français le sacrifice de deux années de
travail et c'est donc à cela que nous
voulons nous attaquer parce que nous
croyons effectivement qu'il faut
valoriser le travail l'effort le mérite
et permettre à ceux qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie de bénéficier d'un temps
libéré du temps légitime du repos à la
retraite voilà pourquoi cette amendement
propose de financer la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse avec une simple
piqûre de moustique si je puis dire 5%
pour les héritage de plus de 4,2
millions et 10% pour les héritages de
plus de 13 millions 13 millions chers
collègues sachant que cela ne concerne
qu'à peine une personne sur 100 en
France je crois que c'est une mesure
extrêmement raisonnable merci José je le
dirai extrêmement modéré
très bien monsieur
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
les amendements sont pas exactement
identiques ils sont en discussion
commune celui de Monsieur Lucas a le
mérite d'être plus ciblé je dois avouer
même si j'ai énormément d'estime pour
Jérôme Guedj que les le sien et celui de
Madame Rousseau ont une cible un peu
plus élargie en réalité
ce qui pose question c'est c'est que
finalement
vous allez d'une certaine manière
entrer percuté des principes
fondamentaux du système par répartition
puisque les principes fondamentaux du
par répartition c'est la solidité
intergénérationnelle et le principe de
contributivité mais on est sur les
cotisations sur le travail là finalement
un travailleur qui est à la fin de sa
vie à pas à essayer de devenir
propriétaire et devenu propriétaire
c'est peut-être le seul bien qu'il a
aujourd'hui on a déjà une
reprise sur l'héritage pour financer
parfois la dette liée à la dépendance à
l'Ehpad à l'établissement lié au
handicap et donc on a déjà d'une
certaine manière une reprise qui est
parfois d'ailleurs injuste par rapport à
des gens qui ont gagné énormément
d'argent mais qui sont pas devenus
propriétaire on connaît des personnes
qui parfois peuvent gagner deux millions
d'euros et que qui payent plus de taxe
d'habitation et qui sont pas
propriétaires donc pas de taxe foncière
contribue pas au niveau local au
fonctionnement et qui à l'arrivée à la
fin de la vie ne sont pas devenus
propriétaire et il y a aucune
récupération sur l'héritage puisqu'ils
ont profité de la vie ce ceux qui sont
des salariés de classe moyenne et qui
ont au prix d'une vie de travail sont
devenues propriétaires aujourd'hui je
trouverai injuste qu'on vienne récupérer
sur eux sur les ritage finalement pour
financer la retraite de ceux
qui arrivent et donc là je pense que
c'est une question de justice sociale
par rapport à la pérennité du notre
système et paradoxalement vous allez
ouvrir une porte sur le capital alors
que vous voulez surtout pas être sur la
capitalisation très bien mais vous le
donner au système par répartition il
faut pas aller sur ce champ là la parole
est à Monsieur turquois
merci madame la Présidente donc une fois
de plus certains disent qu'ils veulent
préserver le système par répartition
mais par les amendements ils ont modifié
profondément la nature si on fiscalise
une partie une partie des ressources de
ce système là ce ne sera plus un système
par répartition et au niveau au niveau
politique dès qu'il y aura un effort à
faire on ira chercher du côté de la
fiscalité plutôt que du côté de la
solidarité entre génération donc cette
cette contribution peut avoir du sens au
niveau de l'examen du PLF parce que on
peut se poser des questions sur sur
l'accumulation notamment des patrimoines
et et des héritages mais à n'a pas sa
place ici dans le cadre d'une réflexion
sur le maintien et la pérennité d'un
système par répartition
enfin je voudrais me joindre au propos
de notre de notre collègue Prisca
théveno qui s'exprimait tout à l'heure
le RN on entend vraiment pourquoi ils
sont contre on sait pas pourquoi ils
sont pour donc je pense que ça serait
bien qui expliquent un petit peu leur
position sur le sujet
très bien monsieur de Courson
oui mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement intéressant
mais moi je crois qu'il n'a pas sa place
dans ce texte
il pourrait avoir sa place dans le
financement de la branche dépendance là
il y aurait je pense un débat
intéressant mais certainement pas dans
la vieillesse pour l'argument d'ailleurs
on doit le répéter depuis 15 ou 20 fois
qui est que vous n'aurez pu un système
de retraite par répartition si vous
commencez à alimenter le régime
vieillesse comme cela à moins que vous
l'affectiez mais c'est pas le cas à des
prestations non contributives
ce qui a été fait d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que Arrco
finance et claque finance les avantages
vieillesse ça ça pourrait avoir un sens
mais je pense qu'il faut réserver ce
débat à
la loi qu'on attend depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant sur la dépendance
très bien monsieur jumelles
oui je m'interrogeais sur le jeu de rôle
entre le RN qui toutes les demi-heures
tondent nous mordre les mollets comme
des bergers allemands et puis les
macronistes une sorte de partie de
ping-pong incompréhensible parce que
vous avez dit les avec les macronistes
pour obtenir la motion référendaire et
donc vous vous tentez toutes les
demi-heures toutes les toutes les
demi-heures vous tentez de nous mordre
les mollets comme des bergers allemands
sans jamais d'ailleurs nous faire mal
parce que nous avons bien compris que
d'une certaine manière vous êtes les
idiots utiles de la macronie sur ce
texte comme sur tous les autres
très bien sur ce nous allons donc passer
mes chers collègues au vote après ses
propos
pertinents alors je mets aux voix
l'amendement 70-13 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
de Madame Rousseau 55 502 même avis même
vote
même avis même vote pour le l'amendement
de Monsieur Guedj je vous remercie
monsieur Guedj vous avez la parole pour
le 747
Thomas très bien
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente alors cet
amendement vise à créer une taxe sur les
supers profits des des grandes
entreprises afin de financer les cinq
branches de la sécurité sociale notre
démarche n'est pas celle de dénigrer
l'ambition de cet amendement est de
faire contribuer dans un contexte où 174
milliards de bénéfices ont été réalisés
par le CAC 40 en 2020 21 un record
absolu car la France est championne
d'Europe des dividendes alors les
actionnaires français sont tout
bonnement parmi les mieux rémunérés et
le patron de l'ONU Antonio Gutierrez
lanceur d'alerte en la matière a invité
le gouvernements à taxer davantage leur
grandes entreprises tout
particulièrement celle qui collecte par
effet de bord les fruits amer de la
crise économique et géopolitique
pendant ce temps on demande aux Français
de se serrer la ceinture et on les
abandonne à l'idée inflexible de devoir
travailler plus longtemps nous avons
pourtant dès l'été dernier posé sur la
table des outils pour débattre avec les
Français le référendum d'initiative
partagée sur les super profits qui peut
ouvrir une réflexion nationale
essentielle si ce débat ne prend pas
corps à travers les institutions nous
constatons aujourd'hui que des millions
de Français dans la rue nous rappellent
leur légitimité de citoyens à vouloir
s'inviter dans la réflexion sur l'avenir
de leur retraite et par la même dans ce
débat incontournable de mieux répartir
la richesse dans notre pays ils ont bien
compris que l'effort demandé celui de
travailler plus longtemps et pour eux
l'immobilisme face aux grandes
entreprises dans la période agace dans
un contexte où l'effort national et
permanent pour les catégories moyennes
et populaires
alors quid des grandes entreprises
quelle est leur responsabilité le
président de la République avait sonné
la fin de l'abondance la responsabilité
nationale mérite d'être mieux partagée
c'est une revendication qui monte dans
les circonscriptions comme mon collègue
Jérôme guedjilo defend nous refusons un
impôt sur la vie au détriment de la
possibilité des entreprises générales
vous avez la parole
merci
madame la Présidente alors c'est un
débat qu'on a eu à multiples reprises
ces dernières semaines en PLFSS en PLF
en PLFR il y a eu une mission flash de
notre assemblée je rappelle qu'il existe
une contribution sociale additionnelle à
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui
représentent 3,3% de de l'IS du pour les
entreprises réalisant un chiffre
d'affaires d'au moins 7,63 millions
d'euros et dont l'impôt dépasse 763000
euros je vous rappelle également que
l'Union européenne allégiférer en 2022
sur ce sujet qui peut désormais
maintenant prélever 33% des bénéfices
imposables de certaines multinationales
en 2022 avec cette contribution
temporaire l'Union européenne contre
récupérer 25 milliards d'euros les fonds
seront redistribués au ménage et aux
entreprises des États membres c'est donc
un avis défavorable
très bien monsieur dit Philippot
oui merci madame la Présidente vous
savez il y a force de débattre des
heures des heures du même sujet de
manier les concepts dans tous les sens
je crois qu'il y a quelque chose qu'on
oublie c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
financement des retraites il repose sur
le travail et quand vous voulez prélever
je ne sais combien de milliards d'euros
sur les entreprises parce que l'air de
rien cette petite taxe qui a l'air
inoffensive de prime abord alors je peux
pas faire d'étude d'impact détaillé mais
ça représente au moins un doublement de
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
entreprises concernées et à 750 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires ont
descend quand même assez bas et bien il
faut mesurer aussi ce que ça représente
en termes d'emplois détruit
d'investissement détruit sur le sur le
territoire national et derrière de
pertes pour notre système de sécurité
sociale et toutes ces branches et ça je
pense que dans votre philosophie vous ne
le mesurez pas l'histoire nous enseigne
une chose tous les systèmes qui ont mis
en place votre idéologie et bien on
contribué à paupériser les pays qui
l'ont fait alors à un moment donné faut
juste revenir un peu plus de rationalité
et juste penser que le travail ce n'est
pas forcément le bagne et que on ne
construit rien dans un pays sans travail
merci madame la Présidente
je m'inscris totalement dans la
continuité de l'argumentaire fait pas
mon collègue dit Philippot
on n'est pas du tout sur le sujet du de
la préservation du système par
répartition ni de sa pérennité dans le
temps mais je vais quand même revenir
sur sur ce sujet des super dividendes
parce qu'effectivement on en a beaucoup
parlé on en reparlera peut-être
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour le
président Mathilde il y avait quelques
limites et quelques effets de bord à
cette à cette proposition la première
bien évidemment c'est qu'elle touchait
les entreprises de manière parfaitement
aveugle ça avait été construit dans le
cadre de voilà de profiteurs de crise de
la guerre en Ukraine sauf que quand on
avait fait les modèles de simulation et
je pense que c'est exactement les mêmes
qui sont repris dans cet article vous
veniez impacter Michelin mais par
ailleurs vous ne touchiez pas total qui
était pourtant si souvent cité ça c'est
le premier effet de bord le deuxième
effet de bord c'est que en fait il ne
touche que les porteurs d'action
français et donc c'est à dire que un
fond de pension américain qui détient
des actions Michelin sera taxées mais un
petit porteur français qui détient les
mêmes actions lui sera concerné donc en
termes de préférence nationale on est
vraiment dans les faits inverse le
troisième par ailleurs c'est qu'il vient
toucher que des entreprises françaises
et là c'est encore plus savoureux parce
que un détenteur d'une action Airbus va
payer mais un détenteur d'une action
Boeing pour le coup serait épargné et
enfin moi je pense que ce sujet là il a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre on a eu
beaucoup de discussions parce qu'il
vient toucher à un point extrêmement
essentiel qui est celui de la
répartition de la valeur ajoutée qui
suit de le partage de la valeur ça n'a
rien à voir avec cette commission je
pense aujourd'hui mais moi j'ai une
petite PME dans ma circonscription qui
s'appelle Dassault Aviation et Dassault
Aviation ils ont un modèle depuis leur
naissance s'appelle le modèle des trois
tiers un tiers salarié un tiers
entreprise un tiers actionnaire et ben
c'est aussi sur ce genre de modèle
aujourd'hui qu'on doit aller ça sera je
l'espère d'autres débats plus tard dans
notre dans notre dans notre assemblée ça
n'a rien à voir ici avec le modèle pas
répartition mais en tout cas ouvrons le
débat mais au bon moment la parole est à
Monsieur Charles de Courson
mes chers collègues cet amendement c'est
une contribution exceptionnelle valable
pendant trois ans
expliquez-moi comment vous financez un
système pérenne avec une contribution
exceptionnelle qui expire d'après votre
texte en 2025
ça tient pas
indépendamment du fait que en fait c'est
la taxation des des surprofuits
préconiser d'ailleurs par l'Union
européenne mais c'est pas fait pour
financer les retraites
très bien la parole est à Madame tailler
paulian merci madame la Présidente oui
juste en réponse on nous accuse de
vouloir toujours taxer les entreprises
et un collègue LR disait dans votre
système ça n'a jamais marché mais le
système où votre idéologie à vous
monsieur a été mis en place c'est-à-dire
le libéralisme ultralibéralisme celui-là
il produit aujourd'hui inégalité
pauvreté et catastrophe climatique donc
je pense que votre magnifique est
merveilleux système mériterait d'être
réformé deux font en comble et notamment
pour revenir sur un débat qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure par une meilleure
répartition des des produits du travail
entre le capital et le travail pour
mieux rémunérer le travail et si on
rémunéré mieux les salariés qu'on leur
donnait des meilleurs conditions de
travail qu'est-ce qui se passerait eh
ben on aurait plus de cotisations et on
n'aurait pas de problème de retraite
je veux rebondir sur l'argument qui a
été déployé fort justement par Charles
de Courson parce que en effet le
caractère exceptionnel de ces
super profits
et
dégager une ressource qui est
susceptible de venir abonder
les branches concernées et moi je suis
prêt à sous-amender si en séance ça
permet d'obtenir l'hymne prématour si
précieux de Charles de Courson pour que
c'est super profit n'aborde plus cette
fois-ci les branches parce qu'en effet
il y a quelque chose d'aléatoire mais
par exemple le fond de réserve des
retraites c'est à dire que si on dit à
un moment donné que pendant une période
donnée il y a des supers profits on les
met de côté on les taxe on les met de
côté dans ce fond de réserve des
retraites qui lui peut être utilisé
comme de besoins pour lisser ça déjà été
fait dans le passé à partir de 2008-2009
ça s'appelle pas de la ça s'appelle pas
de la capitalisation excusez-moi je
crois pas que quand Lionel Jospin est
créé le fond de réserve des retraites en
2001 il avait une logique de
capitalisation il avait une jolie il
avait une logique qui consistait à se
dire que dans des moments conjoncturels
de creux démographique pour équilibrer
les régimes des retraites il pourrait
être utile d'aller
puiser dans ce fond de réserve des
retraites donc si vous voulez qu'on nous
puissions la bomber et ben essayons de
chercher des mesures temporaires qui
abondent se font pour une utilisation
conjoncturelle donc si ça vous permet
d'aller dans le sens moi je suis pour
qu'on mobilise les réserves des
retraites il reste plus que 26 ou 29
milliards d'euros mais si on recharge ce
FLR qui a été singulièrement siphonné
notamment après la crise de 2008 et ben
on pourrait se mettre d'accord sur cette
disposition
très bien mes chers collègues donc nous
allons passer au vote de cet amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant le 59 91 il est défendu parquet
très bien allez-y merci madame la
Présidente quelques mots pour présenter
cet amendement il s'agit là de créer une
taxe sur les milliardaires ainsi que la
proposer Oxfam alors je sais que ça ne
vous plaît pas et je sais que vous dites
c'est c'est incroyable cette nupette qui
prétend préserver la retraite par
répartition qui nous propose que de la
fiscalité en fait c'est des méchants pas
beaux qui veulent la retraite par
capitalisation
alors évidemment non notre la retraite
par répartition évidemment et notre
modèle et d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
dire notamment monsieur turquois qui
nous accuse régulièrement de ça comme
croyant avoir là enfin démasqué notre
double langage mais mes chers amis mes
chers collègues de la majorité
proposez-nous une augmentation des
cotisations patronales et nous
retirerons tous nos amendements qui
portent sur la fiscalité il n'y a aucun
problème nous préférerions pouvoir
effectivement financer le système de
retraite grâce à une augmentation des
cotisations patronales pourquoi parce
que comme cela a été dit à de nombreuses
reprises déjà mais cela mérite toujours
le cas l'intérêt d'être redit ces
dernières années les entreprises ont vu
tellement d'aides et tellement de
diminution d'impôts pour eux pour elle
que une petite augmentation de
cotisations ne ne viendrait pas
certainement pas avancer donc faites je
vous en prie augmentons tous ensemble
les cotisations patronales ça nous
évitera de passer par la fiscalité
très bien monsieur Coulomme un pardon
madame la rapporteur pardon merci madame
la Présidente c'est un avis très
défavorable on est vraiment en désaccord
sur le fond et notre vision notre ce que
nous proposons dans la politique est
plutôt de faire en sorte et nous l'avons
fait depuis 2016 puisque les flux se
sont inversés à diminuer le nombre
d'expatriations et là l'amendement que
vous proposez est une véritable machine
à expatriation donc avis défavorable
très bien monsieur Coulomme vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente merci
alors comme nous sommes ici sur les
rangs de la nuque peut tout à fait
surpris que vous n'arriviez pas à
intégrer la nécessité la juste nécessité
d'une meilleure répartition de richesse
et que vous nous invitez souvent à
écouter votre pédagogie la pédagogie je
le rappelle c'est l'art d'enseigner aux
enfants et ben je vais faire moi aussi
un effort de pédagogie avec vous et je
vais
considérant que vous êtes malgré tout de
bonnes foi vous faire un petit exercice
de mathématiques presque un compte pour
enfants vous allez voir si les enfants
nous écoutent écoutez bien les enfants
nous sommes 60 millions de Français à
être impactés par votre réforme des
retraites 60 millions de Français à qui
vous allez carotter deux années de
retraite je fais un petit calcul
mathématique très simple prenez vos
calculs
60 millions x 2 ans ça fait combien
d'années vous l'auriez même fait
mentalement 120 millions d'années
c'est-à-dire que vous allez quand même
retirer au peuple de France 120 millions
d'années de retraite c'est à dire que ça
nous reporte au crétacés ou au
Jurassique entre les deux les enfants
vous voyez c'est l'époque des dinosaures
et bien pendant cette même période de
120 millions d'années
Bernard Arnault lui qui a accumulé une
richesse de 200 milliards prenez à
nouveau vos calculettes 200 milliards
divisés par 120 millions d'années c'est
un petit peu comme si Bernard Arnault
depuis les dinosaures de il y a 120
millions d'années avait tous les ans
touché 1666 euros voilà et comme il me
reste encore un petit peu de temps de
pédagogie je vais vous en faire une
autre 200 milliards d'euros depuis que
Bernard Arnault est né c'est-à-dire il y
a 73 ans c'est comme si tous les jours
tous les jours depuis qu'il est né
depuis qu'il a fait son petit caca dans
sa culotte et ben il a touché 7 millions
600.000 euros tous les ans tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours
depuis qu'il est né 7 millions 600 000
euros c'est à dire bien plus que le gros
lot de la Loterie Nationale auquel vous
vous invitez les Français à jouer pour
rééquilibrer l'équilibre des chances à
la naissance et bien voilà si vous
trouvez que ceci est juste et qu'il
aimerait effectivement les enfants
continuaient à voter pour Bernard
Arnault enfin merci bien monsieur le
député mais franchement l'enfant que je
suis j'ai pas bien compris parce que
vous êtes parti d'un chiffre de 60
millions il y a pas 60 millions d'actifs
parce qu'il va falloir enlever
effectivement il va falloir enlever déjà
tous les retraités et tous les jeunes
donc votre site de 60 millions il est à
revoir parce que j'ai toujours pas
compris monsieur Boucard vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente je vois
d'abord remercier le rateur précédent
pour son effort de pédagogie je me sens
beaucoup moins bête à l'heure actuelle
qui a qui a 2 minutes vraiment merci à
lui et je vois il me féliciter de ce
débattre qui est vraiment très
intéressant en fait on est en train de
refaire dans cette commission le débat
entre communisme capitaliste etc etc et
moi j'entends à mon avis la déception
des Français qui aiment qui attendent de
cette commission à débat sur le système
de retraite et moi je ne pensais pour
les collègues qui sont là depuis lundi
matin ce qui n'est pas mon casque je ne
suis pas loin de cette commission tant
mieux pour moi qui finalement travaille
depuis trois jours depuis trois jours et
vous n'avez pas encore abordé le système
de retraite parce que la vraie question
ce que veulent entendre les Français
c'est ce que vous allez faire les uns
les autres ce que nous allons faire les
uns les autres sur l'article 7 est-ce
qu'il y aura le report de l'âge légal de
départ en retraite qu'est-ce que les
députés de la nation vont faire sur la
question des trimestres cotisés c'est la
seule vraie question de ce projet de loi
de réforme de retraite tout le reste
alors on peut parler un peu j'ai vu hier
vos débats très intéressant sur l'index
qu'il fallait déplacer à la virgule
presque c'était vraiment fascinant je
partage la vie de de Courson qui ne sert
pas à grand chose mais c'était
extrêmement intéressant mais la morale
c'est que vous allez clôturer ces débats
ce soir à 20h sans avoir abordé le
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
et je trouve que c'est vraiment
particulièrement de mal je voudrais dire
aux collègues qui qui parle pour parler
un peu de temps en temps que je crois
que les Français nous regardent et que
nous ne sommes pas dans cette commission
comme nous serions dans une
manifestation l'objectif n'est pas de
bloquer mais qu'à la fin les députés des
nations se prononcent pour ou contre ce
projet de loi de réforme et moi je suis
contre je le redis il y a pas de sujet
là-dessus mais qu'à la fin les députés
puissent se prononcer et qu'il n'y ait
pas un blocage de cette assemblée je
crois que ce serait la pire des
solutions aux yeux des Français
très bien merci monsieur le député
Monsieur Charles de Courson
mes chers collègues
voulaient la mort des milliardaires je
vous rassure je rassure
il suffit de filer ensuite au Luxembourg
en Belgique et l'affaire elle est réglée
vous n'aurez plus de milliardaire en
France c'est très simple mais je voulais
vous faire une deuxième observation vous
savez que le Conseil conditionnel a
estimait que la somme ISF est équivalent
plus IR plus taxe foncière par rapport
aux revenus ne devait pas dépasser 70
72%. donc je vous ai expliqué comment
les grandes fortunes françaises ne
payent pas l'ISF ne payez pas l'ISF elle
paieront pas plus votre amendement vous
croyez que ça va vous rapporter 12
milliards puisque la fortune des
milliardaires françaises doit tourner
autour de 600 milliards mais vous
n'aurez rien du tout
du temps de Liliane Bettencourt à son
âme Liliane Bettencourt ne payait pas
l'ISF
voilà grâce au système que je vous ai
expliqué tout à l'heure de la holding de
tête en fait etc voilà donc vraiment
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau et ça ne
sert à rien voilà
uniquement pour se faire plaisir
monsieur Lucas non vous ne voulez pas
merci bon rapidement
on a une vraie différence c'est vrai
nous on assume le fait que on n'aime pas
le fait qu'il y a des milliardaires
parce qu'on considère que moralement que
dans une société d'inégalité un individu
accumule accumule autant de richesse et
de ressources notamment de ressources
naturelles ça nous pose un problème
moral mais vous qui les aimer et vous en
avez le droit c'est sain et c'est normal
vous avez le droit d'aimer les
milliardaires on a on a renoncé à vous
convaincre de d'y mettre un terme mais
écoutez écoutez l'appel qu'ils ont lancé
le 22 janvier 2020 l'appel de 121
millionnaires et milliardaires à payer
plus de taxes pour réduire les
inégalités je cite je cite ces
milliardaires non justement chers
collègues ils demandent pas à faire un
chèque à faire l'aumône il demande à
payer plus de taxes et d'impôts ils
disent ils disent il y en avait donc
2100 il y a 2153 dans le monde à
l'époque millionnaire au milliardaire
milliardaire pardon et donc ils invitent
à avancer maintenant avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard ils disent il y a ceux qui
préfèrent les taxes et ceux qui
préféreront les c'est eux qui le disent
c'est les milliardaires c'est c'est pas
moi vous voyez presque qui pourrait
adhérer à la New peste les milliardaires
on les y invite d'ailleurs avec plaisir
et ils invitent avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard à payer à ce que à ce que les
pouvoirs publics à ce que les pouvoirs
publics à ce que les pouvoirs publics
exigent deux exige 2 des impôts plus
élevés et plus équitables je répète des
impôts plus élevés et plus équitables
donc vous voyez nous sommes là nous nous
essayons de transcrire dans la loi la
volonté des milliardaires vous voyez que
nous sommes extrêmement co-constructif
aujourd'hui très la parole est à
Monsieur Benz
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement permettez-moi de revenir
rapidement sur ce que le député Jumel a
évoqué tout à l'heure en parlant du
rassemblement national que nous
tiendrions un jeu de rôle avec vous dire
et que nous étions des idiots de la
macronie sur le jeu de rôle d'abord
monsieur jumelles ce n'est pas un jeu
cette réforme des retraites elle est
grave elle est injuste elle va toucher
les Français dans leur chair ce n'est
pas un jeu et deuxième chose les idiots
utiles écoutez utile en tout cas vous
vous l'êtes à la macronie c'est claire
et vous l'avez prouvé dimanche dernier
dans la deuxième circonscription de la
Marne vous avez appelé à voter pour une
candidate favorable à la réforme des
retraites donc concrètement concrètement
ce sera une voix de plus pour les
retraites donc vous faites le jeu vous
effectivement de la macronie
très bien donc mes chers collègues nous
allons abordons madame la rapporteur
général oui je voudrais merci madame la
Présidente répond à Monsieur Coulomme
parce que vous dites vouloir répartir
les richesses mais avec cet amendement
qui est encore une fois chasse les plus
riches de notre pays il vous n'aurez
plus aucune richesse dans ce pays
très bien monsieur jumelle
chez moi ça fait longtemps que je vous
ai parlé de ce territoire
extraordinairement beau j'ai la glace
vallée la filière derrière
78 entreprises 13000 emplois c'est là
que se fait tout le flaconnage des
parfums de luxe du monde entier
et c'est de là dont d'ailleurs Bernard
Arnault puise sa fortune alors je veux
expliquer ce qui nous perturbe
lorsqu'un verrier
fabrique un beau flacon de parfum
lorsqu'une trieuse de verre est mobilisé
pour trier les parfums fabriqués lorsque
un mouleur un décorateur de verre
travaille à faire en sorte que
ce fleuron du luxe français puisse être
dans les vitrines des Champs-Elysées la
valeur ajoutée la
vente de leur force de travail c'est 40
centimes par flacon lorsque le flacon se
vend 100 euros c'est à dire que leur
force de travail coûte 40 centimes
lorsque le flacon rapporte à Bernard
Arnault 100 euros donc vous voyez bien
qu'il y a un je vous assure que le corps
des verriers des trieuses de verre des
décorateurs de verre des mouleurs de
verre ne ne suivent pas de la même
manière
aussi lentement que celui que de la
fortune de Bernard Arnault qui prospère
tous les jours et donc quand on parle de
ça quand on parle de l'anesté de prendre
le pognon là où il est pour financer la
protection sociale là où il y en a
besoin on est au cœur du projet de la
réforme des retraites et on est au cœur
de ce pourquoi nous sommes ici pour
défendre la France qui travaille
très bien donc je vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
amendement pouvant être mis en
discussion commune madame taillé paulian
merci madame la Présidente par ces deux
amendements nous revenons à un mode de
financement peut-être un peu plus
traditionnel et qui est plus lié au
travail et à la pénibilité au travail
bon moi je note que le rassemblement
national a boss s'exprimer avec
précision toutes les demi-heures c'est
jamais pour rien proposer donc ils n'ont
rien à dire donc moi je propose par cet
amendement avec mes collègues du groupe
écologiste un de créer une contribution
des entreprises quand elles licencie
pour inaptitude au-delà de la raison
c'est à dire au-delà de la moyenne
aujourd'hui les entreprises licenciées
pour inaptitude et en fait
première intérêt de cette contribution
ça nous permettrait de mesurer le nombre
d'inaptitudes dans notre pays on est
aujourd'hui incapable de le faire
alors aujourd'hui dans notre pays il y a
des tas de salariés qui au bout d'un
certain temps de labeurs deviennent
inapte pourquoi parce qu'ils ont des
troubles musculo-squelettiques parce que
ils ont le dos à briser ils ne peuvent
plus exercer le métier qu'ils exercent
jusqu'à présent
dans le secteur public on ne peut pas
aller licencier et c'est tant mieux et
on travaille sur le fait de leur
proposer d'autres postes dans le secteur
privé on casse les travailleurs puis
après hop on s'en tape parce qu'on remet
ça sur le dos de la sécurité sociale de
l'assurance chômage etc etc on s'en tape
tellement qu'on sait même pas les
compter donc il serait temps de
responsabiliser les entreprises pour que
toutes je dis bien toutes les
entreprises quand elles ont un salarié
qui ne peut plus exercer son métier
parce que il est rendu inapte notamment
par la pénibilité d'une part elle fasse
vraiment le travail pour chercher un
autre poste et d'autre part si elles ont
trop de salariés qui sont déclarés
inaptés licenciés pour cela et bien
qu'elle verse une contribution parce que
cela veut dire que la politique de
prévention n'est pas à la hauteur parce
que cela veut dire qu'on ne prend pas
soin des travailleurs et des
travailleuses et c'est aussi cela qu'il
faut faire si on veut permettre aux gens
d'aller au bout et de Dark à la retraite
en bonne santé
très bien
madame
la Présidente
votre amendement est
écrit d'une façon qui ne permet pas
qu'il soit
l'amendement et écrit d'une telle façon
qui ne permet pas d'être effectif
puisque vous écrivez pour inaptitude
anormalement élevée mais que ce n'est
pas précisé donc on voit bien qu'on
pourrait pas le rendre effectif et
encore une fois c'est une imposition en
plus pour lesquelles je suis défavorable
très bien Madame kéké
merci madame la Présidente
par votre réforme des retraites vous
avez choisi de prendre deux ans de vie
supplémentaires aux gens qui souffrent
déjà au travail et pour qui le départ à
la retraite c'est vivre en fin
j'interviens en soutien de l'amendement
de ma collègue qui me tient beaucoup à
cœur beaucoup de métiers sont très
pénibles et les salariés souffrent
moralement mais aussi physiquement
contrairement à ce contrairement à ce
que vous pensez beaucoup de salariés
quittent le travail parce que leur corps
ne suit plus ce n'est pas par joie qu'il
passe mais parce que le médecin du
travail les met en
attitude et cette inaptitude vient à
causer des tendances lourdes et parfois
infernal et des gestes à répétitives
hier je vous ai parlé des 40 chambres
par jour on peut aussi parler des tonnes
que portent des caissières des cadences
des aides à domicile des infirmières
les salariés du bâtiment et bien
d'autres c'est donc normal que les
entreprises pardon qui licencie beaucoup
pour inaptitude soit taxé plus que les
autres parce que ce n'est pas normal que
les gens d'une même entreprise partent à
cause de l'inaptitude ça veut dire que
les conditions de travail sont
difficiles ou même horrible c'est pas
normal ça veut dire que ces entreprises
créent la pénibilité et c'est pas normal
qu'elle abîme les corps des gens il faut
donc les tasser plus ça les évitera
aussi à revoir les conditions de travail
des salariés et les améliorer
très bien monsieur de Courson
c'est un amendement intéressant mais il
sorte au problème de définir qu'est-ce
que c'est que un taux de licenciement
pour une aptitude anormalement élevée
c'est quoi anormalement élevé
tant qu'on n'aura pas défini ce que
c'est que la notion d'anormalité en la
matière
l'amendement est inefficace donc je vois
pas en l'état on peut pas voter un tel
amendement
très bien monsieur dit Philippot
entièrement d'accord avec les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus ne perdez pas
d'esprit d'une chose le but c'est
d'aménager les carrières notamment les
fins de carrière et l'évolution
professionnelle des gens pour qu'ils
puissent rester en emploi le plus
longtemps possible et certainement pas
et bien d'aller sanctionner les
entreprises sur la base de critères que
vous n'aurez même pas choisi puisque au
final ce sera fixé par décret ça vous
échappera complètement donc un moment il
faut être capable de faire confiance aux
branches professionnelles de leur fixer
une mission les objectifs et je pense
quels sont les mieux placés dans chacune
d'entre elles pour savoir comment faire
en sorte d'éviter ce type de situation
monsieur frappé
merci madame la Présidente je rejoins
effectivement les propos sur le taux
d'inaptitude d'abord mais surtout je
trouve qu'il faut une précision merci
une précision importante sur le
classement des entreprises vous mettez
là toutes les entreprises inaptitudes
lorsque les entreprises enregistrent un
taux de licenciement mais il est certain
que les entreprises diffèrent
fondamentalement dans ce dos en fonction
des postes proposés donc il manque une
précision là merci
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez intervenir oui merci madame
la Présidente je voulais répondre à
Madame kéké en disant parce que je pense
qu'on n'arrivera peut-être pas à
l'article 9 qui parle de la pénibilité
où nous simplifions le compte de
prévention professionnelle où nous où
nous l'augmentons en nombre de points où
nous créons un fond d'intervention
de prévention de 1 milliard qui
permettra des congés de reconversion et
puis le suivi médical régulier enfin
toutes ces mesures qui permettront avec
la prévention que les gens arrivent
certes peut-être un peu plus tard à la
retraite mais en meilleure état ou alors
qui pourront partir plus tôt
très bien je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
très bien il est rejeté même avis même
vote pour le suivant très bien monsieur
Lucas vous avez la parole
pour le merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente par ma collègue de gauche
pour l'occasion alors vous avez chers
collègues des sentiments profonds on l'a
compris pour les milliardaires pour les
millionnaires pour les
héritiers pour les rentiers
alors j'ai cherché quelqu'un ou quelque
chose d'autre à faire contribuer pour
épargner aux Français deux ans deux ans
de trop au travail et donc je vous
demande si vous seriez prêt à accepter
de faire cotiser les robots car ce
contrairement à ceux que j'ai
précédemment cité ils ne font pas partie
de votre électorat
et donc et donc je vous propose je vous
propose un principe très simple c'est
que dans
l'industrie du commerce alimentaire que
les machines qui ont remplacé des
salariés donc des cotisants et qui sont
utilisés pour augmenter la rentabilité
soit à contribution et il y a dans cet
amendement un centre de disposition qui
montre et qui plafonne qui montre que
c'est pas du tout
quelque chose de qui désinciterait à
investir mais au contraire quelque chose
qui permet de partager voilà donc je
pense que les robots ne vous en voudront
pas eux de les taxer un peu pour
protéger l'ensemble des humains qui eux
veulent passer deux années deux années
de sérénité de repos d'inquiétudes
plutôt que de travailler jusqu'à ce que
inaptitude ou morts s'en suivent
très bien monsieur Léo man
merci
madame la Présidente vous remettez alors
du jour la taxe robot la fameuse taxe
robot ça crée une nouvelle fois un impôt
et puis surtout est-ce que ça ne va pas
pénaliser les salariés qui travaillent
dans les magasins alimentaires je
m'étonne de cette joie de cette base
fiscale donc avis défavorable très bien
monsieur léoman pour le coup merci
madame la Présidente mon collègue vous
propose donc de mettre en place une taxe
sur les robots sur les machines et
notamment en réalité dans les grandes
surfaces c'est on a depuis plusieurs
jours un débat intéressant sur le
capital et le travail que fait une
machine à la fois elle travaille mais en
même temps elle détruit un certain
nombre de travaux qui existent mais on
ne peut pas être contre le fait
d'installer des machines puisque il
s'agit de travail de travaux qui sont
pénible et pour nous éviter la
pénibilité du travail et bien ça fait
partie de nos objectifs et d'ailleurs
c'est un long débat qui a eu lieu au
final depuis le 19e siècle et qui pour
la gauche était celui d'un monde idéal
dans lequel les machines remplaceraient
un jour peut-être le travail des humains
et permettrait précisément aux êtres
humains de se reposer donc nous ne
pouvons pas être contre cela mais
néanmoins puisque ces machines
détruisent du travail et bien en les
taxant nous pourrions du coup avoir une
contribution sur le travail qu'elle
produisent néanmoins
je veux vous dire que ce débat il avait
lieu au 19e siècle et au 19e siècle les
ouvriers souvent détruisaient ces
machines parce que ils avaient
l'impression de se faire voler leur
travail il y a eu des révoltes ludisme
notamment mais aussi celle des Canuts et
je voudrais puisque nous avons un petit
peu de temps vous lire la chanson des
Canuts parce que je la trouve magnifique
et que peut-être elle vous fera
réfléchir pour gouverner il faut avoir
manteau et rubans en sautoir nous
anticipons pour vous grande de la terre
et nous pauvres Canut Sandra on nous
enterre c'est nous les canuts nous
allons tout nus mais notre règne
arrivera quand votre règne finira nous
tisserons le linceul du vieux monde car
on entend déjà la révolte qui gronde
entendait la révolte qui gronde 2,8
millions de personnes dans la rue hier
pour vous dire de retirer votre texte de
la réforme des retraites
[Musique]
très honnêtement si nous concitoyens
regardent ces débats mais ils doivent
être totalement affligé
affligé je veux bien qu'on fasse du
travail parlementaire mais déposer des
amendements aussi stupides bêtes
simplement pour faire valoir sa culture
qui ne serviront à rien le débat qui ne
serviront pas à aborder les sujets
essentiels qu'il est nécessaire de
corriger dans ce projet de loi et dont
il faut que nous parlions bien sûr la
question de l'âge la question des
carrières des femmes des carrières
hachées la question de la pénibilité la
question des carrières longues vous vous
faites plaisir mais vous faites ridicule
vous faites ridicule et vous ne servez
pas l'intérêt des Français
arrêtez voilà il faut que nous puissions
parler des sujets de fonds mais très
honnêtement voilà vous desservez vous
vous desservez les Français vous
desservez les sujets les plus importants
vous êtes santé c'est servir alors je
veux bien que vous fassiez plaisir pour
étaler votre culture mais là on est ici
pour parler de la vie des gens de la
sauvegarde du système par répartition et
c'est ce qui intéresse les Français et
je vois toujours que le rapport au
travail et voilà il n'est absolument pas
une valeur que vous partagez j'en suis
absolument absolument atterré
très bien je t'en applaudis pas s'il
vous plaît madame Laurence et
d'elle-grière
je me permets d'intervenir c'est la
première fois que je suis présente dans
cette commission et je suis assez étonné
du contenu des débats je pensais qu'on
allait parler de la retraite et qu'on
allait s'occuper de sauver le système
par répartition moi ce que je constate
là c'est des échanges qui visent à
augmenter le du moins rajouter des taxes
des taxes et des taxes ok la question
c'est qui est-ce qui va les payer ces
taxes parce que lorsqu'on lorsque l'on
va augmenter ses taxes je pense que le
premier réflexe d'un magasin de produits
alimentaires ça va être de répercuter
ces taxes sur quoi sur le prix des
produits vendus et donc qu'est-ce que ça
va ça va entraîner ça va entraîner une
augmentation des prix des produits
achetés par l'ensemble des citoyens et
donc ça va entraîner une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat donc en gros votre
proposition c'est de baisser le pouvoir
d'achat pour pouvoir financer les
retraites moi ça m'interroge beaucoup il
me semble qu'il est plus intelligent de
se poser la question de travailler
peut-être un peu plus mais au moins en
préservant le pouvoir d'achat et des
retraités et des salariés
très bien Madame La Valette
madame la Présidente
merci mes chers collègues il reste trois
heures de commission et c'est vrai que
j'aurais aimé que vos obsessions de la
nuit pêche sur les millionnaires les
taxes les taxes sur les sociétés l'impôt
sur la fortune se déplace et que vous
preniez quand même compte massif il faut
prendre conscience en fait que toutes
les ambitions sociales de ce pays ne
sont possibles que par la natalité c'est
un sujet qui a été à peine effleuré et
dont nous n'aurons évidemment pas le
temps de parler vu l'heure alors mes
chers collègues on a bien vu les
réactions pavlovienne que vous avez à la
nupestre tant à la nupesque à la
majorité finalement il y a que Monsieur
Bazin qui a pu en parler normalement on
sait pas très bien ce que les familles
vous ont fié pour vous les détestiez
autant mais c'est surtout inquiétant
parce qu'encore une fois toutes les
ambitions sociales ne sont possibles que
par là chers collègues de la nuit Pesse
et de la majorité souvenez-vous sans la
natalité des trentes glorieuses il y
aurait pas eu 1981 sans les enfants de
la prière il y a pas de programme commun
il y a aucune des avancées sociales de
la fin du 20e siècle c'est si important
comment se fait-il que nous ayons
complètement éludé éluder le sujet je
vous rappelle que le dernier
gouvernement de droite comme de gauche
tout le monde sera content emporter un
coup majeur aux politiques familiales
dans notre pays que ce soit la
diminution bien sûr des compléments du
mode de garde la majoration de la
location familiales le plafonnement
fortement abaissé je vous rappelle que
vous preniez comme exemple ou
l'Allemagne ou l'Italie et vous savez
très bien que ces deux pays où les
gouvernements ont été menés par des
parties socialistes locaux ont mené les
politiques macroniennes avant nous et on
peut voir les effets qu'ils ont eu et ça
plonger leur pays dans une spirale
démographique absolument terrible encore
une fois ce système de retraite vous le
savez c'est l'équilibre entre les
recettes et les dépenses les recettes on
ne peut pas faire l'impasse de la
natalité comme du plein emploi comme de
la productivité je regrette bien que
nous n'ayons pas pu en parler je vous
rappelle quand même que Marine Le Pen
proposait que le deuxième enfant soit
une demi par fils soit une part fiscale
pleine c'est un amendement que nous
avions posé qui n'a pas été qui n'a pas
été accepté je le regrette bien il est
dommage que la démographie n'est pas
pris plus de place dans cette commission
je le regrette vraiment
contre la natalité c'est être antisocial
Sibille
lui seul à la parole s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues
Madame La Valette
merci ma présidente
en tant que en tant que député de la
métropole de Lyon je ne pouvais que
réagir par rapport au canuts
s'il vous plaît c'est 1831 c'est des
personnes qui sont payées à la pièce qui
n'ont aucune retraite
c'est des métiers où on embauche les
enfants parce que avec leurs petites
mains ils sont les seuls à pouvoir
passer dans les médias tissés donc ne
mélangez pas les débats là on parle de
retraite et et heureusement les
conditions de travail ont évolué grâce à
un système social qu'on souhaite
préserver par répartition
très bien monsieur Lucas s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît monsieur Lucas
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît monsieur léoman s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît Monsieur Léon non monsieur léoman
non taisez-vous seul monsieur Lucas s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît monsieur
mais nous savons que certains tiennent
dans cette commission des propos
outranciers ne réagissons pas la parole
est à Monsieur Lucas et à lui seul je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
Présidente moi je suis assez
pas moi je suis assez atterré par le
niveau d'argumentaire en réponse à la
proposition que je viens de formuler sur
le fait de faire cotiser les robots qui
méconnaient des travaux économiques et
scientifiques qui ont lieu depuis des
années et
si je peux si je peux éviter de me faire
agresser par la collègue au bout de la
salle ce serait très agréable même la
Présidente je
madame ce n'est pas moi chers collègues
chers collègues ce n'est pas moi qui
vous donne un cours en l'occurrence
c'est Bill Gates ça devrait vous plaire
il est milliardaire dans une interview
publié dans un magazine américain Bill
Gates propose de taxer les robots à un
niveau
identique à celui des salariés afin de
financer l'adaptation de la société à la
transformation du travail cela
compenserait les pertes de recettes
fiscales de l'État duo destruction
d'emploi d'une part et aiderait à
financer les politiques sociales de
réinsertion professionnelle d'autre part
donc moi je veux bien que vous fassiez
tout pour éviter d'avoir un débat
sérieux sur comment on finance les
retraites autrement autrement qu'en
allant privé les français et notamment
les plus modestes de deux années de vie
et de deux années de vie en bonne santé
mais s'il vous plaît essayez au moins
d'avoir des arguments qui sont un
minimum rationnel et intelligent on y
gagnera du temps
les arguments intelligents pertinents et
pas outrancier très bien alors madame
Parmentier le code a demandé la parole
et ensuite Monsieur Charles de Courson
merci merci madame la Présidente non je
voulais souligner quand même une
nouvelle fois s'il vous plaît on
s'écoute mes chers collègues on s'écoute
merci je voulais souligner une nouvelle
fois le mode opératoire de la news de la
mélenchonie qui consiste à invectiver à
insulter à raconter n'importe quoi enfin
dire que nos collègues sont pour
l'esclavage ou pour le travail des
enfants pour provoquer des réactions et
ensuite obtenir leur belle petite vidéo
où on est tous sur excité dans cette
commission voilà leur mode opératoire le
même qu'ils ont parfois sur les marchés
pendant les campagnes c'est inadmissible
c'est antidémocratique ça ça plus les
mensonges comme de dire hier que pendant
qu'il manifestait vous étiez nous nous
étions soi-disant la buvette alors qu'on
recevait le président de la Rada
d'Ukraine mais vraiment c'est mensonges
sur mensonges
arrêtez maintenant très bien la parole
s'il vous plaît
la parole est à Monsieur Charles de
Courson la parole est à monsieur de
Courson et lui seul s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues
cet amendement est intéressant puisqu'on
font il s'inspire on pourrait le dire
que c'est un amendement Canut
c'est à dire de ceux qui croient qu'en
freinant l'automutilisation et en
réduisant la pénibilité du travail
humain on fait progresser l'humanité
c'est exactement l'inverse
est-ce que vous avez déjà été caissière
ou caissier
bon oui et ben vous savez quand vous
faites ça pendant 30 ans de votre vie
vous avez des problèmes de TMS
et donc l'automatisation des caisses est
un progrès social et donc toutes les
taxes qui visent à empêcher
l'automatisation la mécanisation
c'est-à-dire à ralentir ou à empêcher
l’alément de la dureté du travail humain
va dans un sens contraire à l'intérêt
des travailleurs et surtout des
travailleuses en l'espèce donc il faut
absolument repousser cet amendement
très bien monsieur Valtou oui madame oui
madame la Présidente écoutez je crois
que dans trois heures dans 3 heures nos
débats vont s'arrêter et et on arrive au
terme de trois jours de débat qui
finalement ont été assez vins parce
qu'effectivement on a en face de nous on
a en face de nous des effectivement des
députés qui ont finalement un mépris de
la démocratie parlementaire qui ont qui
ont le mythe qui vit dans le mythe de la
rue le mythe de la révolution de la rue
le mythe de la de la manifestation qui
va tout renverser le mythe des sondages
qui doivent gouverner notre pays et le
mythe de ce peuple qui doit se déverser
sur les institutions il y a on a assisté
à trois jours de proposition totalement
vide totalement
idiote totalement inapte des amendements
inutiles des logos et sans fin le rappel
aux grandes heures révolutionnaires
comme si c'est comme ça qu'on pouvait
faire avancer un pays au XXIe siècle
tout ça est vain mais on voit comme ça à
quel point il y a une détestation du
débat parlementaire et de construction
parlementaire c'est une détestation
profonde chez les députés de LFI
particulièrement chez les députés de la
nups malheureusement par par
contamination qui fait qu'effectivement
on ne peut pas débattre sereinement et
on n'a pas pu débattre sereinement des
vrais sujets c'est dommage mais ça
préfigure ce qui nous attend
effectivement dans les prochains dans
les prochains jours je le regrette et
effectivement l'auteur de l'amendement
puisqu'il veut une réponse sur le fond
monsieur de Courson a très bien démontré
c'est un amendement idiot pour faire
nous faire perdre du temps comme tous
les amendements je le répète c'est un
amendement idiot voilà
très bien merci bien monsieur le député
alors sur ce sur ce mes chers collègues
mes chers collègues alors nous allons
nous allons passer au vote alors sur
l'amendement 700012 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable
qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
c'est bon très bien mes chers collègues
je fais une suspension de 10 minutes
merci
nous allons
avec Madame la rapporteur général cher
Stéphanie reprendrent et nous passons
tout de suite à l'amendement suivant le
70 35 et maintenant de Monsieur Monnet
merci madame la Présidente
juste pour dire que contrairement à ce
qu'il n'y paraît c'est avant la pose et
peut-être parfois malgré quelques excès
de langage et contrairement à ce que
certains pensent nous étions bien au
cœur du débat
c'est la question du financement du
système des retraites il y a pas besoin
d'attendre l'article 7 pour être au cœur
de ce débat important et je pense que si
les esprits se sont un peu échauffés
c'est justement parce que nous sommes au
cœur de nos points de divergence
c'est à dire que notre divergence elle
est elle est non mais c'est pas que les
robots
notre divergence elle est claire vous
vous êtes davantage dans l'option de
contraindre les dépenses et nous nous
sommes dans la recherche de nouvelles
recettes et on a fait un certain nombre
de provisions maintenant vous ne pourrez
plus dire qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution puisque c'est pas faute de vous
en avoir fait preuve en est mais ça
c'est notre point de divergence et nous
nous non l'idée qu'il faut de nouvelles
recettes pour obtenir une retraite qui
correspondent aux besoins des retraités
et aux besoins du monde du travail et
d'ailleurs c'est l'objet de l'amendement
que je défends qui je pense devrait
faire consensus vu ce que j'ai entendu
nous ne mettons pas à contribution les
entreprises nous mettons directement à
contribution capital à travers une
contribution sur les dividendes
qui n'est que de 2% donc une règle pas
la totalité du besoin de financement de
du système des retraites mais quand même
qui permet de contribuer à faire venir
de nouvelles recettes sur notre système
et de pérenniser le système par
répartition je vous remercie
très bien Madame madame la rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente je crois
qu'on a eu le débat qui va sur la
branche autonomie donc qui ne va pas
être sur la branche vieillesse c'est
encore une une imposition et donc un
avis défavorable
très bien
Madame Leduc
oui merci madame la Présidente je veux
profiter de cet amendement pour revenir
un peu sur les débats un peu échaudés
qu'on a eu tout à l'heure et je voudrais
qu'on évite de tomber dans la caricature
vous nous vous nous mettez souvent face
à cette question qu'on serait
caricaturaux et en fait je trouve que la
caricature est plutôt sur vos rangs vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure qu'on
souhaitait la mort des milliardaires je
vous rassure on ne souhaite pas la mort
des milliardaires et on ne mange pas non
plus les enfants si on doit parler de
mort ici et si le mot mort doit venir
sur le tapis c'est de la mort avancée de
nos concitoyens donc dont on doit parler
avancer par cette réforme des retraites
qui va plus abîmer les corps et rogner
de l'espérance de vie parce que c'est ça
la réalité de cette réforme et rogner
des années de vie heureuse à la retraite
il s'agit pas de supprimer physiquement
les milliardaires il s'agit de partage
alors maintenant quand on parlera de
milliardaire je vous demanderai
d'entendre ce mot là ce mot de partage
qui est un mot qui est beau et qui doit
raisonner et qui donne partout dans la
population lorsqu'on demande lorsqu'on
exige un impôt un impôt qui est aussi un
joli mot un impot juste on parle de ça
on parle de partage des richesses donc
d'ailleurs si vous ne souhaitez pas nous
écouter nous écouter écouter les eux les
millionnaires puisque 200 millionnaires
dont deux Français ont signé le 18
janvier une tribune réclamant d'être
taxé davantage afin d'aider à combattre
les inégalités je cite la solution est
évidente pour tous évidente pour tous
vous ne représentants mondiaux devaient
nous taxer nous les Ultra riches et vous
devez commencer maintenant ont-ils
réclamé donc c'est amendement de notre
collègue Monet vise à mettre à
contribution c'est c'est dividendes
versées aux actionnaires c'est une
contribution plus que raisonnable il l'a
dit et je le rappelle les dividendes
versées par le CAC 40 cette année
représente plus de 80 milliards d'euros
c'est un record et si on prend
l'ensemble des dividendes versés en
France on dépasse les 250 milliards
d'euros donc c'est bien de partage et de
justice dont on est en train de parler
de partage des richesses c'est ce que
demande la très grande majorité de la
population et je rebondirai aussi sur le
caractère antidémocratique que vous qui
nous a été dit tout à l'heure
merci madame la Présidente si nous
sommes là c'est pour débattre du système
de retraite on a des défis à relever il
y a le vieillissement de la population
on a des déficits à venir il faut qu'on
trouve les solutions pour pouvoir
assurer un niveau de pension à ceux qui
sont retraités
pardon excusez-moi monsieur Ruffin j'ai
pas recommencé mais on est sur un sur
une nécessité de trouver des solutions
j'ai peur qu'avec vos amendements qui
sont dans une vision qui est cohérente
avec ce que vous portez mais qui est
d'une certaine manière il y a des
richesses faut qu'on les partage mais
vous oubliez à mon avis une vision
dynamique c'est qu'avant qui est des
richesses il faut qu'elle puisse être
créée et la création de richesse par le
travail ça permet à terme de pouvoir
soutenir notre système de protection
sociale et c'est vrai que notre système
de protection sociale si demain on ne
travaille plus qu'on est dans le temps
libre permanent on ne pourra pas
soutenir notre système de protection
sociale quand vous parlez de dividendes
pour qui est dividende il faut qu'il y
ait du résultat pour qu'il y ait du
résultat faut qu'il y ait eu du travail
et d'une certaine manière le travail
plus on va valoriser ce travail plus ça
va être gagnant-gagnant pour ceux qui
travaillent et ceux plutôt à la retraite
et on porte de belles valeurs celle de
la solidarité intergénérationnelle qui
est menacé par un système de retraite
par répartition qui aujourd'hui a une
dette programmée et donc si on ne trouve
pas de solution il y a des inquiétudes
sur les maires de famille certains les
ont commencé à les porter il y a des
inquiétudes sur les parcours sur la
pénibilité il y a des inquiétudes sur le
cumulant plan retraite et les
inquiétudes sur la retraite progressive
il faut qu'on aille sur ces sujets là et
je pense très sincèrement que c'est une
responsabilité collective au niveau de
notre commission de pouvoir émettre des
avis sur l'ensemble de ces amendements
pas afin d'éclairer le débat dans
l'hémicycle et là j'ai peur qu'avec
finalement cette marche là maintenant et
on a compris un certain nombre
d'éléments on rate l'essentiel qui est
quand même de rassurer sur l'avenir de
notre système de retraite par
répartition de rassurer les jeunes sur
le sens qui vont avoir de pouvoir
consentir à ce système dans la
transmission de ce patrimoine et la
sécurité sociale
je vous donne le micro allez-y madame la
députée merci madame la Présidente alors
en fait moi depuis le début l'un des
débats et Dieu sait que on a passé des
heures on fermait dans cette salle je
n'ai pas vu véritablement ce que vous
étiez prêt et prête à accepter
en fait comme amendement et c'est un peu
le sujet puisque nous sommes dans une
assemblée délibérative une Assemblée
nationale qui est censée pouvoir
travailler un texte et en fait on a
présenté les choses de manière
différente parfois de manière frontale
parfois de manière subtile parfois de
manière
caricaturale ou ou humoristique même et
en fait rien ne passe jamais en fait
c'est à dire que il n'y a pas un seul
des amendements que nous avons proposé
par un seul
pas un seul qui ait été accepté et donc
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est à quoi servons-nous ici et
finalement si l'objet du gouvernement et
de la et de du groupe Renaissance et
d'attendre le 49-3 bah faites-le
faites-le assumer devant les Français le
fait que vous ne souhaitez pas de débat
parlementaire parce que ça n'est pas
possible de nous renvoyer à une attitude
alors qu'en fait la vôtre est à ce point
la bloquer qu'il n'y a pas un amendement
qui soit pas un et Dieu sait que
pourtant Dieu sait que pourtant nous en
avons proposé donc je vous appelle à la
responsabilité je vous appelle à la
responsabilité et cette responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est d'entendre que le
gouvernement et le président de la
République ne gouverne pas seul sur une
planète éloignée mais gouverne dans une
démocratie avec un parlement qui
s'appelle l'Assemblée nationale très
bien Madame Rousseau je me permets de
vous recoiger madame la députée parce
que s'il y a eu des amendements qui ont
été adoptés et encore encore je crois ce
matin ou hier soir s'il y a eu des
amendements qui ont été adoptés très
bien
plusieurs monsieur Vigier vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la Présidente
non simplement j'écoutais de notre
collègue madame Rousseau à l'instant
vous ne lui rappeler d'ailleurs que
évidemment qui sont été adoptés venant
de l'opposition mais je voulais dire
Madame Rousseau
c'est votre stratégie qui vous conduit à
une forme d'impasse il n'était pas
obligatoire d'ailleurs vous avez changé
de stratégie en préparant la séance
après par en pardon cette commission au
départ il nous avait été expliqué
signifier qu'il y aurait 75 000
amendements après vous avez modifié un
peu le calibrage et vous êtes arrivés à
4 à 5000 c'est votre choix c'est la
liberté totale simplement je me permets
juste un commentaire sur votre stratégie
je ne dis pas qu'elle est bonne qu'elle
est pas bonne je la commente du coup
nous avons passé énormément de temps sur
l'article 2
et quelque part on voit bien qu'on n'ira
pas sur d'autres articles parce que vous
avez mis en place vous même les
conditions qui font qu'on ne peut pas
aller balayer l'ensemble des articles de
ce texte de loi moi je le regrette avec
le groupe et bien nous avons dû poser
une trentaine d'amendements certains ont
déposé une petite centaine donc vous
auriez concentré vos amendements plutôt
que les décliner j'entends et vous le
portez avec force on a des divergences
assumons-les et c'est la démocratie en
revanche c'est votre stratégie qui vous
conduit à cet impact dans laquelle nous
sommes ce soir simplement faut pas dire
que c'est nous qui empêchant le débat
vous avez créé les conditions d'une
pitchman du débat parce que vous avez
voulu vraiment mais pas nous aussi
fallait pardonnez-moi on en aurait posé
3000 j'accepterai totalement la
responsabilité mais je suis persuadé et
on verra vous réfléchirez vos collègues
en direction de la séance ne rejetez pas
sur les autres la responsabilité qui est
la vôtre elle était votre liberté vous
l'avez utilisé c'est le moindre des
droits du Parlement vous ferez comme
vous voudrez pour la semaine prochaine
c'est demain jeudi à 17 heures mais nous
verrons à l'un de ce vous déposerait la
stratégie que vous aurez défini pour la
semaine prochaine très bien monsieur
jumelles
bon il est 17h30
et
non non mais
je
comme je vous connais par cœur je sens
monter la petite musique
du RN du modèle des Playmobil
qui qui est donc en fin de commission
vont nous dire à cause de vous on n'a
pas pu examiner jusqu'au Bultex
je vous connais comme si je vous avais
fait si comme disait ma grand-mère
sauf que je vous invite à réfléchir à
plusieurs éléments d'abord le choix du
véhicule législatif que vous avez fait
le projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale fait
que de toute façon que des amendements
soient adoptés ou non en commission le
texte présenté dans l'hémicycle sera le
texte que vous avez décidé tout seul
tout seul dans le secret de l'Elysée
deuxièmement vous avez utilisé une
disposition législative qui
contraint le délai d'examen de ce texte
essayez de chercher demander aux
administrateurs de faire ça pour vous
ils iront plus vite de chercher dans les
archives de nos débats parlementaires
s'il y a une réforme des retraites où
nous avons consacré trois jours en
commission ça n'existe pas donc vous
avez délibérément fait le choix
d'enfermer alors j'invite mon collègue
Vigier à pas tombé dans dans ce piège
caricatural vous avez fait le choix
en réservant simplement trois jours de
discussion en commission de ne pas
permettre un examen jusqu'au bout de ce
texte quatrième élément et là il est
fondamental nous nous pensons que ce
texte
nécessite non pas des amendements à la
marche mais qu'il n'y a rien à garder
dans ce texte qui a rien de bon dans ce
texte ni les mesures d'âge ni
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine ni
les mesures cosmétiques qui prennent
comme disposition de faire payer les
riches jamais et de faire contribuer les
pauvres tout le temps et donc si vous
voulez on a joué le jeu du débat
parlementaire au moment dans ce texte
mais sans illusion et sans naïveté le
député on va passer donc au vote
donc sur cet amendement 70-35 qui a reçu
un avis défavorable qui est pour
non monsieur jumelles vous pouvez pas
voter oui voilà
je suis pas né de la dernière pluie
monsieur jumelles
très bien merci
très bien qui est contre
il est rejeté
pardon la parole est à alors qui
souhaite défendre le 59 97 madame la
présidente madame taillée vous avez la
parole merci madame
la Présidente
17h37 et nouvel épisode dans la boîte à
outils que nous vous proposons pour
financer le système des retraites et ce
déficit d'un temps d'un temps très court
cet amendement visage sujet tire les
revenus financiers des sociétés
financières et non financières à une
contribution pour l'assurance vieillesse
au même taux que les cotisations
patronales et salariales du secteur
privé
moi ce que je retiens de ces heures
nombreuses passer en commission c'est
quand même deux choses
d'abord nous avons démontré par
l'ensemble de nos amendements
l'inutilité la poudre aux yeux
l'absolu indigence du dispositif d'index
senior
que vous proposez pour un résoudre un
problème que vous considérez pourtant
comme important donc votre index senior
ne sert à rien nous avons quand même
cherché à l'améliorer et rien n'a été
possible et puis nous avons démontré
votre votre volonté farouche de faire
payer le plus grand nombre
faire payer le plus grand nombre c'est
votre unique obsession finalement et
malgré toutes les propositions là je
vous en fais une nouvelle mais il y en a
d'autres qui vont venir pour financer le
système des retraites
vous n'en prenez aucune on a pourtant
été créatif parce que oui nous pensons
qu'il faut dégager des recettes
supplémentaires et notamment pour
améliorer le système des retraites
actuelles qui est inégalitaire pour les
carrières hachées pour les femmes
et j'ose même dire que quand nous avons
présenté des amendements que vous avez
jugé intéressant alors là là comme celui
sur la pénibilité que j'ai présenté il y
a quelques dizaines de minutes là
l'amendement était mal rédigé pas
opérationnel alors c'est pas bon en fait
si jamais bon parce que vous intéresse
écoutez j'ai une proposition
j'ai une proposition sérieuse à vous
faire à 17h39
si vous adoptez cet amendement qui
rapporte 30 milliards
je prends l'engagement devant vous qu'on
retire tous les autres amendements
jusqu'à l'article 7 qu'on vote contre
l'article 7 et qu'on a réglé d'une
certaine manière la question des
retraites leur financement et qu'on a
effacé la mesure la plus pénalisante
pour les corps qui s'abîment pour les
corps qui s'usent et pour ceux que vous
voulez encore broyer à travers cette
mauvaise réforme non vous votez cet
amendement de mise à contribution d'une
certaine manière du capital à 30
milliards d'euros pour financer
l'équilibre des retraites on passe à
l'article 7 et on le balaye on vote
contre et puis on rentre chez nous et
puis on rentre chez nous content content
d'avoir écouté le peuple qui manque le
peuple qui lutte le peuple qui résiste
le peuple qui travaille et qui a fait
tourner le pays pendant la crise covid
que nous avons durement traversé voilà
la proposition honnête que je formule
devant vous à 17h40
merci on est heureux on a une horloge
parlante là depuis quelques minutes
c'est très bien alors sur ce je vais
demander quand même à la rapporteur
général son avis sur ces deux
amendements merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur jumelles sur votre
amendement donc nous avons eu le débat
depuis maintenant quelques
heures c'est un avis défavorable mais je
voudrais ici
donner quelques chiffres pour tous
pour essayer de répondre à votre
intervention de tout à l'heure qui
disait que c'était scandaleux de nous
laisser que trois jours en commission
les dernières réformes des retraites en
en 2014 c'était deux jours de commission
811 amendements en 2010 qui était une
réforme qui avait aussi
été compliqué la réforme de 2010 c'est
trois jours en commission
616 amendements et une c'est semaine en
séance donc en trois jours on est
capable on est capable on est capable en
trois jours d'examiner normalement un
texte voilà mais mais il y a pas 5000
amendements il y en a 616 voilà c'est la
différence vous pouvez pas nous faire
porter sur la durée de la commission le
fait de pas pouvoir arriver au bout du
texte depuis le début on dit qu'on veut
avancer c'est l'intérêt de tous les
Français qu'on puisse avancer
très bien alors je vais passer j'ai
plusieurs demandes de paroles s'il vous
plaît monsieur Bazin
[Musique]
alors je vais passer la parole
je n'ai jamais dit que vous n'étiez rien
monsieur dit Philippot et lui seul à la
parole merci madame la Présidente je
peux partager
qu'a dit Monsieur jumelle sur le choix
du véhicule législatif et les
contraintes que cela fait peser sur nos
débats et ça sera exactement le même
problème dans dans l'hémicycle il faut
mesurer l'état de tension du pays et
tout ce qu'il y a nécessité qu'on a des
débattre de points de points cruciaux
moi je pense que vous avez eu une
journée entière pour présenter tous les
dispositifs possibles et imaginables de
taxation du grand capital des
entreprises des rentiers et de tout ce
que vous détestez et force cette
constater qu'aucune de ces propositions
ne trouvera déco ici dans cette dans
cette commission je le dis en tant
qu'observateur objectif puisque je n'y
ai pas le droit de vote mais c'est un
fait
je vous donne un conseil malgré tout
politique
si vous voulez avoir au moins et bien
quelque chose de symbolique de
significatif politiquement qui puisse
sortir de cette commission retirer tous
les amendements jusqu'aux articles qui
sont vraiment les points de crispation
qui sont importants pour l'opinion vous
aurez un débat sur ces questions là vous
aurez un vote comme ça a été le cas dans
la commission de la défense et peut-être
que vous pourrez vous en servir par la
suite je vous donne non parce que
l'amendement vous savez
moi je n'ai pas le droit de vote mais 30
milliards de taxes supplémentaires sur
l'économie française
et bien sur les sociétés et bien en tout
cas c'est pas quelque chose que
quelqu'un pourra accepter et ça dépasse
de très loin le simple sujet des relais
des retraites en France et en tout état
de cause
si vous souhaitez avoir un débat sur des
sujets qui inquiète vraiment nos
concitoyens est-ce que il faut là je
légale est-ce qu'il faut la durée de
cotisation qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
sur beaucoup d'autres points et bien
c'est entre vos mains parce que tous les
amendements forcés de constater que ce
sont des amendements de la nuque vous
avez les clés du débat vous pouvez
choisir pour les deux dernières heures
et demi de continuer de pourrir le débat
ou alors vous pouvez choisir de le faire
avancer de l'amener sur des points
significatifs prenez vos responsabilités
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
turquois
merci madame la Présidente
notre collègue jumelle a parlé de la
réforme de 2019 je me rappelle plutôt
bien on avait l'ambition de faire
quelque chose que vous portez qui était
celle de l'universalisme les mêmes
règles à tous les mêmes règles en
matière de droit des familles les mêmes
règles en matière d'acquisition de droit
c'était un système par point qui pouvait
être discutable et donc comment remettez
les 42 régimes sur la même base alors il
y avait un temps d'échange plus long
c'était là on est on est sur une
approche on l'assume pleinement on est
d'abord sur une approche de rétablir des
équilibres financiers c'est un premier
sujet et on essaye de corriger un
certain nombre d'iniquités mais avec
moins d'ambition moins d'universalisme
qu'il y avait en 2019 donc il y a un
certain nombre de sujets que vous portez
contre lequel vous êtes battu en 2019
premier sujet deuxième sujet par rapport
à la liste des amendements qui
n'auraient pas été pris mais à force
vous vous centrez sur les mêmes points
je pense
qu'on aurait pu évoquer sur où on va
chercher des ressources dans le cadre
d'un régime par répartition il y a quand
même amplifié le taux d'emploi des
actifs actuels il y a quand même
toujours des questions de chômage
notamment sur les seniors on a évoqué
des choses notamment évoquées la
question du rapport à l'emploi parce que
effectivement vous l'avez dit plusieurs
dix je vois madame kéké a raison d'avoir
dit que il y a des métiers je pense que
c'est une partie mais il y a une partie
importante des métiers qui peuvent être
pénibles et donc comment on travaille ce
rapport à l'emploi et plutôt que
d'attendre la fin vous parlez des corps
usés plutôt attendre que les corps
soient usés comment on oriente
prévention on prévient et que peut-être
à mi carrière on puisse permettre un
maximum de personnes de se réorienter
comment on pouvait évoquer si on avait
été plus loin la clause de revoyure qui
nous semble importante pour refaire un
bilan dans trois ou dans quatre ans
plutôt que de continuer plus loin la
réforme voir si on l'adapte on
l'amplifie on
[Musique]
parce que oui on a un double sujet quel
est l'avenir qu'on propose à nos
concitoyens et c'est le cœur de
l'ensemble de nos amendements comment
est-ce qu'on le finance comment est-ce
qu'on le développe comment est-ce qu'on
vit bien son travail et comment est-ce
qu'on vit bien après le travail et le
deuxième problème que nous avons
aujourd'hui et je le souligne parce que
depuis deux jours ça ne fait qu'empirer
c'est qu'on a en refus du travail
parlementaire qui se concrétise à
travers toutes ces remarques attaquez
nous sur le fond attaquez nous sur ce
que nous proposons mais de grâce cesser
de laminer ainsi la démocratie
parlementaire ce n'est pas pour ça qu'on
a été élu on n'a pas été élu on ne
pouvait pas du tout élu pour atteindre
que les choses se passent nous avons été
élu pour proposer nous avons été élus
sur un projet et que ceci vous déplaise
j'en suis forte mais la réalité est là
et en dernier point vous nous avez dit
Madame la rapporteur que vous déployer
le fait qu'il y ait trop d'amendements
oui effectivement il y a un certain
nombre environnement mais rapporté au
nombre de pages on est plutôt tranquille
en revanche là où il y a une vraie
inflation et qu'elle est historique
cette inflation là c'est sur le nombre
de personnes qui sont dans la rue pour
cette retraite jamais aucune réforme des
retraites
ici personne ne s'assoit sur la
démocratie parlementaire et le travail
parlementaire madame la députée vous ne
pouvez pas dire cela ici vous ne pouvez
pas montrer le nom madame la franchement
vous vous êtes exprimé longuement tout
le monde sait exprimé tout le monde
prend la parole à chaque amendement et
allez un contre débat etc et vous dites
qu'on s'assoit sur le travail
parlementaire mais comment vous pouvez
dire ça même les Français ne vous
croient pas c'est votre groupe qui a
pris le plus longtemps
mais mais moi je parle du travail
parlementaire que vous avez évoqué vous
dites qu'on s'assoit sur le travail
parlementaire pas du tout personne ici
ça soit sur le travail parlementaire ni
on vous a laissé parler mais attendez
mais mais bon vous n'étiez même pas là
tout au début d'ailleurs madame vous
venez d'arriver très bien très bien
Madame Autain a la parole et elle seule
non mais je vois la difficulté parce
qu'en réalité
en réalité
celles et ceux qui dans cette salle
soutiennent le projet du gouvernement
sont à la peine depuis le début des
travaux de cette commission alors comme
vous êtes à la peine vous accusez le
nombre d'amendements je voudrais
rappeler pour ceux qui étaient là la
dernière fois qu'il y a beaucoup moins
d'amendements de notre côté que ce qu'on
avait déposé la dernière fois vous ne
défendez pas votre projet vous critiquez
les parties prix qui sont les nôtres et
si je résume tout le monde doit faire
des efforts comme le dit Madame borne
sauf les grands groupes économiques et
les milliardaires et nous nous dénonçons
l'indécence des fortunes amassées par
ces grands groupes et ses milliardaires
quand Benjamin Lucas faisait référence à
la morale d'un seul coup ou là là il y
avait des cris d'orfray ici c'était
insupportable alors ne parlons pas moral
parlons principes et le principe que
nous défendons face à vous c'est le
principe du partage des richesses et là
monsieur de Courson qu'est ce qui nous
dit vous voulez la mort des
milliardaires rien que ça la mort des
milliardaires monsieur le cours sont
si on leur prend leur argent une partie
de leur argent et qu'on les met à
contribution ils ne vont pas mourir en
revanche si vous faites travailler deux
ans de plus les plus modestes ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler le plus tôt
ceux qui ont le travail le plus pénible
alors oui là il s'agit de morts réels
non pas de leur prendre de l'argent mais
de toucher à leur vie concrète à leur
chair et à leur corps on nous dit alors
vous voulez chasser les riches alors que
c'est eux qui produisent la richesse
mais enfin c'est incroyable qui produit
la richesse dans ce pays les
travailleurs les travailleuses les
producteurs et les productrices de
richesse et ça ça veut dire que nous
nous défendons la valeur du travail
quand vous défendez la valeur du capital
et finalement le débat que nous avons
ici il est sur le partage de la valeur
ajoutée et sur le fait que ce qui vous
êtes insupportable ce qui vous êtes
insupportable c'est d'imaginer que nous
pourrions avoir d'autres solutions et
nos amendements ne sont là que pour ça
vous dire que des solutions financières
il en existe des caisses et des wagons
et ces deux cela dont je n'ai pas parler
très bien mais pas attaquer vos amis la
parole est à Monsieur Guedj
madame la Présidente
depuis lundi matin sans discontinuer
nous faisons vivre la qualité de notre
travail parlementaire et celui-ci permet
et c'est sa première vertu
d'illustrer ce qui est au cœur de
l'antagonisme qui j'allais dire nous
rassemble mais plutôt nous divise
il y a et depuis ce matin nous sommes
sur les amendements de financement
alternatifs et j'ai entendu des
remarques un peu des obligeantes qui
disons mais passons à autre chose allons
sur l'essentiel et le significatif nous
sommes au coeur de l'essentiel parce que
nous sommes sur le point sur lequel il y
a la véritable divergence je le répète
pour la 8e fois aujourd'hui vous avez
décidé de créer un impôt sur la vie nous
vous proposons d'autres formes de
financement vous avez un postulat qui
est de dire nous refusons toute nouvelle
contribution supplémentaire ce faisant
vous oubliez vous escamotez le fait que
vous créez une contribution
supplémentaire qui s'appelle faire
travailler deux ans de plus les gens et
donc ce point de désaccord il est au
cœur du débat que nous avons et qui
renvoie et pardon de le dire mais je
suis d'accord avec Clémentine au teint
avec François Ruffin avec toutes celles
et ceux qui ont dit que le cœur du débat
sur les retraites en réel c'est un se
passe sur l'organisation du partage de
la richesse dans notre pays voilà et
donc on n'a pas pu aller au bout on ira
probablement dans l'hémicycle et je
termine sur un point sur la qualité de
notre travail parlementaire parce que
Madame la rapporteur vous avez mentionné
les travaux dans les précédentes
Commission dans les présentes réforme
des retraites vous avez un peu
opportunément oublié la réforme de 2000
de 2020 en 2020 il y a eu trois semaines
de travail en commission et 21600
amendements il y a eu trois semaines de
travail en commission et donc je peux
vous assurer que nous aurions aimé avoir
le temps suffisant en commission pour ne
permettre d'aller au bout de l'ensemble
de ces amandes merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Éric à lozet
[Musique]
simplement je pense qu'effectivement il
y a deux modèles et deux visions qui
c'est qui s'opposent et nous sommes pas
dans la logique de texte et plus pour
protéger mieux ce n'est pas comme cela
que ça fonctionne surtout dans un
système où on l'a expliqué de façon
assez simple nous avons un système où ce
sont les cotisants qui financent les
pensions des retraités mais je voulais
surtout réagir sur la commission des
affaires sociales je suis assez désolé
que ma collègue Sandra rigole n'écoute
plus parce que oui il y a des débats ici
à merci Madame merci de m'écouter
non mais merci de m'écouter madame je
vous le redis parce que les donneurs de
leçons qui viennent quelques minutes en
fin de séance alors qu'il n'était pas là
depuis le début de ces auditions je je
trouve ça un peu désobligeant pour
l'entièreté de cette commission je dois
le souligner ici et je le dis je finis
de parler madame rigole je sais que
c'est douloureux c'est douloureux je le
sais mais je vais vraiment continuer à
parler je le dis de façon très claire
l'ensemble des commissaires ici présent
depuis le début de cette de cette Audi
de cette de ce texte qu'il soit de tout
ban confondu ce sont attachés à
travailler à débattre avec de grands
désaccords oui en suivant la règle qui
était un temps de parole pour chaque
groupe nous avons proposé un certain
nombre de fois de faire un pour un
contre ça n'a pas été accepté nous on
nous en tenons nous en prenons pas
ombrage et nous continuons mais venir
mais venir ici nous expliquer que nous
ne travaillons pas ce n'est pas faire
honneur d'une part à la rapporteur et
d'autre part à la présidente qui tient
cette commission non seulement sur cette
sur ce texte mais aussi depuis le début
de cette législature avec brio
très bien merci non c'est le temps
n'était pas écoulé je suis désolé
monsieur pas du tout Monsieur Charles de
Courson
mes chers collègues quand on lit avec
attention cette amendement il nous
propose de taxer à un taux qui est la
somme des taux de cotisation salariés et
employeur du régime vieillesse
c'est-à-dire grosso modo un peu plus de
20%, est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
que quand vous distribuez un dividende
20% supplémentaires de taxation alors
que même si vous avez un prélèvement
forfaitaire et si vous en avez pas vous
êtes au-delà des 73
75%, estimé par le Conseil conditionnel
comme le plafond de la duquel on peut
pas aller donc vous voyez bien que on
peut faire des amendements comme ça de
réflexion c'est sympathique parfois mais
ça tient pas la route et nous sommes
plusieurs à l'avoir dit répéter depuis
trois jours en faisant cela vous
détruisez le régime par répartition
puisque un régime par répartition c'est
que vous ouvrez des droits à partir du
moment où vous cotisez alors vous me
direz mais actuellement on a un
financement mixte c'est pas tout à fait
exact parce que les financements de
l'État voire la CNAV voir des ASSEDIC
qu'on pense des mesures qui ont été
prises spécifiques donc on reste dans un
système où les droits sont ouverts à
partir du moment où vous cotisez ou que
quelqu'un d'autre cotise pour vous
là si on adoptait ces amendements on
détruit le système par répartition alors
on peut être pour les Anglais ils ont
choisi cela
mais c'est pas la tradition française
est à ma connaissance nous nos collègues
de gauche sont pour le maintien d'un
système de répartition
et pas un système où on finance ça à
coup d'impôts et résultat et bien on est
attise totalement et vous casser le
régime de répartition
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Marcio
merci madame la Présidente bon ça fait
trois jours que la nuque se nous fait
son numéro d'obstruction pour nous
empêcher d'étudier l'article 7 sur
l'ignoble au report de l'âge légal de la
retraite avec des amendements qui nous
font penser à un débat sur le montant de
la valise RTL maintenant il nous propose
taxes surtax comme si c'était la
solution miracle la nups si on vous
donnait le Sahara dans cinq ans il
faudrait en racheter du sable je
regrette que nous n'ayons pas pu aborder
en commission le fond de cette réforme
dans le bassin minier et je peux vous le
dire que les salariés sont usés par le
travail les couvreurs les carreleurs les
serveurs les soignants les caissières
les mers seuls aux carrières hachées et
les personnes handicapées se moquent
éperdument de ces débats ce qu'ils
veulent c'est qu'on les protège qu'on
protège notre modèle de république
sociale dans laquelle nous sommes encore
nombreux à croire une vision humaine où
on a le droit à une vie de retraite pour
profiter d'une relative bonne santé et
de ses proches après une vie de dur
labeur donc les 64 ans imposés par le
gouvernement et c'est uniquement ça qui
les intéresse nous devons en parler à
leur retirer vos amendements qu'on
puisse parler de la retraite à 64 ans
oui comme dirait Sébastien Jumet il est
17h59 et ce à quoi on s'attendait arrive
finalement on savait bien qu'à un moment
donné vous allez nous faire le reproche
qui n'est pas assez de temps pour
examiner la multitude d'amendements que
vous avez déposé mais avouer que quelque
part il y a comme un double langage
quand hier je vous attendrai puisque je
suis là depuis le début quand même de
l'ouverture de la science comme d'autres
nous parler de finalement d'une
stratégie d'obstruction donc vous pouvez
pas à la fois nous faire le reproche de
manquer de temps et d'un côté faire de
l'obstruction et à mon défaut choisir
quoi je pense que nos concitoyens nous
concitoyens ont le droit d'être éclairés
sur ce positionnement après je m'adresse
à d'autres chers collègues moi je me
sens pas compétent pour coupe en
commenter la qualité de votre travail
parlementaire il est tout aussi bon
qu'un autre et certainement pas l'objet
de nos travaux en commission en tout cas
c'est pas l'habitude que l'on a dans
cette commission d'aversale de commenter
le travail des uns des autres par contre
oui vous avez introduit des sujets
importants et intéressants dans le débat
et je pense qu'il a été assez riche
peut-être un peu vif et enflammé parfois
mais en tout cas il a eu le mérite
d'exister et je pense qu'on peut pas
faire l'injure en tout cas la présidente
d'avoir présidé
la façon dont ça a été proposée à savoir
que chacun a pu s'exprimer avec un
orateur par groupe et ensuite cher
Jérôme moi j'apprécie effectivement ta
volonté d'engager le débat sur le
partage de la richesse je pense qu'il y
aurait d'autres débats introduire comme
celui de la question de la valeur de
travail et quelle place on trouve
aujourd'hui au titre du travail dans
notre société je pense que ce sera remis
à la semaine prochaine ça tombe bien
cette fois on aura deux semaines
très bien
mais merci bien donc nous je vais mettre
ces deux
ces deux amendements aux voix tous les
deux ont reçu un avis défavorable tout
d'abord le 59 97 qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté mais ma vie
même vote pour les 70 75 merci alors
amendement 60004 avant son qui qui le
présente Madame taipoliant je vais le
faire madame
la Présidente
la concision c'est tout moi c'est
amendement en cadre par la loi la
détermination des cotisations patronales
des plafonnées affectées à l'assurance
vieillesse en leur imposant un taux de
2% c'est à dire 0 10 points de plus
qu'actuellement je voulais ajouter que
là je vais répondre à aux souhaits de
monsieur de Courson qui est que nous
vous proposions des des recettes
nouvelles qui ne soient pas des recettes
fiscales cependant je tiens à préciser
parce que cela était nous a été reproché
à plusieurs reprises que si nous
proposons des recettes fiscales ce n'est
pas du tout pour retirer à la sécurité
sociale son caractère et au système des
retraites son caractère de
redistribution et de système par
répartition mais nous considérons que
dans notre société il y a des inégalités
qui n'ont qui ne sont pas limitées au
travail notamment les inégalités femmes
hommes pour lesquelles l'appel à l'impôt
et donc l'appel à la au budget de la
Nation peuvent être on peut y recourir
parce que ce sont des problématiques
plus larges donc ça n'est pas du tout
contradictoire avec le fait de défendre
ce que nous faisons à chaque instant le
système par répartition
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente vous
souhaitez augmenter les cotisations
d'assurance vieillesse ce qui réglerait
rien d'après les travaux du corps le
financement des déficits cumulés à
l'horizon 2032 si on prend le scénario
qui retient une hypothèse de chômage à
7%, supposerait d'augmenter de près de
1,7 points le taux de prélèvement global
à horizon 2030 ça voudrait dire
augmenter de 442 euros par an les
cotisations pour pouvoir équilibrer le
système cette augmentation n'est donc
pas une option souhaitable
donc avis tout à fait défavorable
très bien
monsieur Bazin
oui merci
collègues c'est vrai que la question
c'est comment on finance d'une certaine
manière ce qu'on souhaite financer et et
le modèle notre modèle il tient sur le
fait que on a un nombre de
travailleurs qui cotisent
un niveau de cotisation et en face on a
un nombre de retraités avec un niveau de
pension si on veut pas que le niveau de
pension baisse et on sait que le nombre
de retraités augmente avec le
vieillissement et que c'est une réalité
et qu'on veut pas baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés je crois que ça
peut nous rassembler aussi ici il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions vous faites
des propositions d'une certaine manière
sur le patrimoine existant encore ici à
travers cet amendement sur le revenu
financier des sociétés financières
est-ce que tout notre système de
protection sociale à l'avenir peut tenir
sur les propositions que vous faites je
pense très clairement que si on adopté
un certain nombre d'amendements
finalement il y aurait plus de sociétés
financière sur ces aspects là chez nous
ça va se déplorer différemment mais ça
ne viendrait pas durablement apporter
des solutions de financement sur
l'ensemble mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
et on parle beaucoup
des richesses mais finalement avant de
partager les richesses il faut les créer
et pour les créer il faut travailler
notre système il reposer sur deux
principes la contributivité et la
solidarité et la solidarité elle était
entre les générations et donc sur des
cotisations liées au travail qui sont
liées au travail et c'est vrai que dans
la manière dont vous appréhendez les
choses alors c'est sûr que le pfss nous
contraint sur le fond et sur la forme
puisqu'on ne peut pas évoquer un certain
nombre de sujets relatifs au travail il
y a un paquet travail qui est annoncé il
y a des chantiers qui sont très
importants et j'espère qu'on pourra en
débattre d'ici la fin de notre
commission dans dans quelques dizaines
de minutes sur les droits conjugaux et
familiaux parce que je crois qu'il y a
des vraies corrections à apporter et
pour le moment c'est renvoyé qu'à un
chantier du corps et je trouve ça
dommageable sur l'assiette de
cotisations des indépendants c'est
renvoyé au PDFs 202 4 je pense que là
aussi il faut qu'on puisse peut-être
prendre des engagements un peu plus fort
c'est important merci monsieur le député
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
là ça fait plusieurs amendements sur
lesquels nous vous proposons de
d'avoir des modes de financement de
cette réforme des retraites qui
permettent d'éviter qu'on pourrisse la
vie de millions de gens en augmentant
l'âge de départ en retraite je vais vous
faire une petite confidence parce que je
viens de voir passer un truc qui me fait
qui me renvoie à mon propre passé je
vois un article de BFM qui dit Nicolas
Sarkozy encourage la droite à soutenir
la réforme des retraites et à tenir
compte des combats qui ont été les siens
et je dois vous dire que mon propre
engagement politique à gauche au côté de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la nupesse
aujourd'hui il vient de Nicolas Sarkozy
et de sa réforme des retraites moi j'ai
un parcours politique qui est sans doute
très différent de ceux de mes collègues
de gauche je viens de la droite très
exactement je viens du MoDem
et c'est Nicolas et ouais c'est Nicolas
c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui m'a convaincu
d'aller avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
que figurez-vous que la réforme des
retraites de Nicolas Sarkozy écoutez
j'ai reconnu la réforme des retraites de
Nicolas Sarkozy elle faisait suite à la
crise des subprimes crise dans laquelle
l'État avait sauvé des banques qui avait
fait n'importe quoi et ensuite c'est la
spéculation des banques contre la dette
des états qui a poussé à faire une
réforme des retraites en 2010 avec le
report de l'âge légal or en réalité on
aurait déjà pu faire autrement à cette
époque là et c'est Monsieur Sarkozy qui
avec cette réforme des retraites m'a
convaincu d'aller complètement ailleurs
et de rejoindre Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
lui avait écrit un livre qui s'appelait
qu'il s'en aille tous et je veux vous
dire presque vous allez finir par
retirer cette réforme des retraites
c'est une certitude mais dans
l'intervalle de temps vous aurons vous
aurez convaincu comme je l'ai été des
milliers des millions de gens de
l'inefficacité de votre système
économique et de son inhumanité donc
quelque part on ne peut que vous
remercier puisqu'à la fin vous allez
perdre
oui merci madame la Présidente bon une
nouvelle fois la nupesse nous bon encore
une fois provoque bon là nous raconte un
peu sa vie son œuvre c'est très
intéressant pour les Français mais on a
toujours pas avancé non plus sur un vrai
contre-projet
solide et via moi j'aimerais savoir
encore une fois est-ce qu'il existe un
pays qui dans lequel on payerait plus
d'impôts qu'en France on aurait une
retraite à 60 ans et comment est-ce
qu'ils vont faire pour garder dans ce
pays toutes les personnes qu'ils ont
envie de taxer toutes les entreprises
qu'ils ont envie de d'imposer davantage
et par ailleurs on arrive bientôt à la
fin aussi de nos départs en commission
et on a toujours pas compris ce qu'il y
a dans le fameux projet de Marine Le Pen
qui serait a priori très très riche
parce que il existe il est écrit
paraît-il mais on a encore eu aucune
proposition à qui allez-vous demander
des efforts au rassemblement national
pour régler ce problème de déficit
très bien et bien monsieur Benz va vous
répondre oui merci Madame le Présidente
chers collègues écoutez ces amendements
techniques sont pas tous inintéressants
mais pour répondre à notre collègue
également de la majorité qui a hâte de
connaître le programme de Marine Le Pen
sur la question des retraites écoutez en
tant que secrétaire de cette commission
et au nom de notre groupe dans ce cas-là
je vous fais une proposition à tous je
vous propose de mettre l'article 7 en
examen prioritaire il est 18h il ne nous
reste plus que deux heures deux heures
pour parler du coeur nucléaire de cette
réforme et pour qu'on puisse confronter
nos points de vue je vous remercie
très bien monsieur Lucas
madame la Présidente
monsieur Bazin a
donné un argument qui est pour moi non
seulement l'argument le plus ringard qui
soit mais mais aussi mais je vais vous
l'expliquer mais j'ai le droit c'est pas
une insulte c'est l'argument qui est
ringard c'est pas monsieur Bazin qui par
ailleurs extrêmement sympathique mais
qui mais qui est au cœur du débat qui
nous oppose depuis plusieurs heures qui
est au cœur du débat qui nous oppose
depuis plusieurs heures monsieur Bazin a
dit pour partager la richesse il faut
d'abord la créer s'il est aussi gourmand
que moi il aurait pu dire ce qui est
souvent dit avant de partager le gâteau
on part il faut d'abord le cuisiner mais
monsieur Bazin regardons ensemble la
devanture de la pâtisserie elle dégorge
de crème les ultra-riches dans notre
pays ce sont plus enrichis en quelques
mois de pandémie qu'en une décennie le
patrimoine moyen des 10% des Français
les plus pauvres et de 3800 euros quand
il est pour le pour cent des Français
les plus riches de presque 2 millions
d'euros donc la richesse elle est là
Monsieur Bazin elle existe il est
simplement mal partagé elle n'a jamais
été aussi mal partagé dans notre
histoire récente donc votre argument il
est complètement farfelu il ne tient pas
la route
je mets aux voix c'est amendement s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues on se calme
je me suis Bazas s'il vous plaît
monsieur Bazin
on reste courtois malgré l'heure tardive
déjà
alors je mets aux voix cet amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de Madame
la rapporteur général qui est pour
il y a de moins en moins de bras levés y
compris à l'extrême gauche qui est
contre
il est rejeté
alors
ensuite amendement souvent madame
Rousseau vous le défendez madame c'est
l'abonnement de Madame SAS 60 08 c'est
ça madame taipoli en donc je vais aller
présenter merci beaucoup madame écoute
s'il vous plaît parlez dans le micro
madame je vous entends pas alors à
celles et ceux qui voudraient parler de
l'article 7 je voudrais rappeler que
comme le gouvernement a choisi de passer
en PLFSS il faut d'abord adopter les
recettes et donc pour permettre de
liquider l'article 7 il nous faut régler
le problème de financement conjoncturel
auquel nous sommes face et pour ce faire
nous avons cet amendement qui augmente
les cotisations
patronales des plafonnés
et qui permet de régler le problème
conjoncturel auquel nous sommes
confrontés et puis nous pouvons tous
rentrer chez nous puisque nous aurons
ainsi
régler le problème je voudrais ajouter
donc il n'est pas possible en fait
d'appeler l'article 7 avant de parler
financement donc oui nous parlons
financement et nous vous sortons toutes
les propositions possibles et
imaginables et elles sont nombreuses et
elles ne sont pas nombreuses parce
qu'elles sont fantaisistes elles sont
nombreuses parce que des richesses oui
il y en a déjà dans ce pays nul n'est
besoin d'en créer toujours davantage et
notamment au détriment de notre
environnement je crois qu'il faut que
nous arrêtions aussi de concevoir notre
société comme une course folle à la
production de toujours plus de bien
d'ailleurs qui sont pas forcément très
utiles mais au contraire à ralentir
notamment à partager le temps de travail
et à faire en sorte que nous puissions
vivre heureux dans le cadre de notre
planète qui je le rappelle a des limites
très bien merci madame la députée madame
la rapporteur général votre avis sur cet
amendement
un avis défavorable pardon très bien
monsieur Ruffin merci madame la
Présidente pour Monsieur Bazin
dont je trouve pas les propos ringards
puisque ce sont des propos qui sont
relativement répandues dès qu'on
fréquente des plateaux de télévision
tous les jours les agents d'entretien
les charismes les manutentionnaires tous
les jours les chefs de rayons dans la
grande distribution tous les jours les
agents des hôpitaux tous les jours les
enseignants créent de la richesse dans
ce pays
jamais la France n'a été un pays aussi
riche donc un moment se pose la question
dans ce gâteau qui n'a cessé de grossir
de sa répartition quand dans le même
jour vous avez
à la Une des échos retraite les derniers
arbitrages du gouvernement et en page 27
dividende record pour les géants du CAC
40 en 2022 la question de la répartition
se pose elle se pose mon point de vue
d'un point de vue économique mais elle
se pose aussi d'un point de vue moral le
président de la République a fait ses
vœux sur l'unité de la nation l'unité de
la nation face aux crises qu'on a
traversé covid gars en Ukraine mais
l'unité de la narration face à la crise
écologique qu'on va avoir à traverser
dans la durée comment on peut avoir une
unité de la nation quand les Français
ont le sentiment d'une sécession des
riches et je dirais que on trouve
aujourd'hui finalement dans le champ
politique un écho une traduction à cette
sécession des riches c'est la sécession
d'Emmanuel Macron quand dans le journal
l'opinion qui un journal libéral à un
journal de droite on lit aujourd'hui
retraite Macron seul contre tous avec
même Françoise Beyrout qui s'exprime et
qui dit une partie très importante de
l'opinion de se reconnaît pas dans cette
réforme avec un parlement autour de la
majorité qui dit et encore je ne sais
pas si son gouvernement soutient
vraiment la réforme qu'un homme seul
décide d'imposer comme ça aujourd'hui
contre les trois quarts des Français
contre 9 salariés sur Nice contre 9
manifestations avec deux trois millions
de personnes dans la rue je pense que on
a affaire à une sécession des élites qui
poste aussi à la démocratie très bien
merci monsieur le député donc sur ce je
mets aux voix cet amendement qui a reçu
un avis défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion commune
je passe la parole à Monsieur Guedj oui
madame madame la prison m'autoriser du
coup à apprendre un peu de temps parce
que cet amendement il a quand même la
particularité d'assumer d'assumer ce
qu'il propose un peu de temps deux
minutes
allez-y avec bonheur si vous voulez
défendez en même temps
depuis le début vous nous dites face aux
déficit programmé il y a trois
possibilités allonger la durée du
travail c'est ce que vous proposez
baisser les pensions personne n'en veut
et augmenter les cotisations on a
compris que vous dites pas un
prélèvement
supplémentaire avec ces amendements nous
assumons la proposition qui consiste à
mobiliser l'augmentation des cotisations
vieillesse qu'elle soit salariale ou
patronales madame leur rapporteur vous
avez indiqué dans la projection à
l'horizon 2032 moi je vais m'en tenir un
horizon plus proche le corps nous dit
qu'à l'horizon 2027 c'est 12 milliards
pour équilibrer
avec la seule mesure que nous vous
proposons là ce serait une augmentation
de 0,8 points des cotisations vieillesse
avec une répartition à faire c'est de
l'ordre du décret entre les cotisations
patronales et les cotisations salariales
pour que vous ayez un ordre de grandeur
ça signifie que il faudrait au niveau du
SMIC augmenter les cotisations sociales
et patronales et salariales de 14 euros
par mois et de 28 euros au niveau du
salaire médian pour résorber le déficit
et voyez ce débat là il est crucial
parce que moi je serai très intéressé
qu'on pose mais vraiment presque dans un
raisonnement maximaliste vous n'avez pas
voulu des autres modes de financement
mais au pire du pire de demander à nos
concitoyens et aux entreprises entre
deux ans de travail supplémentaires avec
les difficultés de taux d'emploi des
seniors que vous n'aurez pas résorbé
d'ici là et une augmentation des
cotisations avec une clause de revoyure
régulière c'est ce que prévoit les deux
amendements une clause de revoyure
régulière qui permet d'ajuster année
après année le montant des cotisations
pour équilibrer est-ce que vous pensez
pas qu'on est sur quelque chose de
beaucoup plus praticable de beaucoup
plus consensuel de beaucoup moins
conflictuel alors vous allez me
rétorquer on veut pas augmenter les
cotisations quelles qu'elles soient mais
par ailleurs on vous fera plus tard si
on a le temps après l'article 3 la
démonstration qu'il y a plein
d'exonération de cotisations 80
milliards au total 18 milliards sur la
seule branche vieillesse ont une grande
partie n'a pas d'efficacité économique
on l'a déjà évoqué et donc le refus même
et je termine par là en ayant débordé
que de 30 secondes le refus même
d'explorer l'hypothèse d'une
augmentation des cotisations salariales
et patronales et j'ajoute que beaucoup
de commentateurs ont dit c'est la
première réforme des retraites sur
laquelle on ne met pas à contribution
les entreprises sous forme d'une
augmentation des cotisations patronales
ça veut dire qu'on fait payer uniquement
aux travailleurs et on épargne les
entreprises vous voulez quelque chose
d'équilibré je vous propose une
augmentation des cotisations salariales
patronales et salariale pour éviter
certains pots sur la vie que sont les
deux années supplémentaires très bien
merci Madame la rapporteur votre avis
je voudrais
il y a une discussion
commune ah oui bah il les a défendu
tous les pardon je voudrais
je voudrais faire deux remarques la
première c'est que le président du corps
nous a bien redit que le corps ne
faisait pas de proposition ils font des
prévisions parce que c'est ce qui est
inscrit dans le dispositif de
l'amendement et d'autre part on a déjà
testé l'augmentation des cotisations
c'est pendant la réforme dernière
réforme des retraites avec réforme
Touraine puisqu'il y a une augmentation
de 1,15 points des cotisations ce qui a
augmenté le coût du travail et baisser
le salaire net sur les feuilles de paie
on préfère augmenter l'emploi c'est ce
que nous avons fait avec plus d'un
million cinq d'emplois créés pour ne pas
avoir à augmenter ce taux de cotisation
donc un avis défavorable
très bien monsieur Coulomme
on a entendu tout à l'heure
finalement de ce plaindre que au-delà
d'un certain tour on devenait
confisquatoire et finalement l'argent
que l'on prendrait à ceux qui détiennent
des capitaux phénoménaux se récomparable
au sang que l'on prend à ceux que l'on
va faire travailler plus longtemps
et bien alors comme je suis moi aussi un
peu feignant je vous cite je vais vous
lire directement un article des échos de
2012 je cite aux États-Unis dans les
années 30 la crise économique amène le
président Roosevelt à modifier
l'équilibre existant entre le marché et
l'État redistribuant ainsi les profits
économiques le New Deal destiné à
relancer l'économie américaine fut
accompagnée d'une nouvelle donne fiscale
je cite Roosevelt après tout les impôts
sont des cotisations que nous payons
pour jouir des privilèges de la
participation à une société organisée et
juste les années 20 ont vu une explosion
des très hautes rémunérations quand le
président démocrate arrive au pouvoir en
1932 le taux marginal de l'impôt sur les
revenus les plus élevés et de 25%. en
trois étapes il faudra passer
progressivement ce taux à 91%
en 1935 le revenu actes familièrement
appelé sows the rich attacks remet à
plat les règles d'imposition pour les
hauts revenus les personnes gagnant plus
de 200000 dollars ce qui correspond à un
million de dollars d'aujourd'hui par an
par an sont axés plus fortement à
hauteur de
63%. la loi fut révisée en 36 augmentant
le taux à 79 % pour atteindre ensuite
41% en 41 pendant près de 50 ans les
États-Unis vivront avec un taux marginal
d'imposition sur les très hauts revenus
proches de 80%. donc vous voyez on a
quand même une large marge avant que
vous qu'on puisse vous taxer d'être des
bourreaux de riches chers camarades des
autres rangs vous voyez vous avez encore
de quoi vous faire une bonne morale et
je ne cite pas là le fait que ici dans
cette assemblée certains groupes
politiques qui se réclament d'une Europe
chrétienne puisse faire appel également
à la charité chrétienne j'imagine un
Jésus qui débarquerait au milieu des
marchands du temple la parole est à
Monsieur Martin
Monsieur Martin merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
Présidente
sur
au cours de cette journée nous avons
entendu
je suis dans le micro comme je peux
je suis au plus près
je suis dans
le dans l'attente qu'on m'écoute merci
[Musique]
on a entendu aujourd'hui à peu près
toute la journée le nouveau slogan
du Parti socialiste nupes et de Monsieur
Jérôme Guedj à savoir l'impôt sur la vie
2 ans que l'on volerait
au retraités qui devrait partir en 64
ans
je rappelle je rappelle que là je réel
de départ en retraite est en moyenne de
63 ans et un mois pour les femmes et de
63 ans et 6 mois pour les hommes dans
notre pays
par conséquent il est tout à fait abusif
et
manipulateur de dire que l'on vole la
vie des gens en leur proposant de ne pas
augmenter leur cotisations retraite et
là évidemment nous sommes contre la
proposition qui vient d'être émise par
Monsieur Guez nous ne voulons pas
amputer le pouvoir d'achat des salariés
nous ne pouvons nous ne voulons pas
augmenter les cotisations patronales des
entreprises nous voulons le plein emploi
madame la rapporteur vient de le dire
c'est le plein emploi qui permet
effectivement de financer la protection
sociale dans notre pays et je précise
que dans notre réforme nous
redistribuons au moment de la retraite à
savoir que nous réduisons
progressivement les écarts de salaire
entre les femmes et les hommes et au
moment de la retraite notre proposition
réduit encore davantage cet écart des
retraites entre les hommes et les femmes
donc la proposition de réforme des
retraite qui est la nôtre est une
composition de redistribution entre les
hommes et les femmes au moment de la
retraite
oui merci madame la Présidente
j'écoutais tout à l'heure Jérôme Guedj
qui nous disait dans le rapport du corps
il manque 12 milliards en fait à
l'échelle de 2030 pour stabiliser tout
ça il m'accordera quand même que il a
passé sous silence les fameux 30
milliards de déficit structurels que
l'on connaît et c'est 30000 là ils sont
toujours là après il nous dit il y a
plusieurs pistes qu'on peut emprunter la
première piste c'est de dire on baisse
les retraites on dit non nous ne voulons
pas diminuer les retraits de rapport du
corps le dit très bien si on ne fait
rien et puis à Moscovici il a rappelé
lors de son audition si on ne fait rien
le système n'est pas sous table nous
disons non la deuxième solution c'est
dire on augmente les cotisations et bien
je suis en désaccord formé avec vous sur
l'augmentation des cotisations
salariales pourquoi parce que si vous
avez fait la démonstration vous-même on
va chercher 14 euros dans la poche de
nos retraités mais quelque part vous
diminuez leur pouvoir d'achat vous aviez
été les premiers et d'ailleurs de façon
juste à critiquer le fait que les APL
avaient été baissés de 5 euros et
comment maintenant vous expliqueriez à
ces mêmes français qu'on leur a enlevé
14 euros pour les retraites pour
stabiliser le système et lorsqu'on est
allé prendre 5 euros qui était une faute
voyez je suis très honnête devant vous
et bien là le raisonnement ne tient pas
donc vous dire que pour nous il y a une
troisième voie et cette troisième voie
on peut se retrouver peut-être ça sera
un jour de faire évoluer tant de travail
je sais pas de réorganisation du travail
je vois que des propositions sont faites
sur travailler sur quatre jours ce qu'il
faut quoi qu'il arrive et je terminerai
là-dessus l'équation en grande partie
réside sur le taux d'emploi des seniors
chacun a lu le magnifique rapport de
Lorenzi du cercle de l'épargne 47
milliards d'euros sont allés chercher
sur le taux d'emploi des seniors bagarre
en nous là-dessus faisons cela mais de
grâce ne l'ont pas toucher les
cotisations enfin dernier mot Jérôme
Guedj lorsque la CSG a été augmentée en
2018 pour norder
qui a été rétabli tout à l'heure par un
amendement tout le monde a considérer
que c'était injuste donc voyez bien que
ne nous reprochez pas ce que un moment
vous avez critiqué et qu'en fait vous
voyez bien que malheureusement votre
raisonnement n'est plus dans la
cohérence parce que 14 euros c'est 3
fois 50 vous avez demandé la parole
oui parce que
je pense que c'est important pour
éclairer nos débats et j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il y avait après la
confusion de Sandrine Rousseau entre
entre paresses et repos là on a une
confusion avec des références
spirituelles je sais pas si c'est le
lieu d'ailleurs ici mais le travail dans
la tradition chrétienne pour ce que j'en
sais
ce qui compte et d'ailleurs il y a une
forme d'appel à l'ardeur au travail ce
qui peut importe la nature de travail ce
qui compte c'est la dignité du travail
et la considération pour que pour que
pour celui qui l'exécute qui soit
considéré comme une personne et je crois
que c'est important de pas ce qu'on tout
à l'heure j'ai entendu le terme charité
mais il faut pas confondre charité et
dignité du travail c'est à mon avis une
confusion énorme qui est qui est faite
là d'ailleurs
j'ai bien suivi l'exemple tout à l'heure
en me disant mais vous savez dans les
boulangeries il y a la crème déborde
devant les devantures etc bon en ce
moment faut être sincère nos concitoyens
sont préoccupés par l'inflation et nous
boulangerie par pâtisserie par
l'augmentation des coûts d'énergie je
suis pas sûr que l'exemple dans le
contexte actuel la crème déborde comme
vous êtes en train de le dire il y a
plutôt des tensions sur les
approvisionnements des tensions sur
l'inflation et qu'en réalité je suis pas
je fais pas le même constat que vous et
sinon on n'aurait pas d'ailleurs on
pourrait aller beaucoup plus loin dans
ce qu'on voudrait redistribuer si on
avait davantage de richesses produites
c'est d'ailleurs tout l'enjeu je pense
que si on améliore le taux d'emploi et
je crois que l'important c'est un vrai
sujet chez les jeunes chez les seniors
chez les maires de famille derrière on
créera plus de richesses et on pourra
apporter plus de sérénité envers ceux
qui ont besoin et c'est tout
c'est tout ce qui peut amener à la à
l'excellence de notre modèle de
protection sociale c'est celui d'être
généreux parce qu'on est capable de
produire il faut tenir les deux et la
charité n'a rien à voir avec ça pour le
coup
très bien monsieur le député donc je
mets aux voix ces deux amendements
le 731 qui est pour qui a reçu bien sûr
à la vie défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur qui est pour qui contre
il est rejeté même à vie même vote pour
l'amendement suivant je vous remercie
amendement pouvant être mis en
discussion commune monsieur Guedj vous
avez la parole
madame Thomas il y a aucun Thomas aucun
problème
merci madame la Présidente je vais à mon
tour
donc faire plaider pour deux amendements
qui visent à créer une surcotisation au
bénéfice de l'assurance vieillesse sur
les hauts salaires de manière inflexible
le président dans sa campagne avait posé
une ambition celle de nous faire
travailler plus longtemps pour préserver
avec obstination sa volonté d'équilibrer
les finances publiques
l'équilibre des finances au détriment
d'une certaine idée de notre protection
sociale choix qui a coûté cher à bon
nombre de ses lieutenants dans
l'hémicycle et nous pouvons en témoigner
avec mon collègue boulot ici présent
demander aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps c'est la proposition ISO débat
mais dans un contexte bien particulier
je voulais revenir sur ce contexte avec
vous qui crée un gouffre entre les
attentes du terrain et les ambitions
présidentielles qui fait de cette
volonté politique l'objet d'un débat
légitime entre nous et la qualité des
travaux parlementaires c'est aujourd'hui
de se poser les questions essentielles
du financement de ce régime tout en
répondant bien sûr à l'urgence du moment
où les inquiétudes autour de ce projet
de loi sont fortes je reviens au
contexte pour rééquilibrer le
financement du système des retraites on
demande aux Français un effort
supplémentaire nous vivons une crise
sociale aiguë en matière d'accès aux
soins dans ma circonscription les
habitants le disent on cotise toute
notre carrière du travail toute notre
vie mais nous n'avons plus accès aux
soins ni à l'hôpital ni en médecine de
ville dans le monde rural nos
concitoyens cotisent mais sont en
rupture permanente d'égalité dans
l'accès aux soins l'injustice est
vertigineuse le contexte c'est aussi le
litre d'essence qui remonte à presque 2
euros les étudiants de plus en plus
nombreux qui font la queue aux Banques
Alimentaires pourtant face aux hausse du
coût de la vie on demande aux Français
de sacrifier deux années de plus dans
leur vie dans ce contexte les grandes
entreprises versent 44 milliards à leur
actionnaires alors amendement
identique monsieur Guedj
j'avais le deuxième amendement à porter
donc
me laisser la parole bien sûr donc voilà
je disais que dans ce contexte les
grandes entreprises versent 44 milliards
à leur actionnaires et ce sont les 5%
les plus rémunérés qui ont vu leurs
revenus fortement augmenté BNP par la
sanofiac ça LVMH avec cumulé 35
milliards d'euros de bénéfices net en
2021 et ont donc versé en 2022 des
dividendes en augmentation de
32%. donc notre réflexion c'est celle de
poser la question de la redistribution
des richesses pour préserver l'équilibre
financier de nos retraites les grandes
entreprises
ont une part de responsabilité à prendre
et pour l'intérêt général les hausses
salaires ont aussi un rôle à jouer notre
responsabilité se joue c'est de proposer
des sources de financement pour le
système des retraites
ce tout petit amendement ou en tout cas
les deux que je vous propose à voter ça
n'est pas grand chose mais c'est sans
doute un grand pas pour l'égalité et la
justice républicaine
très bien monsieur Ruffin vous défendez
le 33 52 c'est moi
nous souhaitons proposer d'augmenter le
taux de cotisation salariales des
plafonnés d'assurance vieillesse sur le
revenu supérieur au plafond de la
sécurité sociale vous le savez le
système de retraite n'est pas en
faillite les maigres économies que le
gouvernement entend faire en faisant
travailler les Français plus longtemps
sont équivalentes à peu près à la baisse
des impôts de production promise le
gouvernement
ne prend pas non plus en compte les les
surcoûts élevés du chômage de la santé
et des versements de et des
renversements par contre de prestations
sociales au final un relèvement de l'âge
légal à 64 ans apporterait des économies
infinies soit à peu près 2,5 milliards
d'euros par contre
par contre selon la Commission des
contes de la sécurité sociale augmenter
d'un point les cotisations globales des
plafonnées rapporterait 6 milliards
d'euros nous défendons vous l'avez bien
compris une autre vision de la société
nous ouvrons pour la réduction du temps
de travail et l'augmentation des
salaires et des pensions cela a un coût
et c'est pour la cette raison là que
nous proposons de la surcotisation des
eaux salaires ce qui permettra d'en
assumer une partie si ça vous intéresse
pas ce que je vous dis c'est pas les
collègues vous pouvez écouter
vous avez fini madame la député
très bien merci Monsieur Clouet
non c'est vous allez-y madame Simona
je suis désolé mais
je pense que vous pouvez pas faire
celui-ci madame non
parce que vous n'êtes pas consignateur
oui madame allez-y je on a du mal à
s'entendre parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
bruit c'est un peu compliqué
alors je dois je dois reconnaître que
vous mettez du coeur à l'ouvrage quoi
que vous avez l'air d'y croire de moins
en moins et pour cause vous n'arrivez
plus à convaincre personne que le régime
des retraites est infaillite plus vous
expliquez plus vous appuyez sur ce point
plus les gens comprennent grâce
probablement à votre pédagogie la
réalité c'est-à-dire que les dépenses de
retraite sont relativement maîtrisées
comme le rappelait le président du corps
par contre votre dogmatisme libéral en
multipliant les cadeaux fiscaux au plus
riches et en voulant à tout prix baisser
le coût du travail a tendance à assécher
des recettes donc rappelons une chose le
travail ne coûte pas il produit de la
richesse ce qui coûte c'est la ponction
coopère le capital sur le fruit du
travail mais à l'aide d'une rhétorique
culpabilisatrice et répétée à outrance
vous avez
si vous voulez parler de coût pourquoi
ne pas parler du coût du capital qui
augmente chaque jour avec votre
politique les maigres économies que le
gouvernement souhaite faire en volant
deux années de vie aux françaises et aux
Français sont équivalentes à la baisse
des impôts de production promise au
MEDEF les aides publiques aux
entreprises représentent plus de 150
milliards parlant par an voilà ce qui
coûte cher bref de réalité s'imposerait
à vous si vous étiez de bonne foi en
matière de retraite et de travailler de
protection sociale le système de
retraite n'est pas en faillite le lien
entre prix du travail et chômage est
inexistant surtout au niveau des eaux
salaires donc avec cet amendement les
salaires supérieurs au plafond de la
sécurité sociale sur cotiserait et
participerait donc mieux à la solidarité
nationale c'est un premier pas dans la
bonne direction très bien
et chacun reçoit
le 33 54
vous pouvez dire défendu
oui allez-y
bien écoutez vous avez donc décidé de
condamner le peuple à deux enferme soit
disant pour sauver le système de
retraite
alors souffrez quand même ce que le
droit de tout à l'heure moi me choque
profondément je vais faire la
pardon
alors souffrez qu'il est que 18h36 que
votre apéro n'aura pas lu avant 20h il
faudra donc que vous attendiez 20 heures
pour passer à autre chose vous à 20h
vous allez passer un appel
très bien mais c'est un supportable vous
avez déjà décidé en prenant le PLF
SS rectificatif et l'article 47 1 vous
avez décidé de vous débarrasser de tout
débat démocratique en expédiant en
expédiant les amendements en débat dans
cette commission c'est une façon mais
vraiment
du débat démocratique alors souffrez
vous prétendez qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
choix pour sauver le système de retraite
que d'imposer ces deux enfers au peuple
nous n'arrêtons pas de vous démontrer
amendement par amendement qu'il y a bien
d'autres solutions
moi je vais vous dire samedi je faisais
un café populaire dans un quartier un
quartier très populaire à Saint-Blaise
dans le 20e il y avait une phrase très
forte d'une femme qui est secrétaire et
qui disait c'est insupportable demande
ma grande entreprise
les supérieurs tout en haut là ils ont
plusieurs zéro de plus que moi sur la
feuille de paye pourquoi on leur prend
pas à eux à ce conclus plusieurs 0 de
plus que moi alors que moi va me prendre
deux ans deux ans de ma vie elle est où
la justice alors là c'est amendement
puisque vous refusez taxer les super
profit puisque vous refusez toutes les
autres propositions qui ont été faites
là ça me semble quand même très modeste
c'est simplement de dire très bien merci
Madame
intervention
à ces monsieur Lucas allez-y
bien mes collègues
Thomas Leduc Amrani et Simonet on dit
l'essentiel et vous ont démontré je
crois parfaitement que d'autres choix
sont possibles pour financer les
retraites dans notre pays que de priver
les Français de 2 ans de bonheur deux
ans de repos deux ans de réparation
parfois de carrière dure et pénible deux
ans d'engagement associatifs pourquoi
pas un engagement syndical d'ailleurs on
a vu hier que le syndicalisme avait de
l'avenir dans notre dans notre pays et
au fond au cœur de ce débat il y a ce
que j'évoquais ce que notre collègue
Ruffin évoquait tout à l'heure une
question qui est une question
profondément morale oui oui nous
considérons que il est profondément
immoral quand
une infime minorité de privilégiée
accumule les richesses
s'accaparent les ressources créant une
forme ça a été dit de séparatisme dans
la société que cette opulence s'étale
s'enrichit s'amplifie à mesure que vos
politiques publiques se déploient et que
dans le même temps vous demandez aux
françaises et aux Français de sacrifier
deux années de vie deux années de vie de
vie en bonne santé pour assouvir
assouvir vos objectifs idéologiques
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
et c'est parce que les Français sont
d'accord avec nous qu'ils étaient hier 2
millions 800 000 dans la rue et 8700 à
Annonay la ville dont a été Maire le
ministre du Travail du Pôle emploi et du
retournement de veste monsieur du stop
c'est la démonstration évidente qu'il y
a aujourd'hui une soif de justice et de
dignité dans notre pays il est 18h40 et
jusqu'à 20h vous l'entendrez revenir
alors très bien Madame la rapporteur
général votre avis s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît monsieur Vigier monsieur
Vigier la rapporteur général va nous
donner son avis sur ses amendements
merci madame la Présidente redire à
Madame
Simonet que depuis lundi matin on
expédie pas les amendements et que je
m'attache en tout cas essayer d'être la
plus concrète et de répondre à chacun
des amendements même si ils sont répétés
répétés répétés pour je voulais répondre
à madame Thomas parce que justement je
suis complètement en désaccord
c'est-à-dire votre argumentation je
pense que c'est complètement l'inverse
pour moi en tout cas vous dites que
c'est parce que on a des hôpitaux
publics en mauvais état qu'il faut
proposer cette surcotisation mais je
crois que c'est parfaitement l'inverse
je pense que il ne faut pas augmenter le
coût du travail parce que sinon ça va
diminuer les emplois et donc notre
richesse et je crois que c'est très
important ce débat sur la richesse que
nous devons créer en plus dans notre
pays je pense que c'est un enjeu face à
une guerre en Europe face à des défis
sur la souveraineté
énergétique sur les défis de la
transition écologique et que c'est parce
qu'on doit créer cette richesse qu'il ne
faut surtout pas augmenter le coût du
travail donc pour cette raison
défavorable à vos amendements
très bien
Madame Thévenot
merci merci madame la Présidente en
réalité alors je sais pas à quelle heure
il est parce que je crois qu'il y a une
nouvelle règle c'est de dire l'heure
qu'il est il est 18h41 et il est 18h41
et nous pouvons constater et nous
pouvons constater qu'à 18h41 mercredi la
nuit a fini par être prise à son propre
jeu à force de dire tout et n'importe
quoi en permanence vous avez fini par
vous contredire vous-même je m'explique
là vous êtes en train de nous proposer
un amendement pour avoir une
surcotisation sur les salaires les plus
élevés vous allez me dire rien de
nouveau sous les tropiques vous voulez
en permanence taxer imposé celles et
ceux qui ont qui sont le plus à l'aise
financièrement vous êtes tout à fait sur
votre ligne sauf que ce matin ce matin
non pas un lapin mais vous nous avez
fait j'ai la blague vous nous avez fait
voter vous nous avez fait voter en
commission un amendement pour pour
favoriser non pas les retraités les plus
modestes mais les plus aisés et ce n'est
pas moi qui le dis moi aussi monsieur
Ruffin je lis la presse monsieur Ruffin
cause mais c'est pas grave c'est
Marianne qui le dit la nuque obtient la
baisse de la CSG et fait ainsi un cadeau
au retraiter les plus aisés et donc et
donc j'ai envie j'ai envie de vous
demander à vous j'ai envie de vous me
demander à vous la gauche mais qui
êtes-vous où habitez-vous que
faites-vous ici
merci Monsieur Isaac Sybille et lui seul
à la parole s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
merci
merci madame la Présidente
l'intérêt
l'intérêt de ces amendements
contrairement au précédent
c'est qu'ils sont dans la logique de
l'équilibre de par des régimes par
répartition première chose et on le
répète si vous demandez plus de
cotisation c'est que vous admettez que
les régimes sont en déséquilibre jusqu'à
maintenant vous disiez il y a pas de
problème donc on peut tous
ici autour de ces tables
affirmer que c'est ces régimes sont en
déficit ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose qu'est-ce que vous faites
vous préférez effectivement jouer sur
les cotisations mais en fait c'est
uniquement financement du rééquilibrage
à crédit vous le savez les cotisations
employeurs employés et vous le répétez à
longueur de temps sont des salaires
différés si on reprend les chiffres par
exemple de Monsieur Guedj 28 euros par
mois multiplié par 12 mois et multiplié
par 43 ans au final c'est quoi ces 15000
euros que vous prenez à chaque français
et même
ça ça revient puis pas la même chose
et en plus vous dites que cela si on
continue dans quelques années on va
continuer à augmenter les taux donc
c'est pour ça que notre majorité préfère
proposer aux Français plutôt que de
confisquer ces sommes immédiatement de
travailler plus pour assurer ce régime
par répartition et pour augmenter les
futures pensions je vous remercie
très bien de la part de Madame la
rapporteur général donc le 30 le 733 qui
est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
identique je les mets tous ensemble qui
est pour
qui est contre ils sont tous rejetés
très bien j'arrive à deux amendements
oui deux amendements identiques monsieur
dareville non monsieur jumelle vous le
défendez le 70 83
oui il consiste cet amendement à trouver
des modalités de financement
en augmentant les cotisations patronales
mais en prenant en compte les éléments
virtueux des politiques salariales en
matière d'emploi de formation de respect
des objectifs sociaux d'emploi du
Seigneur etc etc donc si le modulation
de de la cotisation patronale en
fonction
du caractère plus ou moins vertueux de
la gestion salariale
très bien amendement suivant monsieur
Monet non il est parti qui défend c'est
défendu le 71 pas défendu
très bien y a-t-il quelqu'un oui
d'accord très bien Madame la rapporteur
votre avis sur ses amendements c'est un
amendement qui augmente le coût du
travail donc avis défavorable monsieur
Ferracci
madame la Présidente je réagis à cet
moment parce que il y a dans cet
amendement l'esprit mais juste seulement
juste une partie de l'esprit d'un
système de bonus malus sauf que c'est
évidemment le malus sent le bonus et
donc en fonction des critères qui sont
évoqués dans l'amendement ça se traduit
par des hausses de coût du travail de
manière systématique ce que je veux dire
et peut-être pour prolonger la
discussion que nous avons entamé tout à
l'heure avec Monsieur Guedj sur les
hausses de cotisation sociale c'est que
les effets sur l'emploi de séance de
cotisation sociale sont bien établies
bien documentées ils sont évidemment
très importants et très négatif et à
partir du moment où l'on détruit des
emplois en augmentant les cotisations
sociales et bien on n'a pas le rendement
en termes de finances publiques que l'on
aurait pu espérer je vais attirer
l'attention ici sur une étude de la
Terra Nova qui parlera très probablement
à nos collègues des bancs de la gauche
qui elle-même évoquent une étude de
l'OFCE qui parlera également au bord de
la gauche
cette étude dit qu'un point de hausse
des cotisations se traduit après avoir
détruit des emplois et dégrader la
compétitivité des entreprises par 02
point seulement de rendement pour les
finances publiques c'est pas moi qui le
dis c'est Terranova qui reprend le FCE
donc prenons garde chers collègues à
tout cela et ayons en tête également que
des augmentations de cotisations
patronales ont toujours une incidence
sur les salaires puisqu'elle se reporte
toujours sur les salaires bruts et
qu'elle pénalise le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés je vous remercie
très bien monsieur Juvin
s encore des taxes cet amendement va
détruire des emplois donc nous ne sommes
pas favorables
très bien
c'est tout donc je vais mettre aux voix
ces deux amendements
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés je vous
remercie alors des amendements pouvant
être mis en discussion commune avec des
amendements identiques monsieur kalifère
défendu
[Musique]
non non non je suis pas dans cela voilà
c'est un moment qui anticipe quelque peu
avec les discussions que nous aurons sur
l'article 9 qui vise notamment à créer
deux fonds de prévention de la
pénibilité
défaut de fonds
de départ à la retraite de 62 ans à 64
ans coûterait 1 milliard 8 l'euro par an
en dépense supplémentaire
soit un coup plus de plus de 7 fois
supérieur et dépenses prévisionnelles
des fonds plutôt que de prendre ce
milliard dans les caisses du régime
c'est à maintenant propose donc une
nouvelle source de financement pour la
prévention de la pénibilité en créant un
malus de cotisation sociale au bénéfice
de la branche ATMP payable par les
entreprises présentant une sinistralité
anormalement élevé si ton amendement qui
vise la responsabiliser
l'écosystème de l'entreprise voilà
madame la Présidente l'amendement qui
est bien du pays même on n'est pas au
pays hors sol mais il faudra
certainement en allongeant le temps de
travail pensez à la pénibilité et
financer
très bien amendement suivant
identique 49 80 monsieur Petavy
défendu
amendement 38 26 monsieur Petavy
[Musique]
la Présidente c'est amendement a pour
objectif de trouver des financements qui
sont directement liés à la question de
la pénibilité
vous le savez les entreprises sont
amenées à licencier des travailleurs et
des travailleurs pour inaptitude le plus
souvent d'ailleurs en raison des
pénibilités liées à leur poste de
travail et on a souvent des gens qui
sont licenciés et ce sont ceux-là après
que l'on retrouve dans les fameux ni en
emploi ni etc etc parce que au bout du
bout ils finissent par n'avoir plus de
droit or ces personnes qui sont
licenciées pour inaptitude On peut même
pas les compter dans notre pays
aujourd'hui on a pas de chiffres réels
pas de suivi c'est un véritable problème
et deuxièmement bien entendu on ne peut
pas donc contrôler la façon dont les
entreprises opère ses licenciements
est-ce qu'elles ont oui ou non chercher
à reclasser vraiment ces personnes
est-ce qu'elles ne se sont pas un peu
finalement
débarrassé à bon compte de ces
travailleurs qu'elles ont usé jusqu'à
l'os
et puis en les licenciant pour pour fin
de tout recevoir donc en fin de tout
recevoir et en guise de remerciement
donc il s'agit là de mettre en place un
malus pour les entreprises qui
présentent une tendance élevée à
licencier des travailleurs et des
travailleurs pour inaptitude ce sont
c'est l'objet de ces deux amendements
que je vous ai ainsi présentés en une
seule prise de parole
merci madame la députée il reste un
autre amendement elle a défendu les deux
madame la rapporteur votre avis merci
madame la Présidente le taux de
cotisation
ATMP varie déjà en fonction du taux de
sinistralité dans l'entreprise donc
c'est un avis défavorable
très bien alors Monsieur turquois
oui merci madame la Présidente d'abord
je voulais aller dans le sens de ce que
je viens de dire Madame la rapporteur
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a déjà une
application des conséquences en termes
de taux ATMP quand il y a une
sinistralité dans l'entreprise donc
c'est déjà c'est déjà pris en compte
d'autre part je voudrais quand même
m'opposer
à l'image que les entreprises vont comme
épuisé
usé jusqu'à la corde leur salarié ça
peut peut-être arriver dans certaines
situations je pense que je connais
beaucoup d'entreprises ou entre
l'employeur entre le chef d'entreprise
et ses salariés il y a une un respect
mutuel et une volonté de préserver au
maximum les individus
vous vous décrivez vous décrivez des
situations qui
qui ont sûrement existé qui existe
sûrement encore mais qui ne sont pas le
lot
de beaucoup de beaucoup d'entreprises la
dernière chose c'est peut-être
l'occasion de
d'éclairer un point particulier
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'emploi des
seniors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous employez un
seigneur
vous voudriez employer un seigneur qui
était qui serait au chômage
si vous êtes une PME vous l'embryez un
seigneur et l'année d'après il va
déclarer une maladie une maladie du
travail une maladie professionnelle ça
c'est un vrai problème parce que si
déclare la maladie professionnelle à 57
ans alors que vous l'avez embauché à 56
ans statistiquement sa maladie
professionnelle sera lié à ce qu'il a
fait au début de sa carrière et là
l'impact va se traduire pour
l'entreprise qui aurait fait l'effort de
l'embaucher à cet âge-là et là nous
devons je pense avoir une réflexion sur
peut-être une mutualisation
des taux d'atmp à partir d'un certain
âge je pense que ça a été évoqué avec
monsieur le ministre je sais pas où on
en sera au moment de l'examen en
hémicycle
mais défavorable à ses amendements
intéressants en disant il doit y avoir
un malus quand il y a beaucoup
d'inaptitudes dans les entreprises le 19
janvier au matin de la grève moi je suis
sur un rond-point à Amiens et je
rencontre les syndicalistes de Goodyear
Dunlop qu'est-ce qui me raconte il me
raconte que tous les mois dans leur
boîte il y a une ou deux personnes qui
sortent pour inaptitude
auparavant jusqu'à la loi el khomri
Macron il y avait une obligation de
reclassement à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise et il fallait l'accord des
syndicats pour que éventuellement il y a
licenciement maintenant il y a plus cet
accord-là qui est nécessaire ce qui fait
que les gens se font virer et Monsieur
turquoise ça dépend pas de la bonne
volonté de telle et telle patron soit
ils existent et même ils sont la
majorité mais quand on est dans des
grandes entreprises quand on est dans la
grande distribution quand on est dans le
bâtiment quand on est dans des
usines comme Goodyear Dunlop là ce sont
des secteurs entiers où le taux d'une
aptitude 55 57 ans 59 ans devient
extrêmement élevé donc là il y aurait la
nécessité sur ces secteur là en effet
qui est une contribution supérieure pour
que les gens se retrouvent pas derrière
avec du Revenu de Solidarité Active
après avoir traîné la pâte pendant un an
et demi deux ans de chômage c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
qu'il faut rajouter dans ce malus un
autre risque qui est le risque
psychosocial qui est le burn out qui est
qui est le fait que aujourd'hui ça ça
pète dans tous les sens sur le terrain
psychologique et que pour l'instant
c'était d'ailleurs une revendication des
syndicats quand ils ont été reçus la
semaine dernière par la commission des
affaires sociales les risques
psychosociaux ne sont pas reconnus dans
le tableau des maladies professionnelles
et bien elle a nécessité de reconnaître
les risques psychosociaux entre autres
le burn out dans le tableau des maladies
professionnelles
très bien la parole est à Monsieur de la
porte
je vais pas revenir sur ce que vient de
dire mon camarade Ruffin sur la
nécessité d'intégrer les risques
psychosociaux mais parler plus largement
de la question de l'usure
professionnelle et de l'amendement
présenté avec mon collègue kalifère
quand on vous propose d'instaurer un
malus sur les cotisations des employeurs
dû au titre des accidents du travail des
maladies professionnelles pour les
entreprises n'ayant pas pris de mesures
nécessaires pour éliminer un risque
avéré de maladies professionnelles on
vous propose juste quelque chose qui
nous semble être la base et donc quand
j'entends mon collègue dire turquois qui
dit Monsieur turquois bon la plupart des
patrons ils sont bien et ça se passe
bien en fait c'est pas le sujet
le sujet qu'on compose ici c'est de dire
pour les entreprises où ça se passe pas
bien il faut mettre des sanctions donc
en fait c'est tout simple on ne pointe
personne du doigt on dit juste que il y
a plein d'endroits où ça se passe pas
bien on dit pas que c'est majoritaire on
dit rien de tout ça mais on constate
simplement que les salariés aujourd'hui
en France ils ont des risques ils
subissent de l'usure professionnelle ils
vont pas bien et que notre rôle notre
rôle c'est de faire en sorte que les
entreprises elles mettent tout en oeuvre
pour que ça aille mieux et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que vous proposez
finalement avec l'index seniors ce n'est
qu'une transposition de cela avec une
logique de bonus malus chère à notre
collègue ferrachi et donc c'est pour
cela que j'espère que vous soutiendrez
cette démarche qui n'est qu'une démarche
de bon sens et qui transpose exactement
ce que vous avez fait par exemple sur
l'assurance chômage et pour finir
j'évoquerai le cas de salariés que je
côtoie fréquemment et qui sont cassés
je pense à Angelica elle a le dos en
compote mais elle n'arrive pas à faire
reconnaître cela comme une maladie
professionnelle pourquoi parce que elle
porte des gens elle porte des gens et
elle se brise le dos mais
malheureusement vous avez supprimé ces
critères avec votre réforme de 2017 et
puisqu'on n'aura pas le temps de parler
de pénibilité parce que vous avez refusé
qu'on est plus de trois jours de
commission il faut évoquer ce que vous
ne faites pas dans ce texte vous ne
rétablissez pas les quatre critères de
pénibilité et vous nous empêchez
finalement de faire en sorte que les
gens comme Angelica elle puisse avoir
des droits supplémentaires à la retraite
c'est malheureux et nous dénonçons
très bien Madame Tallier Pollion c'est
un amendement trois choses d'abord qu'on
connaisse mieux le nombre de personnes
qui sont déclarées inapte et qu'on
puisse suivre après leur situation parce
que on a beaucoup de misère sociale en
fin de carrière liée aux suites et aux
conséquences de ces mises en inaptitude
la deuxième chose c'est éviter et
empêcher les comportements
irresponsables et scandaleux d'un
certain nombre de d'employeurs qui ne
font rien pour éviter ces inaptitudes
mais considèrent que c'est dans les
c'est dans leur coup et que donc voilà
et pour le salarié lui il est victime il
est victime du travail qu'il a fait et
il est victime de la situation sociale
qui lui est faite et troisième chose
pour faire en sorte que les que la
situation s'améliore parce que c'est
bien à ça qu'on doit penser
se mettre en place ce bonus malus il va
donner davantage envie de mettre en
place de vrais politiques de prévention
et pas de prévention à 55 ans quand le
malais fait quand on a déjà mal au
poignet ou aux épaules non de prévention
primaire pour améliorer l'organisation
du travail pour améliorer les outils de
travail les conditions de travail ce qui
permettra de faire en sorte que les
carrières se déroulent mieux et que ces
licenciements pour inaptitude soit
éviter vous savez le président de la
République refuse de dire que le travail
est pénible et il préfère le mot d'usure
oui il y a des travailleurs qui sont
usés mais pourquoi ils sont usés parce
que le travail est pénible donc il faut
faire en sorte qu'il le soit le moins
possible et pour cela une seule solution
la prévention et pas que la prévention
individuelle en bout de course non la
prévention dès le départ la prévention
primaire
très bien j'ai monsieur alosé ou
monsieur Maillard qui prend la
parole monsieur alouzet oui merci madame
le Président sur la pénibilité sur les 9
critères initiaux 6 ont été maintenus
pourquoi les trois critères
ergonomiques port de charges
rappelez des mois pour deux charges
vibrations vibration et postures non non
chimique il est maintenu non non il est
maintenu
bien pourquoi les trois les trois
critères là on parle des critères
ergonomiques principalement bon chers
collègues là
je parle des critères purement
ergonomiques donc port de charge posture
et vibration reconnaissez quand même que
tel qu'ils étaient construits mais bien
sûr je les ai voté mais vous remarquerez
que même vous bottez des choses qui sont
pas très justes notamment la suppression
de la CSG tout à l'heure au bénéfice des
gens les plus aisés donc voyez que c'est
pas toujours facile bien donc vous
reviendrez dessus comme je reviens sur
ce vote que j'ai eu à l'époque parce que
évidemment vous imaginez que c'était
assez compliqué de mesurer chaque
personne combien de fois par jour elle
se baisse à 30 degrés 45 degrés 70
degrés c'est la portée 5 kg 10 kg 15 kg
enfin bref c'était c'était la radio du
dos ne sert strictement à rien monsieur
jumelles parler de ce que vous
connaissez la radio du dos ne sert
strictement à rien pour évaluer les
douleurs et les handicaps des personnes
bien
c'est pas facile de parler quand on a
des jumelles dans le dos
bien alors j'essaye de terminer mais
c'est pas facile
différente avec un travail avec les
branches dont on s'est à peu près avec
certains indicateurs lesquels dans
lesquels les personnes sont plus
exposées on voit bien les personnes
assistantes maternelles dans les crèches
et bien d'autres et donc dans ses
branches il y aura un travail spécifique
pour identifier des personnes et un
travail individuel avec un suivi médical
renforcé ou de la des visites de 45 ans
et de et de 62 ans 61 ans il y aura des
visites beaucoup plus fréquentes qui
permettront d'appliquer la la pénibilité
et c'est à ça entre autres que vont
servir les 6 milliards qu'on collecte
sur les 18 c'est à financer alors pour
les plus jeunes la prévention et pour
les plus âgés parce que malheureusement
parfois c'est trop tard des mesures de
sorte qu'ils puissent partir avant l'âge
à 62 ans donc il faut le dire
malheureusement à cause de la forme des
débats qu'on a ici on n'aura pas pu
discuter de cette pénibilité c'est
pourtant l'enjeu essentiel des 6
milliards qu'on va collecter pour
progresser pour aider les gens à partir
à continuer à partir plus tôt mais ça on
le dit pas surtout faut pas le dire faut
plutôt
pardon pour ma passion madame la
Présidente
merci madame la Présidente dites moi
comment faire confiance une majorité qui
a supprimé 4 critères sur 10 de
pénibilité
ont été retirés du compte professionnel
de prévention les postures les charges
lourdes les vibrations mécaniques et
l'exposition aux agents chimiques dans
le programme que nous défendons la
pénibilité non seulement prise en compte
à travers des trimestres supplémentaires
définies par branches et secteur
d'activité mais surtout à travers un
système d'innuité progressive en raison
de l'âge d'entrée sur le marché du
travail merci
très bien donc Madame la rapporteur
général merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais dire à Monsieur de la porte qui
va pouvoir assurer
Angelica qui a des problèmes de dos vous
voyez moi je suis rhumatologue le lundi
matin et cette partie sur la pénibilité
à un article que j'ai regardé tout
particulièrement comme l'a dit mon
collègue
Erica lozet je regrette d'ailleurs un
qu'on soit pas allé jusqu'à cet article
9 parce que pour Angelica qui était
peut-être dans la manifestation hier
parce qu'elle est inquiète pour son mal
de dos
je n'en doute pas il va vous allez
pouvoir lui expliquer qu'avec cette
réforme elle va elle va pouvoir avoir un
droit qui était jusque la virtuel
et un droit qui va devenir effectivement
les le mal de dos les vibrations comme
ça a été dit par mon collègue ça ne
n'était pas efficace dans le C3 P donc
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que nous les
avions retirés et c'est pour cette
raison que dans cet article 9 nous
mettons plusieurs mesures dont le fond
d'investissement de la prévention de 1
milliard qui va permettre aux
entreprises de pouvoir mieux adapter le
l'environnement au travail qui va
permettre de pouvoir avoir des congés
payés pour reconversion qui va permettre
aussi avoir un suivi individuel de
prévention parce que vous voyez dans le
mal de dos c'est pas une fatalité quand
on fait de la prévention et quand on
peut avoir une activité physique
éventuellement adaptée
ça permettra à cette dame forcément
inquiète qu'on lui dise qu'elle va avoir
deux ans de plus à travailler et ben
avec ces mesures elle arrivera peut-être
en travaillant un peu plus un peu plus
longtemps mais avec un dos qui lui fait
moins mal
très bien donc je vais mettre au voie
mes chers collègues je vais mettre aux
voix les deux amendements
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés même
avis même vote pour le 38 26 même avis
même vote pour le 68 61
et le 68 62 très bien ils sont tous
rejetés
alors amendement amendement suivant
madame kéké non allez-y
madame la Présidente collègue partait à
ma demande nous souhaitons augmenter la
pénibilité finance la pénalité
financière des entreprises qui ne
respectent pas les objectifs de
réduction des écarts de rémunération
entre les femmes et les hommes l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
constituent également un ange financier
majeur dans le secteur privé les femmes
gagnent
28,5% de moins que les hommes en moyenne
elle travaille plus souvent à temps
partiel et dans des métiers moins bien
payés que les hommes en neutralisant
l'effet des temps partiel et des heures
supplémentaires le salaire annuel net
moyen des femmes en équivalent temps
plein et toujours inférieur 16,8% à
celui des hommes un écart expliqué en
partie par la discrimination salariale
mais aussi par le fait que les femmes
occupent souvent que les hommes
dépositions sociaux des positions
socioprofessionnelles moins favorables
dans les sectes on peut pas on peut pas
parler on peut pas s'il vous plaît
donc
bref il y a même temps
et même attendent mais on peut pas et
même attendre de travail hypothèque
équivalent l'écart de salaire et de
5,3%. les femmes représentent 80% des
travailleurs pauvres et la course à la
précarisation les touches en plein de
plein fouet malgré les lois successives
en matière en matière d'égalité
professionnelle les écarts en termes de
salaire ne se réduisent pas si le rythme
reste le même les femmes devraient
gagner autant que les hommes d'ici
2234 selon l'économiste Rebecca Amsellem
hier collègues vous poussiez tous des
cris d'orfrés comme mes collègues
ruffins jumelles et les Oman vous parlez
de la colère populaire que vous
contribuez à créer avec cette réforme
inacceptable je vous rappelle que les
femmes ont toujours joué un rôle sur sur
le premier plan lors des grandes
révoltes populaires celle-là même qui
nous honorent et en tant que
représentant du peuple français ainsi ce
sont les femmes qui le 5 octobre 1789
rechercher le Capet à Versailles je vous
l'affirme aujourd'hui
que ce soit les premières touchées les
femmes sont et seront au premier plan de
la mobilisation contre c'est votre
réforme dans la rue et sur ces bancs
comme l'écrit le grand Pasolini tant que
l'homme exploitera l'homme tant que
l'humanité sera divisée en maître et un
esclave il y aura ni moralité ni paix
à Madame la rapporteur et rebondir sur
cette question des femmes parce que
quand je vous parle d'Angelica
vous me dites elle pourra travailler un
peu plus longtemps avec un dos qui fait
moins mal parce que vous aurez créé à
l'article 9 un fond d'investissement
dans la prévention mais moi je suis en
je suis hors de moi et je vous le dis
parce que Angelica son dos il est déjà
brisé alors ne vous ferez la prévention
que vous voudrez ça va pas lui ça va pas
lui remettre son dos droit ça va pas lui
mettre son dos droit elle est allée à la
médecine du travail on l'a dit circulez
rien à voir donc franchement quand
j'entends ce genre de réponse mais je
suis franchement je suis resté très
calme mais là moi je suis hors de moi et
je pense que c'est toutes les Angelica
qui nous regardent elles seront hors
d'elles parce que la question de la
pénibilité vous n'avez pas rien vous
n'avez pas réintroduit les critères de
pénibilité monsieur à l'oser ce n'est
pas vrai donc Madame madame risque
franchement
il ne répond pas à la problématique
posée pour Angelica en particulier et je
comprends qu'elle soit dans la rue elle
y était et elle est continuera
madame Le Nabour
merde d'ailleurs sur ce que vient de
dire monsieur de la porte madame la
rapporteur a posé les mesures que nous
prenons pour
prévenir l'usure professionnelle dont
effectivement le suivi médical la visite
à 45 ans et le fond de de prévention
enfin le fond d'un milliard pour la
prévention moi vous pensez à Angélique
car moi je pense à Marie à Alice à
Adeline à Elie ce sont toutes mes
anciennes collègues qui sont professeurs
de danse encore aujourd'hui et qui
effectivement et bien sont et bien sont
amenés à faire
mais non non alors excusez-moi mais vous
savez que non non la danse c'est
justement des milliers de professeurs
bon en tous les cas pour vous dire que
beaucoup pour vous dire que je voilà que
que au-delà du fonds de prévention du
suivi médical il y a la possibilité
d'aider à la reconversion et tout cet
argent et bien nous investissons dans la
pardon dans la prévention d'usure
professionnelle mais que et bien la
nupaisse vient de nous retirer 3
milliards d'euros en donnant et bien de
l'argent au retraiter les plus aigés les
plus aisés c'est dommage parce que et
bien mes collègues étaient très
heureuses qu'on puisse investir dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
très bien monsieur Cyril Isaac Sibille
merci ma présidente madame m'a apporté
génial je suis très content qu'on puisse
évoquer la prévention dans le sens où on
ne pourra pas malheureusement le faire
je félicite les députés de laupes on
vient de franchir la barre des 5000
amendements il nous reste moins d'une
heure et on a il nous reste encore 5000
amendements à voir bravo messieurs
mesdames vous avez gagné on n'aura pas
pu examiner le projet de loi et dans ce
projet de loi il y a des grandes
avancées comme effectivement le fond
d'investissement par rapport à la
prévention
et c'est bien que générale et puis
évoquer parce que malheureusement on
n'aura pas l'occasion de le faire
très bien merci Madame la rapporteur
général oui merci juste un mot monsieur
Delaporte si cette dame elle a un dos
brisé c'est à dire qu'elle est vraiment
en incapacité en fait de poursuivre à
travailler si nous étions allés aux
articles 8 et 9 vous auriez pu lui dire
qu'elle pourrait toujours partir bien
avant 64 ans puisque nous bougeons pas
l'âge de départ des gens en incapacité
très bien monsieur
monsieur
Ruffin monsieur Ruffin
s'il vous plaît
il faut être sérieux madame la
rapporteur on est en train de parler de
dizaines de milliers d'auxiliaires de
vie on en parle en train de parler de
chef de rayon en série on est en train
de parler de travailleurs du bâtiment
par milliers et vous ne répondez il va y
avoir un fonds de présentation machin
bidule mais vous croyez qu'il y a une
seule de ces auxiliaires de vie un seul
de ces travailleurs du bâtiment un seul
de ses chefs de rayons qui va vous
croire aujourd'hui vous en fichez vous
êtes plus là pour convaincre de toute
façon mais vous vous imaginez que votre
propos il va il vous manque un numéro
vert dans tout ça mais sinon on a le
reste mais qui va pouvoir croire à cette
histoire là il y a pas un travailleur
qui va y croire vous savez monsieur
décrosailles l'un de vos collègues là il
était en plateau il vient de dire cette
réforme est injuste
repoussez l'âge n'est pas juste mais je
la voterai sans état d'âme quand on en
est à dire bah voilà on sait que c'est
pas juste mais ça se passe
et quand
un sondage
un sondage sort un instant qui demande
aux Français monsieur bazar monsieur
Cyril Isaac
le pays car c'est le seul moyen pour que
le gouvernement retire ou modifie sa
réforme de retraite ça fait 60% et c'est
en hausse de 3%. donc il est très clair
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui bloque le pays
ceux qui empêche le pays d'avancer vers
où il a envie d'aller c'est fou quand il
y a trois quarts des Français qui disent
non c'est non quand il y a 90% des
salariés qui disent non c'est non quand
il y a des millions de manifestants dans
la rue qui disent non c'est non arrêtez
d'être la minorité qui bloque le pays
très bien monsieur jumelles vous avez la
parole et lui seul à la parole s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues
vous avez
s'il vous plaît mes chers
vous avez été les premiers en réformant
le droit du travail a supprimé les
moyens consacrés au CHSCT chargé de
l'hygiène et de la santé au travail vous
avez ensuite dans le même état d'esprit
retranché quatre critères de pénibilité
tellement important que le collègue qui
est derrière moi avait oublié celui des
risques chimiques c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que moi dans un département comme
le mien c'est le maritime les risques
chimiques c'est évidemment une
exposition salariée secondaire
accessoire qu'on oublie très vite et
donc François a raison de dire que
personne ne peut vous croire lorsque
vous prétendez vouloir demain vous en
occuper s'il fait beau s'il ne pleut pas
peut-être par contre ce que nous savons
c'est que si cette mauvaise plateforme
et est adoptée
Angelica et toutes les autres c'est des
tout de suite qu'elles vont en prendre
plein la pomme c'est de tout de suite
qu'elles vont prendre deux enfers c'est
de tout de suite qu'elles vont sans
attendre de voir si les effets de vos
politiques préventives hypothétiques
vont vont vont
prendre effet c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour rassurer notre collègue
qui dit encore 5000 amendements à
examiner que nous vous proposons de
retirer le texte tout de suite voilà de
retirer le texte tout de suite parce que
c'est ce que demande la majorité des
Français c'est ce que réclame 94% des
actifs c'est ce que réclame le front
Unis syndical et vous auriez tort de
vous entêter dans cette salle besogne de
casse du système de retraite par
répartition
très bien monsieur destiny
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voulais juste te dire que je suis très
heureux d'être ici aujourd'hui parce que
ça permet de voir un petit peu le vrai
visage de nos adversaires et en
l'occurrence le vrai visage de la nuque
qui se cache derrière qui se cache alors
bon lundi ils étaient dans la rue là
aujourd'hui ils sont parmi nous c'est
bien mais derrière le fait c'est bien
beau de dire que
75% des Français ne veulent pas de la
réforme mais il y a 70% des Français qui
voudraient un référendum alors moi juste
une question est-ce que vous allez voter
la motion référendaire lundi du
rassemblement national où est-ce que
vous allez être le bourreau qui va
appliquer le sujet monsieur le député
est-ce que vous allez être le bourreau
qui va appliquer les deux enfermes que
vous reprochez aujourd'hui au
gouvernement merci ce n'est pas le sujet
monsieur le député vous venez d'arriver
alors je tiens à vous le dire
alors maintenant je passe la parole à
Madame la rapporteur général sur cet
amendement merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais répondre à Monsieur Ruffin qui
a dit hier que j'étais extrémiste mais
c'est justement peut-être parce que je
suis extrémiste que j'ai envie de
répondre sur ces métiers difficiles dont
vous avez parlé qui peuvent entraîner
notamment des mal de dos oui mais sur
les fins j'ai dit que dans cet article 9
que malheureusement nous n'aurons pas
l'occasion d'examiner nous mettons un
milliard et une somme considérable pour
le fond d'investissement en prévention
qui va permettre de financer aussi des
congés de reconversion mais vous oubliez
de dire et donc c'est aussi peut-être
parce que je suis extrémiste je vais
aller jusqu'au bout et redire que dans
cet article 9 il y a aussi un suivi
médicalisé que ces métiers seront
cartographiés par les branches donc ces
métiers dont vous parlez vont être
reconnus comme métier à risque
ergonomique et permettront là aussi
d'avoir des possibilités soit de partir
plus tôt soit d'un suivi qui permettra
une des jours de reconversion donc il y
a des mesures qu'il faudrait peut-être
enrichir mais nous n'aurons pas
l'occasion en tout cas dans cette
commission de pouvoir aller jusque là
mais voilà donc c'est parce que je suis
extrémiste monsieur Ruffin que je vous
propose d'écouter jusqu'à la fin des
remarques que je peux faire
très bien merci
merci Madame la rapporteur général alors
je mets je vais mettre aux voix donc cet
amendement mes chers collègues qui a
reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté alors mes
chers collègues
à cet instant donc je vais donner
l'heure il est 19h19 il nous reste
4997 amendements
a examiné s'il vous plaît
j'ai été tout ouïe je vous ai écouté
donc écoutez moi
alors donc je disais qu'il nous reste à
examiner 4997 amendements donc environ
4710 de la nupes
et nous avons examiné jusqu'à présent
amendements alors donc en trois oui dans
ces conditions vous conviendrez donc
bien sûr avec moi que on ne pourra pas
aller jusqu'au bout du texte
malheureusement de ce projet de loi
comme vous le savez ce texte est inscrit
à l'ordre du jour donc lundi nous allons
tous nous retrouver pour un marathon de
15 jours
d'ici là bien sûr il faut laisser un
temps à laps de temps pour le dépôt
d'amendement et je vous rappelle que
l'heure c'est 17h demain donc c'est le
délai maximal pour pouvoir fixer
effectivement pour pouvoir déposer vos
amendements je rappelle également
qu'en application de l'article 42 alinéa
1 de la Constitution la discussion d'un
bel effetss porte en séance sur le texte
mais vous le savez sur le texte du
projet de loi déposer sur le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale
inutile bien sûr de vous dire que c'est
avec un grand regret que je fais ce
constat nous nous sommes tout de même
nous nous sommes tout de même réunis
pendant 28 heures
ce qui était au départ largement
suffisant pour examiner un pellet SSR de
20 articles nous n'avons pas abordé le
troisième article mais il y en avait
tout de même 20 et quand on sait que
nous avons pu en tous les cas examiner
le PLFSS qui était constitué de 53
articles nous avons pu l'examiner en 22
heures je regrette donc la manière dont
ce temps a été utilisé et ne nous est
pas permis donc d'aborder certains
certaines thématiques certains enjeux de
fonds dans le cadre de cette réforme et
donc je suis bien sûr
contrainte d'en prendre acte je rappelle
aussi que je n'ai pas compté dans les 28
heures bien sûr nous avons eu la
discussion générale dans le cadre de
l'audition de notre ministre du ministre
du soft également nous avons auditionné
le président du corps monsieur le bras
chaque commissaire chaque groupe a pu
s'exprimer franchement largement
je m'en suis donc tenue au consensus sur
la possibilité d'accorder à chaque
groupe la possibilité bien sûr
d'intervenir sur chaque amendement
j'espère que vous l'aurez souligné
notamment les commissaires de la nups je
tiens à vous dire que dans la commission
des finances c'est un pour un contre et
que là tout le monde s'est exprimé tous
les groupes se sont exprimés sur chaque
amendement donc on ne pourra pas dire
que vous ne vous êtes pas exprimé ou que
je vous ai je suis désolé de vous
le dire
j'en veux pour preuve que nous collègues
donc des différents groupes de la nupes
même s'ils n'ont pas pu défendre les
6194 amendements qu'ils avaient déposés
ont pu en tous les cas prendre part au
débat et pour chaque amendement
pratiquement si on fait la moyenne vous
avez eu 10 minutes d'intervention pour
chaque amendement
la Commission a donc mes chers collègues
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé et bien sûr
on ne peut que déplorer le fait de que
nous allions nous arrêter là cela étant
je veux rendre hommage à notre
rapporteur général Stéphanie ris qui a
répondu qui a répondu de façon de façon
argumentée avec courtoisie précision et
concision je le dis à tout elle a
répondu à tous les commissaires tout
groupe confondus elle a par ailleurs
analysé de façon approfondie les
articles du projet de loi dans le
rapport de la commission qui sera donc
publié d'ici la fin de la semaine
mes chers collègues je remercie aussi
l'ensemble je dis bien je termine si
vous le permettez je vais vous donner la
parole donc
je remercie aussi bien sûr l'ensemble
des membres de la commission et bien sûr
au-delà les très nombreux collègues
d'ailleurs qui sont venus nous rendre
visite dans le cadre de cette commission
puisque tout le monde a été accueilli et
ils se sont également exprimés
longuement et j'espère qu'ils ont
apprécié
d'ici la séance publique chacun qu'il
soit bien sûr parlementaire
syndicalistes journalistes ou citoyen
pourra donc se référer à nos travaux
malgré bien sûr la frustration que nous
partageons d'ailleurs qui s'est aussi
exprimé pendant ces trois jours parce
que nous aurions aimé aller beaucoup
plus loin et bien je pense que quand
même ces débats j'espère en tout cas
seront utiles et notamment aux Français
alors je sais que certains vont vouloir
s'exprimer j'ai vu déjà de nombreuses
mains se lever alors et bien je vais
passer la parole alors dites pas que je
donne la préférence à mais c'est la
première maille qui s'est levée monsieur
Ruffin
madame la Présidente je pense pas qu'on
puisse se féliciter de trois jours de
débats en commission pour deux ans
deux ans fermes en trois jours c'est
évidemment pas suffisant et tous les
textes nous disent que normalement le la
rectificative de un projet de Loiret de
qualificatif de la sécurité sociale doit
pas avoir des mesures de cette ampleur
là donc là nous vous nous faites un
bidouillage pour faire rentrer ça à
l'intérieur on peut pas se satisfaire
que ça ne dure que trois jours pourquoi
il y a pas de prolongé ce soir pourquoi
on va pas jusqu'au vote des amendements
demain 17 jusqu'à au dépôt des
amendements demain 17h pourquoi même on
continue pas à siéger en commission
pendant le temps que les amendements
pour la séance sont examinés ce qui est
tout à fait possible donc là il y a pas
de raison au fond de d'arrêter la
commission ce soir à 19h30 donc nous
nous demandons pour qu'il y ait pas de
frustration ni des citoyens ni des
députés qui peut y avoir une
prolongation évidemment c'est pas une
prolongation c'est en fait la normalité
il y a aucune raison pour que la
Commission s'arrête ce soir à 19 heures
monsieur Ruffin je pense qu'il va y
avoir un certain nombre de d'amendements
qui vont être à nouveau déposés et
Monsieur Ruffin je pense que vous êtes
bien sûr tout à fait sensible à la
qualité du travail vous parliez aussi de
pénibilité tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
va falloir aussi et je les remercie
c'est-à-dire à l'administration du
pouvoir absorber tous les amendements
qui vont être déposés et ça on ne peut
pas non plus être indifférent il y a
effectivement des un horaire à respecter
je pense que au regard des amendements
qui vont être dit déposés jusqu'à 17h de
toute façon monsieur Ruffin nous ne
serions pas allés plus loin voilà il y
avait obstruction vous l'avez dit vous
continuerez à le faire vous ne cherchez
pas à aller plus loin donc je suis
désolé hier il y avait une de vos
collègues qui a dit oui nous sommes dans
l'obstruction donc ne dites pas que
parce que la Commission s'arrête va
s'arrêter à 20h qu'on vous a empêché de
travailler débattre
alors sur ce monsieur
je donne la parole à Monsieur Guedj ou
monsieur Delaporte mettez-vous d'accord
ou alors vous êtes deux minutes deux
minutes
allez-y
je comprends pas bien pourquoi on arrête
une demi-heure avant mais parce que
peut-être pour faire de longs
remerciments mais je remerciement parce
que je m'attende pas à voir des
remerciements de votre part donc
simplement pour vous je remercie
toujours la présidente d'une enceinte
très assemblée dans laquelle nous avons
pu travailler depuis 27 heures et je
veux vous remercier pour votre
présidence parce que vous avez eu à
gérer un collectif humain qui était
passionné à la mesure des enjeux je vais
aussi saluer là la rapporteur mais mais
quand même vous dire que vous parlez de
frustration
notre frustration elle est liée au choix
qui a été fait c'est pas le vôtre de
recourir un PLFSS rectificatif et donc
d'être en serré dans les délais du 47 1
parce que comme je le rappelais tout à
l'heure
lors de la dernière réforme des
retraites certes avorter cette
commission assiégée pendant trois
semaines avec 21600 amendements qui ont
été examinés donc la fois précédente un
choix pour réformer les retraites était
une loi ordinaire qui a permis à la
Commission de ne pas être limité dans le
temps et que donc si donc on a une
frustration et un message à faire porter
c'est que nous aurions pu eu égard
l'importance de
la décision qui pourrait être prise et
qui j'espère ne le sera pas nous aurions
pu légiférer une autre manière et qui
aurait permis d'aborder les 6000
amendements ou les 5000 qui restent
encore aujourd'hui alors on va se
retrouver maintenant dans l'hémicycle et
nous je vous le dis on veut aller
sincèrement au bout de l'examen de cette
réforme parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on
avance dans cette réforme c'est le
syndrome Dracula plus on éclaire les
dispositions de cette réforme plus
exposées à la rumière à la lumière tel
Dracula elle se transforme en poussière
nous le ferons dans l'hémicycle
très bien
donc je passe la parole à Monsieur
jumelles ou monsieur Monet on va faire
les deux on va couper en deux
et je démarrais très rapidement enfin
faut pas nous prendre pour des pour des
lapins de 3 semaines le madame la
Présidente je ne conteste pas le fait
que vous ayez donné la parole je
remarque quand même que nos conditions
de travail dans cette salle n'étaient
vraiment pas approprié et vous saviez
très bien que beaucoup de parlementaires
assisteraient à cette commission vu
l'enjeu du sujet mais le propos le
problème c'est que le propos que vous
avez tenu vous savez pertinemment vous
auriez pu le tenir lundi matin à 9h30
face à une surprise pour personne et de
nous reprocher d'avoir mis des
amendements alors que c'est un texte
important c'est ça qui est pas très
honnête moi je trouve qu'on a travaillé
avec sérieux et trouvez-moi un seul
sujet qui n'a pas été un sujet de fond
dans ce que nous avons porté
très bien non je voudrais juste dire à
Monsieur le Député vous pouvez pas me
faire le reproche de ne pas avoir pu ou
sugérer enfin je veux dire le débat par
rapport à au nombre important de
d'amendements qui ont été déposés enfin
prenez aussi vos responsabilités moi
j'aime bien rendre à César ce qui
appartient à César vous avez déposé
pléthore d'amendement et bien
effectivement après il faut savoir gérer
son temps c'est tout c'est ce que je dis
prenez votre part de responsabilité
d'ailleurs dès le lundi certains de vos
collègues vous ont proposé de retirer
cet amende certains amendements pour que
nous puissions avancer dans le débat
vous ne l'avez pas fait vous ne l'avez
pas entendu maintenant ne faites pas le
reproche en disant vous rendez compte on
n'a pas pu le faire du fait des
mauvaises conditions de la salle etc non
non franchement un peu de sérieux alors
la parole
merci de vous rassurez-vous vous avez
été extraordinaire le président de la
République vous remerciera vous avez été
non non mais j'ai pas d'inquiétude je
vous assure vous avez été bonne élève
mais le problème c'est que depuis le
début les jeux étaient faussés le texte
est injuste il est refusé par la
population le texte utilise un véhicule
législatif un constitutionnel et le
texte était enfermé dans des délais qui
ne permettaient pas son examen jusqu'au
bout par l'Assemblée avec la meilleure
présidence de commission
possible du monde j'allais dire il
n'était pas possible d'avoir un examen
satisfaisant de cet et puis d'autre part
je veux vous rassurer nous avons fait un
travail sérieux mais nous demandons le
retrait de ce texte quel que soit les
amendements adoptés nous demandons le
retrait des deux mesures qui font mal
aux vies et qui font mal aux gens
le report de l'âge de départ et
l'accélération de la mise en oeuvre de
la réforme Touraine qui constitue une
double peine pour la France qui
travaille donc même avec toute votre
bonne volonté même avec j'allais dire
des députés de dossiers les certains qui
le sont moins ce texte mérite d'être
tiré et n'aboutira pas très
bien Madame la rapporteur depuis lundi
matin nous avons étudié en trois jours
que deux articles sur les vins d'un
projet qui est pourtant très important
qui inquiète et il y a beaucoup
d'attentes notamment légitimes je pense
à tous ceux qui ont bossé toute leur vie
et qui ont pourtant des petites pensions
et qu'il faut pouvoir revaloriser c'est
profondément dommage j'aurais aimé qu'on
puisse
travailler sur le fond sur l'ensemble du
texte il nous faut réformer notre
système parce qu'il est menacé pour
diverses raisons et il faut garantir le
niveau de pension demain de nos
retraités sans altérer le pouvoir
d'achat de nos travailleurs c'est une
erreur de le résumer uniquement à une
question financière à une question de
durée à une question d'âge il faut
d'abord créer les conditions pour
restaurer la confiance dans notre
système assurer sa pérennité et ça
passera par la valorisation du travail
et le renouvellement des générations or
le diable se cache dans les détails et à
cette heure le compte n'y est pas moi je
lance un appel pour que le gouvernement
prenne en compte un certain nombre
d'attente qui d'ailleurs ne dépendent
pas que nos bancs et qui peuvent être
partagés pour améliorer la donne parce
qu'il y a des inquiétudes pour prendre
en compte davantage les carrières on ne
prend pour prendre en compte les
indépendants aux petites pensions qu'ils
ont derrière complète pour prendre en
compte les mères de famille qui
travaillent et un vrai sujet sur le taux
d'emploi des mères de famille il faut
qu'on puisse ne pas reporter se débat ce
chantier sur les droits conjugaux sur
les droits familiaux à un chantier du
corps il faut qu'on s'en en parle d'ores
et déjà il faut aussi qu'on crée les
conditions pour améliorer le taux
d'emploi non seulement des seniors mais
aussi des jeunes un dernier aspect qui
est totalement absent du texte on l'a
dit depuis plusieurs semaines c'est la
question des fraudes les gens
comprennent qu'il peut y avoir des
efforts mais il faut qu'il soit juste et
surtout qu'il n'y ait pas des pensions
qui soient versées indument à l'étranger
parfois des personnes qui ont dépassé
100 ans je crois que c'est important de
retravailler sur tous ces sujets afin
d'améliorer profondément le texte et de
le rendre acceptable équilibré et juste
très bien merci monsieur le député
monsieur le député Mathieu
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ce qui intéresse les ouvriers
les salariés les gens qui peinent c'est
d'abord le report de l'âge de départ à
la retraite et pas des querelles
byzantines sur des index dont tout le
monde se moque enfin pas tout le monde
la nupette visiblement ça l'a passionne
sa satisfait peut-être son électorat de
Bobo mais les classes populaires et
moyennes que nous représentons au
rassemblement national seront dépités si
elles ont regardé nos échanges et je
tiens d'ailleurs à remercier les
administrateurs d'avoir fait face à
l'incontinence législative de la nupes
alors maintenant il y a une solution
très facile celle de rendre la parole au
peuple ça tombe bien lundi il y a une
motion au référendaire alors mes chers
collègues de la nupesse vous qui êtes si
dessert si fort en thème pourriez-vous
pour une fois être efficace il a voté
lundi chacun assumera ses
responsabilités et chacun assumera les
conséquences de exact
monsieur Lucas
merci même la Présidente chers collègues
de la majorité relative il y a votre
éthique parlementaire et la nôtre notre
responsabilité à nous puisque le terme
responsabilité beaucoup revenu c'était
de faire entrer ici dans cette
commission des affaires sociales la voix
de ces 72% de français c'est 9 actifs
sur 10 qui vivent votre réforme pour se
caler comme une injustice une incroyable
brutalité c'était de faire entendre ici
la voix des 2,8 millions de personnes
qui sont mobilisés hier et des 8700
personnes qui ont manifesté à Annonay
dans la ville du ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et du retournement de veste
Olivier du sobre c'était de faire
entendre la voix de celles et ceux qui
demandent exigent le retrait de cette
réforme ce n'était pas comme le
rassemblement national de venir ici
témoigner ou comme l'a fait Marine Le
Pen ce matin la télévision de ne
trouvait rien de mieux à faire en plein
mouvement social que d'insulter les
organisations syndicales Unies et
déterminée dans cette mobilisation et
qui elle savent pourquoi elles se
battent puis il y a eu votre dans le
sens du combat parlementaire et
plusieurs points qui se suivent sa forme
une ligne je dis nous nous avons déposé
vous critiqué le nombre d'amendements
autant d'amendements qu'il y a de
souffrance engendrés par cette réforme
difficultés de situations difficiles de
vie briser déchirées et nous recevons
chaque jour les témoignages engendré par
cette réforme et vous plusieurs points
qui se suivent sa forme une ligne c'est
la ligne du passage en force parce que
vous sentez bien que vous êtes obligé
d'aller vite parce que votre majorité
relative est en train de devenir
minorité absolue on lit chaque jour dans
la presse des témoignages vous avez donc
choisi de nous imposer une salle trop
petite trois jours de suite alors que
des conditions de travail satisfaisantes
aurait été possible vous avez choisi de
ne pas accorder de ne pas accorder le
temps suffisant le temps suffisant pour
un débat de qualité vous avez choisi en
conférence des présidents une
entourloupe rassemblement national la
motion référendaire chers collègues
chers collègues votre haine de la nuit
pèse vous conduit à tout brûler sur
votre passage je vous invite et je
termine madame la Présidente face à un
pays qui n'est pas structuré un pays qui
est unique contre votre réforme des
retraites s'il vous plaît monsieur
Christophe vous avez vous avez la parole
oui merci madame je crois que notre
collègue aurait besoin d'urgence une
mise au vert parce que fatalement la
Commission ne le satisfait pas en tout
cas pas franchement il y a aucune
surprise dans ce qui se passe vous
faites même pitié finalement excusez-moi
du terme vous vous offusquez de ne pas
avoir assez de temps pour aller jusqu'au
bout du débat mais vous foutez du monde
c'est pas possible regardez le nombre
d'un moment vous avez déposé depuis le
début vous êtes sur une stratégie
d'obstruction
assumez-le c'est tout il y a pas de
honte vous avez voulu qu'on respecte vos
débats parlementaires votre travail
parlementaire nous l'avons fait nous
avons écouté tous vos amendements nous
avons aussi la portée de la
contradiction quand elle pouvait encore
s'entendre mais en soi ne surjouez pas
votre rôle si vous plaît les Français
attendent autre chose d'un débat
parlementaire que la mesquinerie à
laquelle vous obtenez et les insultes
que vous pouvez voter d'un ministre
chers collègues je vous appelle un peu
plus de raison parce que la semaine
prochaine nous ouvrirons deux semaines
de débat deux semaines d'air oui c'est
factuel mais vous connaissiez la règle
du jeu avant l'heure vous saviez très
exactement combien de jours nous aurions
pour travailler on a toujours su
exagiminer des PLFSS dans le télé ici
dans le respect des uns et des autres et
ça c'est toujours bien passé voilà vous
avez choisi une illustratégie mais il y
a aucun mal à l'assumer mais devenu pas
nous reprocher d'avoir fait en sorte que
le débat se passe pas correctement il a
été je remercie la présidence d'avoir
conduit ces débats comment ils ont été
conduits et de vous donner rendez-vous
lundi pour un débat apaisé reposez-vous
bien
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur Sylvain Maillard
merci
merci madame la Présidente
cette réforme cette réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme des formes
c'est une réforme d'effort pour les
Français qui le peuvent de travailler
deux ans de plus mais c'est une réforme
qui garantit pour l'ensemble des
Français un niveau de pension
probablement le plus haut de toutes les
pays d'occidentaux et qui garantit à
long terme c'est pour ça que nous
présentons cette réforme revaloriser les
petites pensions on en met pas parlé
dans ces 28 heures de débats 28 heures
de blocage on a même pas pu en parler
revaloriser les petites pensions
qu'est-ce qu'on a parlé de d'amendement
les plus farfelues 6500 amendements les
plus farfelus contradictoires votre
bilan mais si on en a on en a voté un
c'est l'abonnement
l'amendement que vous avez choisi vous
avez voté un cadeau pour les retraités
les plus aisés c'est celui-là votre
amendement dont vous gargarisez d'avoir
choisi vous êtes incohérent vous avez
parlé pendant 28 heures de taxes
supplémentaires d'IMP en plus de droits
la paresse de détestation du travail
voilà ce dont vous avez parlé pendant 28
heures
votre bilan
vous n'aimez vous n'aimez ni le travail
ni la démocratie
mes chers collègues la seule bonne
nouvelle il vous reste 4 jours 4 jours
pour revoir votre copie en hémicycle
très bien bon mes chers collègues mes
chers collègues sur sur ce je vous
souhaite bien sûr une bonne fin de
semaine et on se retrouve lundi à 15h45